WITH NINETEEN EMERGENCY. AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC THE
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING CHICKEN IN HERE TO
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE BORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE REMITTED MEMBERS. OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS HELLO
ALL AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE. IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE. SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE TWO AT. SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE TWO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE BEEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESSED
IS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IT. ANNUAL BILL
ABOUT NOW BE READY TO ADDRESS
TO COMMITTEE. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE OUR HEARING OF ALL
BILLS ON OUR SCHEDULE. AFTER
THE INITIAL WITNESS IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION HAVE SPOKEN WE
WILL LIMIT PUBLIC COMMENT TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE THAT'S
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE THAT
YOU'RE USING AND WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU. AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. IN THE MEANTIME I
WHICH I WILL TRY TO MAINTAIN AS
ALWAYS TO QUORUM DOESN'T ALWAYS
WORK- AS CUSTOMARY AND- ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS TERMINATED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINING HIRING PROCESS AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IT
CLOSED TO AS A SAME MANNER ASK
IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
ONLINE TOOLS. OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. TODAY WE
HAVE NINE BILLS ON THE AGENDA
THREE OF WHICH ARE SHUT FOR
CONSENT. BEFORE WE HEAR OF- THE
PRESENTATION FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR OR ASK THE CONSULTANT TO
ASSIST OBSTACLE. HE'S HEADFORD
YOUR RECORD HERE TO A BOGUS COM
LONGER HERE KAMLAGER HERE THE
JOB BOTH OF. AB TROUBLE CARE
COM LONGER HERE KAMLAGER HERE
SKINNER SKINNER HERE WIENER
QUORUM IS PRESENT MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT- LET'S FIRST
DISPOSABLE ARE A CONCERN
GALLAGHER IS THERE A MOTION
FOR. OUR CONSENT ITEMS. HE
REMOVED FIVE SENATORS.
AMERICANS. ARTEM ARE. SB SIX TO
NINE BY RALPH S. B. FOUR FOUR
SIX BY GLAZER. AND S. B. FOUR
SEVEN TWO BY CAVALEIRO. MENEM
FILTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ARE
CONCERNED IN ORDER CONSENT
CALENDAR CALENDAR BRADFORD ON
BRADFORD AYE INTO A BOAT HI
JOBO GUY COME LONGER HIGH I'M
LIKE- ICE SKINNER. SKINNER I.
WIENER. WALDRON WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND NOW WILL MOVE TO
OUR FORGE. ZERO EARNED WE HAVE
SENATOR CORTESE AND HE'S
PRESERVING S. B. THREE HUNDRED
CENTER WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
SENATORS SLAM TODAY I'M HERE.
TO PRESENT SB THREE HUNDRED THE
SENTENCING REFORM ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SENSING SOMEONE TO
DIE IN PRISON WITH THE BY THE
DEATH PENALTY OR BY LIFE
WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE SO WHAT. IS VIRTUALLY
UNHEARD OF. IN MUCH OF THE
WORLD. CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY
REGULARLY IMPOSES THE SENTENCES
BUT REQUIRES JUDGES. TO IMPOSE
THEM FOR CERTAIN CATEGORIES OF
OFFENSES EVEN ON DEPENDENTS WHO
DID NOT KILL NOR INTEND FOR
PERSON TO BE KILLED. CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW MANDATES A
SENTENCE. OF DEATH WIFE THE
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE FOR
ANYONE CONVICTED OF MURDER
ESPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES. EVEN IF
THE PERSON DID NOT KILL ANYONE
NOR INTEND FOR ANYONE TO DIE
UNDER CURRENT LAW. IF A PERSON
DIES DURING THE COURSE OF
CERTAIN FELONIES. EVEN IF THE
DEATH IS ACCIDENTAL THOSE WERE
INVOLVED IN THE PHONE OR
SUBJECT TO BE SEVERE
PUNISHMENTS REGARDLESS OF THE
ROLE IN THE PERSON'S DEATH
THROUGH THEIR INTENT.
ADDITIONALLY FOR ALL CRIMES IN
THE SENTENCING SCHEME. IF ANY
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES FOUND
TRUE. THE JUDGE HAS NO CHOICE.
BUT TO SENTENCE A PERSON TO
DEATH WELL WHAT. CURRENT LAW
FORBIDS THE JUDGE FROM
CONSIDERING WHETHER THESE
PUNISHMENTS ARE FAIR IN ANY
GIVEN CASE. THE MANDATED
MINIMUM IS TO DIE BEHIND PRISON
WALLS. WITHOUT ANY MEANS OF
EARNING PAROLE. THE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES SENTENCING SCHEME
REFLECTS THE WORST TENDENCIES
WITHIN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN OVERWHELMINGLY
IMPACTS PEOPLE OF COLOR. FOR
EXAMPLE MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF
PEOPLE SERVING A WALK
CALIFORNIA. ARE BLACK OR BROWN
IN THE VAST MAJORITY HAD NO
PRIOR CRIMINAL RECORD BEFORE
BEING SENTENCED TO DIE IN
PRISON. MOST WERE UNDER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF AGE AT THE TIME
OF THE OFFENCE. IN THE AVERAGE
AGE OF THOSE SUCH SENTENCED IS
NINETEEN YEARS OLD CURRENTLY.
DECADES OF RESEARCH HAS FAILED
TO SHOW ANY PUBLIC SAFETY
BENNETT BENEFIT. M. L. WHAT FOR
THE DEATH PENALTY ON THE
CONTRARY SEVERE PUNISHMENTS
LIKE THESE HAVE DRIVEN THE MASS
INCARCERATION CRISIS THAT IS
DESTROYING LIVES FAMILIES AND
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE LONG BEEN DEPRIVED OF
SUPPORT OF INVESTMENTS AND
PROGRAMS WERE BEING TARGETED.
BY POLICING RACISM AND
OPPRESSION. SB THREE HUNDRED
WOULD SEEK TO FIX THIS
OVERSIGHT IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM BY PREVENTING
SOMEONE. WHO IS NOT THE ACTUAL
KILLER. IT DOESN'T HAVE AN
INTENT TO KILL FROM BEING
PUNISHED IN THIS WAY. BY DEATH
OR LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE.
ADDITIONALLY SB THREE HUNDRED
CREATE A PROCEDURE FOR THOSE
PREVIOUSLY CONVICTED UNDER THE
SENSING SCHEME. TO PETITION THE
COURT FOR RESENTENCING. MY
WITNESSES HERE TODAY OUR SYSTEM
IMPACTED INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEEPLY COMPELLING STORIES- HERE
TO TESTIFY IS TO ENSURE THE
FOUNDER OF THE FELONY MURDER
ELIMINATION PROJECT. I AM ALSO
AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY. WE'RE
HERE TO TESTIFY IS TAMMY COOPER
CARBON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS.
ADDITIONALLY NATASHA MINSKER IS
ON THE LINE BUT TO ANSWER ANY
LEGAL OR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AND COMMUNITY HEALTH. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU NOW
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AGAIN WE'LL GIVE OUR
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES A TOTAL
OF FOUR MINUTES SUCH TWO APIECE
AND WE WILL START WITH
CHALLENGE HERE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIRTEEN AND A HALF
YEARS AGO MY ONLY CHILD TONY
WAS CONVICTED OF FIRST DEGREE
MURDER UNDER THE FELONY MURDER
RULE AND SENTENCED TO LIFE IN
PRISON WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF PAROLE. TWENTY WITH THE
COMPASSIONATE OUTGOING KID WHO
MADE FRIENDS EASILY HE'D NEVER
BEEN IN TROUBLE HE JUST TURNED
TWENTY YEARS OLD WHEN HE JOINED
THE U. S. MARINE CORPS AND HE
WAS PROUD TO BE SERVING HIS
COUNTRY. EVEN IN THE FACE OF
CERTAIN DEPLOYMENT TO IRAQ. ON
SUNDAY AFTERNOON AFTER A DAY OF
DRINKING AND WATCHING FOOTBALL
OF HIS FELLOW MARINES APARTMENT
TWENTY WHAT WITH TWO OTHERS TO
RETRIEVE A PERSONAL LAPTOP
COMPUTER. WHICH HAD BEEN SOLD
BUT NOT PAID FOR TRAGICALLY
WHEN ASKED FOR THE LAPTOP BACK
ONE OF THE GUYS TONY WHICH
WITH. WHO HAD COULD CHANGE THE
SEVERE BRAIN INJURY DURING A
TOUR IN IRAQ BECAME ANGRY THAT
THE YOUNG MAN QUOTE WAS NOT
FOLLOWING A DIRECT ORDER PULLED
THE GUN OUT OF HIS WAISTBAND
AND SHOT AND KILLED HIM. SHE IS
YOUNG MAN COMPULSIVE REACTION
DURING AN ATTEMPT TO RETRIEVE A
LAPTOP WHICH CHARACTERIZED BY
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF
BURGLARY WHICH ENABLED THE DA
TO CHARGE ALL THREE YOUNG MEN
INCLUDING MY SON. WITH FELONY
MURDER SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
DESPITE. THEIR RESPECTIVE
INVOLVEMENT. THE DEATHS THAT
OCCUR BECAUSE THIS YOUNG
DECISION WHICH RBI THE TRACK. I
IN MY HAVE BEEN SET TO DEATH
WITH MY- EVERY WEEKEND IN
HOLLOW CHRIS YEARS HAS BEEN IN
A PRISON VISITING ROOM WITH MY
ONLY CHILD. WILL TREAT EVERY
MINUTE OF DISTANCE WITH HIM
UNTIL WE DIE EACH OF US ALONE.
BEST HAVE BROUGHT UNIMAGINABLE
GRIEF NOT ONLY TO THE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS OF THIS YOUNG MAN
WHITE RIVER SYMPATHIZE WITH BUT
ALSO TO MY SON AND OUR FAMILY.
SH TWENTY HAD NO ABILITY TO
FIRST SEE OR CONTROL THE ACTION
TAKEN BY ANOTHER QUESTION TONY
DID NOT HARM OR INTENT TO HARM
ANYONE. IF WE DON'T CHANGE
THESE UNJUST LAWS I WILL NEVER
AGAIN SEE MY SON OUTSIDE OF A
PRISON VISITING ROOM. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR YES
SO. THANK YOU MOVING ON NOW TO.
MISTERI COOPER CARBON. HELLO
I'M HERE IN THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TAMMY COOPER BARBARA
THOMAS OF COURSE READY FOR
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS SINCE HER
FIRST SURVIVING SEX TRAFFICKING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHEN I WAS
THIRTY TWO YEARS OLD I WAS
CHARGED AS AN ACCOMPLICE IN THE
FELONY MURDER CASE AND
SENTENCED TO LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE FOR A CRIME THAT MARK
HUGHES ARE COMMITTED I HAD NO
INTENT TO HURT ANYBODY AND DID
NOT KILL ANYBODY AND EVERYONE
INCLUDING THE D. A NEW IT. I
WAS ONLY FOURTEEN YEARS OLD
WHEN I WAS SIX TRAFFIC AND BY
THE TIME I WAS SENTENCED TO DIE
IN PRISON AT AGE THIRTY SIX I
HAD ALREADY SUFFERED DECADES OF
ABUSE I WAS THIRTY TWO YEARS
OLD WHEN MY LATEST ABUSER
PRESSURED ME INTO SAYING WOULD
TO MY CLIENT HE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO LIVE I DROVE HIM TO THE
SCENE AND WAITED IN THE CAR
WHEN YOU SEE MY CABLES TAKING
HIM TOO LONG TO RETURN I WANTED
TO THE BILLION REALIZED. THAT
HE HAD KILLED THE MAN.
TERRIFYING COOLEY TRAUMATIZE
SEVERIN FROM THE SCENE WITH HIM.
YOU MIGHT BE USED TO BRIDGE
WITH MURDER THE SENATE COUNTY
DA YOU KNOW MURDER WILL TO TRY
TO IS EQUALLY RESPONSIBLE EVEN
THOUGH I DO MURDER MAN OR
INTENT FOR A TO BE IN ANY WAY.
BUT FACING TRIAL MY ABUSER
THREATENED TO KILL ME AND MY
FATHER IF WE TESTED AGAINST HIM
I BELIEVE HIM BECAUSE I HAD
SEEN SOMEONE DIE AT HIS HANDS.
EVEN THOUGH MY ABUSER HAD MADE
IT TO MY FATHER THAT HE
COMMITTED THE MURDER THE POLICE
BOTCHED THE HANDLING OF THE
EVIDENCE WE WERE UNABLE TO
TESTIFY. USUALLY TO TESTIFY FOR
FEAR FOR OUR LIVES AND HE. WAS
ACQUITTED OF THE MURDER. DURING
MY TERM MY TO THE NIGHT NINETY.
THE COURT. ALL OF THEM. I
EXPERIENCED BY TRACK AND-
INCLUDING MARKERS ABUSER. WHO
THEY KNEW THEM. BECAUSE I WOULD
A BLACK WOMAN WITH A CREAM
RECORD PROCESS. ACROSS CHARGES
IT WAS THE CHARGES IT WAS
EASIER TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
ME AND PULLING ME FOR SOMEONE
ELSE AND VIOLENCE. THESE
BACKWARD LAWS TO TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS OF MY LIFE. I MADE THE
BEST OF IT AND WORK HARD TO
HELP OTHER SURVIVORS OF
TRAFFICKING. AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN PRISON. I WAS
COMMUTED BY GOVERNOR BROWN INTO
EIGHTEEN THANK. WHAT DO WHY I
CAN BE HERE. BUT THAT IS NOT A
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM. I
LIVE SO MANY WOMEN IN PRISON
CORPS SERVING LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE SENTENCES FOR SOMEONE
ELSE'S VIOLENCE. WE NEED TO
REFORM THIS TERRIBLE LAW SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WAS AN
IMPORTANT STEP BUT I WASN'T
ELIGIBLE BECAUSE I WAS SERVING
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE. WE NEED A
THREE HUNDRED TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT SENTENCED TO DIE
FOR OTHER PEOPLE'S ACTIONS. THE
SUIT WE SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEX TRAFFICKING LIKE ME TO
HELP PREVENT OTHERS OF MY
RESEARCH FACING DEATH IN
PRISON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THAT CONCLUDES OUR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES NOW WILL GO TO
CALLERS WHO WISH TO TOPPLE OVER
COME TO THIS ROOM. ARE THERE.
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE HUNDRED.
SHE NO ONE COMING FORWARD LET'S
NOW MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT SEEN NO ONE THERE. NOW-MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES. AND LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE HUNDRED
MODERATOR PLEASE. THANK YOU I
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE
ONE FILED BY ZERO. WE ARE
GETTING A NUMBER QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT. OUR FIRST SCHOOL-
PERSON WILL BE LINE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND SIXTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. PLEASE ON
THE LINE SIXTY EIGHT. GOING
GOING GONE. OKAY NEXT WE WILL
GO TO LINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING GOING
BACK IS FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION AND DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE. WITH PERMISSION TO
CHAIR OF MY TO READ LIST OF
SUPPORTERS TO AVOID A NUMBER OF
ME TOOS LEAVES CONSOLIDATED- AS
A LIST. IN SUPPORT GOING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE SAN DIEGO
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO SURVIVED
AND PUNISHED THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS THING EIGHTY TIME
FOR CHANGE FOUNDATION TOGETHER
WE WILL INDIVISIBLE UFCW
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL ON
COMMON LAW VOICES OF PROGRESS
WE THE PEOPLE SAN DIEGO WHITE
PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES IN THE
PAST. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALL. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE- SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIXTY PLEASE PUT
YOURSELF BACK IN Q. AND. I WILL
GO TO ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SUDDENLY
CONSCIOUS WITH MILLER BUT IT'S
AN ASSOCIATE'S- ON BEHALF OF
RESTORE JUSTICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORTER SB THREE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO TO
LIKE SIXTY SIX- GIVING YOU
CALLING FROM THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ON YOUR
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU. BY
TWENTY THREE YOU ARE UP. THANK
YOU IN THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ANNE L. THURN ABOUT
THE POLLUTION IN THE BUSINESS
BACKGROUND CONFIDENCE HAVE A
LIST OF OTHER ON SUPPORTERS
SPRING COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
THE CALIFORNIA HILLS PROJECT
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH INDIVISIBLE
FAMILIES THAT DON'T INDIVISIBLE
YOU YELLOW INITIATIVES AFTER
LEGAL AND WORK NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER FORTY YOUR
PLACE FOR GREAT. NOTED OF THE
COMMUNITY SAN DIEGO PRISON
POLICY INITIATIVE CRIED INTO
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE THE
CALIFORNIA WE NINE FAMILY
CONTRA COSTA RIGHT THAT PROTECT
OUR JUSTICE CALIFORNIA SOCIAL
JUSTICE MINISTRY OF LIVE OAK
UNITARIAN UNIVERSALIST
CONGREGATION. BIRDS BAY AREA
ANSWERS REMAIN SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL DENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL. YOU WE
WILL GO TO LINE THIRTY TWO GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY IS ANDREA
CALLING HIM. HI MY THIRTY TWO
INCLUDES AND WAS RELEASED UNDER
THE SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
AND I AM VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AS ARE YOU KNOW WE
THAT ARE IN HER. UNDER THE L.
WALK. THAT SHOULD NOT THERE WHO
DID NOT COMMIT CRIME SO AND DID
NOT ALWAYS EACH AND- BECAUSE
THE MORE ELSE BY IN WHOLE. VERY
IMPROVE LIFE ABOUT AND I HIGHLY
THIS BILL I THINK YOU VERY.
THANK YOU. WE WILL EIGHTY SO
PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
CANDACE CHáVEZ WILL SEND
WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA MY
HUSBAND WHO WANTED TO MIL
WILSON STRATTON'S Q. L. WALKS
OF TWENTY SIX YEARS REPEATED
COMMUNICATION UNDER GOVERNOR
BROWN I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU FOR THIS. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE A TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
FOUR CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS CHRISTINA MENDOZA I'M WITH A
FELONY MURDER LIMITATION
PROJECT WITH THE TRUTH
COMMISSION I'D LIKE TO READ THE
CONTENT WITH THE COALITION.
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET DROP A LOT
COALITION I'LL LET BAKER
CENTER. FELONY MURDER
ELIMINATION PROJECT FAMILIES
UNITED TO END A LOT. SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG ALAMEDA COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE. ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA.
ASIAN SOLIDARITY COLLECTIVE
BEND THE ARC CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. CALIFORNIA
SIX FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
COMMUNITY OF UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE YOUTH JUSTICE
COMMUNITY HEALTH COUNCILS. URGE
CALIFORNIA. YOUR CALIFORNIA
DREAMS CORPS JUSTICE. AND FAIR
CHANCE PROJECT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONE PLEASE. I NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE ZERO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE ONE. MADERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WHAT LINE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LEVINE ALONG WE WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY NINE. MY NAME IS LIZA
LUNA FROM THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MY LOVED ONE HAS SPENT
TWENTY THREE YEARS INCARCERATED
DUE TO FELONY MURDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. NINE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FORTY
NINE IF YOU'D LIKE TO RE QUEUE
I THINK YOU MIGHT TO TAKE
YOURSELF OUT WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ERIN
THERE'S SOME UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS COMBAT VETERAN IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
SIX. HI MY NAME IS HEY WHAT ARE
THE NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. WE WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE ONE ZERO SEVEN
ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE OF SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. ARE
YOU NEEDED. MOVING ALONG WITH A
LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THIS IS COLIN WELLS I AM
REPRESENTING VETERANS WALK AND
TALK ON THE U. S. ARMY INFANTRY
VETERAN AND I SUPPORT. SB THREE
HUNDRED WHOLEHEARTEDLY THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SIXTY NINE PLEASE ON MUTE. FIND
SIXTY NINE YOU ARE UP. ONLY ONE
WILL GO TO ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
YOLANDA NEVER READY AND I HAVE
BEEN INSTRUCTED NEVER READY
HERE THIRD TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
DUE TO FELONY MURDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES POPULOUS STATE
OVER TWO MILLION DOLLARS. I
REQUEST FOR YOUR- STRONG. SORRY
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
PLEASE THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE NINETY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. MY. NINETY NINE. OKAY- I
WILL ALIGN ONE ZERO SEVEN ONE
OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING DANNECKER UPON ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MOVED TO
OAKLAND FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA MY HUSBAND HAS BEEN
TWENTY TWO YEARS AND CAR
STRAIGHT TO CALL THE MURDER
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO
TO. ONE MOMENT THERE COUPLE
MORE QUEUING UP AT THIS POINT.
WHY NINETY FIVE WE JUST TOOK
YOU PLEASE ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT
WEEK PARTICIPANTS.
BUT YOU
DON'T WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU
REAP PROMPTED ONE SECOND HERE.
CLEAR OUT THE QUEUE I'M SORRY
ONE SECOND. SO AGAIN LATEST
GERMAN TO OUR QUEUE UP PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE'LL
TRY LINE SIXTY NINE AGAIN
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIXTY NINE.
YEAH NOT SURE MANDATE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE A NUMBER QUEUING UP
ONE SECOND PLEASE. MONTEREY CAN
YOU GIVE ME A SEVEN OF NUMBER
FOLKS YOU HAVE IN Q. AT THIS
POINT WE HAVE THE LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S ABOUT TEN QUEUING UP.
FOUR MINUTES LEFT. ONE SECOND
PLEASE. HI. YEAH.
OKAY NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE ONE
ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. VERY
MY FIANCE SPENT THIRTEEN AND A
HALF YEARS INCARCERATED DUE TO
FELONY MURDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU I
WOULD MIX WITH A LIME ONE ZERO
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE NINE.
ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE EXPLAINING AS WITH
THE INTELLIGENT OF THEM
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE HUNDRED THANK. THANK YOU
ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD MORNING THIS IS-
MARLON THE DRAWDOWN FROM SAN
FERNANDO CALIFORNIA AND
ACTIVISTS IN A MOTHER OF TWO
TEENAGERS AND I AM CALLING TO
STRONG SUPPORTER L. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE FOURTEEN. HI MY NAME IS
LEADER IDEALS MY LOVE ONE SPENT
EIGHT YEARS DUE TO THE FELONY
MURDER CIRCUMSTANCES I URGE YOU
ALL TO SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
FORTY YOU ARE OPEN. ONE FORTY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
GOING ON WITH THE LINE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS LUCAS MARTIN AFTER A CAR
DOWN A TREATMENT CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MUCH AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME INTERNET
GLENDALE. I WAS JUST RELEASED
AFTER SIXTEEN AND A HALF YEARS
THANKS TO SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THREE HUNDRED. SO THAT THE REST
OF OUR LADIES AND MEN CAN COME
HOME THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWELVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS GINA LOBIONDO
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA MY
LOVED ONE HAS SPENT TWENTY
YEARS OF INCARCERATION DUE TO
FELONY MURDER CIRCUMSTANCES I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU WILL ASISTIR TOMORROW ONE
MORE TIME AND THEN- WILL MOVE
ON WE'RE TO OPPOSITION. THE
FINAL REMINDER ONE ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND MISTER KERR WE DO
HAVE JUST A COUPLE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE'RE DOWN TO TWO
MINUTES SO LET'S MAKE SURE THIS
IS. THEY'RE READY TO GO. I
COULD CANCEL OUT HERE. THERE IS
NOBODY ELSE CURATORS TYPE THANK
YOU BUT THEMSELVES OUT OR WERE
MOVING NOW TO OPPOSITION WE
HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO IT SB THREE
HUNDRED IT'S JOHN BROUGH ARE-
YOU PREPARED FOR HIS TESTIMONY
AT THIS POINT. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN PRO HARD I'M AN ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WE URGE A NO VOTE
ON SB THREE HUNDRED. THIS BILL
ELIMINATES SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR FELONY MURDER
UNLESS THE PROSECUTION CAN
PROVE THAT THE DEFENDANT WAS
THE ACTUAL KILLER. OR ACTED
WITH THE EXPRESS INTENT TO KILL.
IT BEARS REMINDING OF THE TYPES
OF CASES WHERE DEFENDANTS ARE
SUBJECT TO FELONY MURDER
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE FINDING
EVEN WHERE THE PROSECUTION IS
UNABLE TO PROVE WHETHER THE
DEFENDANT WAS THE ACTUAL
KILLER. OR ACTED WITH INTENT TO
KILL. THESE CASES OFTEN ARISE
WERE VICTIMS ARE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED BY MULTIPLE
PERPETRATORS. CONSIDER A CASE
FOR TWO DEFENDANTS KIDNAPPED
AND BRUTALLY SEXUALLY ASSAULT
THE VICTIM. ONE PERPETRATOR
THEN KILLS THE VICTIM. THE
PROSECUTION IS OFTEN IN THE
POSITION OF BEING UNABLE TO
PROVE WHICH DEFENDANT WAS THE
ACTUAL KILLER. OR THAT THE NON
KILLER HAD EXPRESSED INTENT TO
KILL. THAT IS ONE REASON WHY
THE VOTERS ENACTED PROPOSITION
ONE FIFTEEN. TO ENSURE THAT
MAJOR PARTICIPANTS IN VIOLENT
FELONIES. ACTING WITH RECKLESS
INDIFFERENCE TO HUMAN LIFE.
COULD BE APPROPRIATELY PUNISHED
FOR SUCH A VICIOUS MURDERS. THE
RETROACTIVE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL ARE TOO BROAD. IF HE
PREVIOUSLY SENTENCED DEFENDANT
CONVINCES A JUDGE TO DISMISS
THE FELONY MURDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT SAME
DEFENDANT WILL BE ENTITLED TO
RESENTENCING ON ALL OTHER
CHARGES. AT A MINIMUM THIS BILL
SHOULD LIMIT RELIEF TO THE
FELONY MURDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE AT ISSUE. IT
SHOULD PROVIDE THAT NO OTHER
CRIMES SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES OR
ENHANCEMENTS ARE SUBJECT TO BE
SENTENCING. THIS BILL ALSO GOES
TOO FAR. IT ALLOWS A JUDGE TO
DISMISS ANY SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE FUNDING NOT JUST
ONE BASED UPON FELONY MURDER.
THE AUTHORED KNOWLEDGES THAT
THIS PROVISION IS INTENDED TO
FACILITATE REQUESTS BY A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO RECOMMEND
RESENTENCING ON SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE MURDERS PURSUANT
TO PENAL CODE SECTION ELEVEN
SEVENTY SUBSECTION D. THE
VOTERS ALREADY SPOKE LOUDLY ON
THIS ISSUE WITH THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION ONE FIFTEEN. WHEN
THEY SAID THAT SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE FINDINGS MAY NOT
BE DISMISSED. AND THEY DECLARED
QUOTE THE RIGHTS OF CRIME
VICTIMS ARE TOO OFTEN IGNORED
BY OUR COURTS EMPIRE STATE
LEGISLATURE UNQUOTE. FOR THE
MOST SERIOUS CRIME IN OUR STATE
THAT IS FIRST DEGREE MURDER
UNDER SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
CRIME VICTIMS END OF VOTERS
DESERVE A SYSTEM WERE FINE NOW
THE OF JUDGMENTS ARE RESPECTED.
AND NOT SUBJECT TO SECOND
GUESSING DECADES LATER. WE
OPPOSED PASSAGE OF THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
NOW WILL GO TO WITNESSES
WANTING TO TESTIFY HERE AND
ROOM FORTY TWO ALL THREE. I
DON'T SEE A HERD OF FOLKS GOING
TO THE MICROPHONE SO THERE'S NO
ONE HERE LET'S GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM TWENTY FORTY. I
DON'T SEE ANYONE THERE EITHER
MISTER MODERATOR CAN WE GOT OUR
PHONE LINES INTO IF THERE'S
ANYONE QUEUED UP IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE HUNDRED. PINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY THERE'S
ONE QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
W. WITH US ONE MOMENT. ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO THE BILL
AND PRINT THANKS. FOR ANYBODY
ELSE IF YOU LIKE TO CURE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MISTER
CARELESS NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS AS IT
RELATES TO THAT SPEED THREE
HUNDRED SENATOR WEAH. THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED TO SENATORS
SCANNER. THANK YOU CHAIR I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL- CALIFORNIA
IS A VERY INTERESTING STATE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUR TRENDS IN
INCARCERATION RATES IN OUR
TRENDS IN THE LIFE SENTENCES
THE SIGNING OF LIFE SENTENCES.
JUST UNDER FORTY PERCENT. OF
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE SERVING SOME
FORM OF A LIFE SENTENCE FORTY
PERCENT. NOW IF YOU COMPARE
THAT FOR EXAMPLE TO ARKANSAS
AND MISSISSIPPI. ONLY 15% OF
THEIR PRISON POPULATION HAS
LICENSES AND IF YOU THINK WELL
MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE MORE OF
THEM HAVE BEEN GIVEN A DEATH
SENTENCE NO CALIFORNIA EXCEEDS
BOTH OF THOSE STATES IN TERMS
OF. THE- PROVIDING OF A DEATH
SENTENCE SO. JUST FROM A
PROPORTIONALITY WE HAVE FAR
MORE PEOPLE. WHO WE SENTENCED
FOR LIFE. NOW OR THE CRIME
RATES IN TERMS OF THE MOST
HEINOUS CRIMES WORST IN OUR
STATE THAN THOSE STATES NO. SO
WHY IS IT THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
MORE PEOPLE SERVING LIFE.
BECAUSE OF EXTREME SENTENCING
THAT NOT ONLY THE LEGISLATURE
BUT ALSO VOTERS ENACTED. DURING
BUT YOU KNOW YOU CAN HAVE A
HIGH PROFILE CRIME WHICH IS
REALLY AWFUL. AND IT'S
PUBLICIZED AGREED DEAL SOMEONE
SEIZES UPON THAT DOESN'T
INITIATIVE AND THEN WE VOTERS
PASS WITHOUT REALIZING THE
IMPLICATIONS. AND THE BROAD
SWATH OF THE POPULATION THAT WE
ARE THEN AFFECTING BY SUCH A
SENTENCE. NOW FREE FACTORED
JUVENILES CALIFORNIA'S MADE
SOME REFORMS FOR CALIFORNIA HAD
BY FAR THE HIGHEST NUMBER BOTH
RON NUMBER AND PERCENT OF
JUVENILES THAT WERE GIVEN A
LIFE SENTENCE EXCEEDING
LOUISIANA TEXAS AND GEORGIA.
NOW IN THIS THERE ARE
APPROPRIATE TIMES FOR A LIFE
SENTENCE BUT I THINK THAT THIS
REFORM IS VERY REASONABLE AND
I'M IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THE DA'S SUPPOSE
HOWEVER. WHAT BENEFIT HAS IT
HAD TO CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THAT
PERCENT OF PEOPLE 40% OF OUR
INCARCERATED POPULATION SERVE A
LIFE SENTENCE IT'S EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE FOR US EXTREMELY. AND
VERY LITTLE BENEFIT AND AGAIN
IT IS APPROPRIATE IN THE MOST
HEINOUS CRIMES AND FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTENT TO COMMIT MURDER
POTENTIALLY TO SERVE A LIFE
SENTENCE HOWEVER WITH THE BILL
BEFORE US DOES IS ALLOW THERE
TO BE A DISTINCTION. THAT YOU
MAY STILL GET A VERY LONG SENSE
BUT THAT YOU WOULD NOT BE GIVEN
LIFE UNLESS YOU MET CERTAIN.
CRITERIA NOW. AGAIN WHY THE
DAS FEEL THAT THEY NEED TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GIVE A LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE FOR. THE PEOPLE
WHO I MEAN THERE'S FIRST DEGREE
MURDER CASES THAT GET LESS OF A
SENTENCE THEN THIS THEN THE
CORRECTION THAT THE SENATORS
PROPOSED TO US- THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE HARD BECAUSE IT'S A
TWO THIRDS VOTE BECAUSE IT WAS
DONE BY AN INITIATIVE IN WHICH
REQUIRES TWO THIRDS BECAUSE FOR
US TO FIX. SOMETHING THAT WAS
PASSED BY INITIATIVE REQUIRES
TWO THIRDS BUT I HOPE THAT WERE
AT THE PLACE WHERE WE CAN
APPRECIATE. THAT LICENSES WHILE
THEY SERVE A PURPOSE AND ARE
APPROPRIATE OR NOT APPROPRIATE.
ACTUALLY 440% OF OUR OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
PRISON IN CALIFORNIA. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR- BRINGING THE
BILL. AND I HOPE THAT WE ARE
ABLE I HOPE MY COLLEAGUES ARE
ABLE TO. SEE THE WISDOM OF
MAKING THIS CORRECTION THIS
DOES NOT ELIMINATE LIFE
SENTENCES. AND CERTAINLY THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT FEEL THAT
THEY COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
BUT WHO WON'T BECAUSE IT IS
NARROWLY CRAFTED. BUT AGAIN I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING
FORWARD. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SENATOR
SENATOR OF AYE SURE OTRO BOOK.
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION AB WITH
REGARDS AND I'M NOT SURE IF-
SENATOR CORTESE CAN ANSWER THIS
OR PERHAPS- WITH THE CHAIRS
PERMISSION- SENATOR SKINNER BUT
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THE
PUBLIC WHO VOTED FOR THIS
INITIATIVE- AND NOW WE ARE
GOING TO BE VOTING ON THE
POSSIBILITY OF OVERTURNING
THEIR REQUEST THEIR DESIRE OF
WHAT THEY VOTED. HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU ANSWER TO THE TO THE
BORDERS OF CALIFORNIA. FIVE I
THINK THE WAY WE ANSWERED TO
THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IS-
PRECISELY. HOW CENTER SKINNER
JUST EXPLAIN THIS TO THE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN- THAT
THE VOTERS. WITH GOOD INTENTION-
PASSES REFERENDUM- WITHOUT
KNOWING WHAT THE OUTCOMES WOULD
BE- WOULD NOT WOULD NOT KNOW
WHAT THE EVOLUTION WOULD BE OF
THE LEGISLATURE'S OWN EFFORTS
TO REFORM THE JUSTICE SYSTEM A
TO THIS POINT- AND- THE TWO
THIRDS REQUIREMENT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE WAS PUT IN AS A
SAFEGUARD- TO ANY CHANGES THAT
WOULD BE MADE TO THE
REFERENDUM- AND I TO. OF COURSE
IMPRESSING ON THAT THIS IS
ENOUGH OF A PROBLEM- THAT THE
TWO THIRDS A REQUIREMENT
SHOULD. BE MET IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IF IT'S NOT- THEN
THE ANSWER TO THE VOTERS IS
GOING TO BE- WE CAN'T WE CAN'T
CHANGE WHAT YOU ENACTED INTO
LAW BY REFERENDUM- IT THIS DOES
NOT TAKE AWAY SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES- I THINK A LITTLE
BIT OF THE OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
MAY HAVE BEEN MISLEADING FOR
EXAMPLE THE EXAMPLE THAT I
HEARD IF I WAS HEARING IT RIGHT
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. WHICH
INSTRUCTION TO THE BILL IS
CLEARLY CALLED OUT OF SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND NOT ONLY
CALLED ON THE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT WOULD STILL
REQUIRE LOCK. OR THE DEATH
PENALTY SIMPLY BY THE ASSERTION
OF THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY. IN IN
THE IN THE PROSECUTION SO. MUCH
OF WHAT THE VOTERS ENACTED HIS
STANCE SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
STANDS- BUT I DO BELIEVE IF WE
WENT BACK TO THE VOTERS TODAY
AND ASKED THE FLIP QUESTION-
WOULD WAS IT YOUR EXPECTATION.
THAT THE OUTCOMES THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN FROM THIS BILL WOULD BE
AS THEY ARE THE TWO THIRDS OF
THOSE. CONVICTED UNDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES I'LL WALK OR
DEATH PENALTY TWO THIRDS OF
THOSE WILL DIE IN PRISON ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER WHO WILL NOT
COME OUT OF PRISON OTHER THAN
IN A CASKET. TWO THIRDS OF
THOSE WILL BE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
TWO THIRDS OF THOSE WILL BE
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE
THE AVERAGE AGE WILL BE
NINETEEN- WE HAVE TO STEP IN IN
DISMANTLE. WHATEVER IT IS THAT
THAT IS CREATING THOSE OUTCOMES
I DO NOT BELIEVE IT WAS INTO
THE VOTERS TO CREATE THOSE
OUTCOMES. OTHERWISE THE
REFERENDUM WOULD HAVE BEEN.
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD CERTAINLY RACIST- ON
ITS FACE BUT NOW WE KNOW OF
WHAT THE ACTUAL OUTCOMES OF
THIS LAW OR WE HAVE THE WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO LOOK AT ACTUAL
OUTCOMES ACTUAL DATA- YEAH WE
HAVE A PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCE
RIGHT NOW AND I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY. THE MOST COMPELLING-
THE MOST COMPELLING REASON TO
CORRECT. A WHAT I THINK SENATOR
SKINNER'S ALLUDING TO A
POINTING OUT. HIS SOMETHING
THAT ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE
CORRECTED BECAUSE OF HER FINE
WORK ON SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN- WE WE'VE ALREADY IT IN
ESSENCE CORRECTED A FLAW IN THE
FELONY MURDER. DR IN CALIFORNIA
BUT WE HAVEN'T CORRECTED THE
SAME FOR IN SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. SO WE HAVE A
PECULIAR SCENARIO. PERSONS WHO
WERE NOT SENTENCED TO L. WALKER
DEF- ARE ABLE TO PETITION
COURTS FOR RELIEF BY SHOWING
THAT THEY NEVER INTENDED TO
KILL IN THE MET THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR RESENTENCING-
BUT UNDER UNDER FELONY MURDER
BUT UNDER SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES-
THAT THAT REMEDY DOES NOT
EXIST. SO HI THIS BILL WOULD
WOULD WOULD BRING ALL THAT INTO
ALIGNMENT- WITH THAT- MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M- AVAILABLE TO
RESPOND TO ANY FAULT QUESTIONS
OR IF- IF SENATOR- CHOI BOGUE-
WOULD LIKE ADDITIONAL FOLLOW UP
TO THAT. I WOULD DEFER TO
NATASHA MINSKER WHO I INDICATED
AT THE OUTSET IS AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER. BUT LEGAL TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. I JUST HAVE ONE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON ON. UNDER
THE OPPOSITION'S WITNESSES-
COMMENT WITH REGARD TO THIS
BILL IS FOUND TO BE VERY BROAD
AND NOT NEARLY ENOUGH TO- I'M%
ASSUMING MEET THE INTENT OF
YOUR OF YOUR INTENT OF YOUR
BILL- HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THAT. I HEARD THE OPPOSITION
WITNESS- USING THE TERM BROAD
WITH RIGHT REFERENCE TO THE
RESENTENCING PETITION THAT'S
CONTAINED IN THE BILL MMHM-
WITH SOME CONCERN THAT- BUT
FRANKLY I THOUGHT HIS. IS
OPPOSITION STATEMENT WAS SO
BROAD IT'S HARD TO TELL WHICH
PART OF IT IS CONCERNED ABOUT
TO BROAD IS YOU KNOW I SHOULD
REALLY BE RESPONDING TO BE
HONEST- BUT- BUT WE THINK IT'S
AN APPROPRIATE. VETTED-
OPPORTUNITY FOR PETITION FOR
REDRESS- IN. BUT YOU KNOW THAT
REDRESS WOULD STILL HAVE TO BE
APPROVING UP IN A COURT OF LAW.
THANK YOU. I JUST ONE LAST
COMMENT- IT'S JUST REALLY SAD
THAT IN OUR STATE. WE HAVE SO
MANY CASES COMING IN FOURTH I
MEAN THE NUMBERS ARE ALARMING-
AND IT REALLY JUST MAKES ME
THINK OF- WHERE WE ARE AS A
CULTURE IN OUR STATE- AS A
WHOLE- AND- IT COMING FROM A
SMALL TOWN COMMUNITY CITY I
JUST I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
JUST THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH OF OUR
STATE. D. THE CLIMATE THE
CULTURAL CLIMATE THAT WE'RE
LIVING IN I THINK IT'S WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
SUPPORT- HEALTHY FAMILIES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES- AND TO HELP
CHANGE AND FOCUS ON QUALITY
EDUCATION AS WELL TO BREAK
BARRIERS. AND IN A CULTURE THAT
IS. QUITE FRANKLY BROKEN BY THE
MEANS OF THE STATISTICS THAT
WERE PRESENTED TODAY- SPECIALLY
BY SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTERS CAN. THANK
YOU TO YOUR APOLOGIES I WANTED
TO JUST MAKE ONE OTHER COMMENT
WE HAD A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
CALLED IN WHO WE HAD SOME
PEOPLE CALLED IN WHO INDICATED
THEY HAD BEEN ABLE TO PETITION
THE COURT AND BE RESENTENCED
UNDER FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
WHICH IS A BILL I CARRIED THAT
CORRECTED ARE FELONY MURDER LAW
TO MAKE IT MORE TO CLARIFY THAT
IN ORDER TO BE CHARGED WITH
FELONY MURDER YOU HAD TO
ACTUALLY HAVE A ROLE. IN THE
DEATH OF THE PERSON- AND NOT BE
JUST A BYSTANDER. NOW AS FAR
THE SENATORS POINTED OUT WHO'S
BROUGHT US THIS BILL THIS IS
FIXING A PORTION OF. THAT
FELONY MURDER LAW AROUND
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES NOW A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE CALLED IN SO
THE PEOPLE WHO CALLED IN AND
SAID THEY HAD PETITIONED AND
BENEFITTED FROM FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. DID NOT FIVE WE'RE NOT A
CONVICTED WITH THE SAME
CIRCUMSTANCES AS WHAT SENATOR
CORTESE SPRING BEFORE US. BUT
WE ALSO HEARD IN THE WITNESSES
WHO CALLED IN A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW NO LONGER
INCARCERATED BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR GAVE THEM A
COMMUTATION TO A GOVERNOR
LOOKED AND THOUGHT OUT OKAY
THIS IS NOT APPROPRIATE THAT
THEY HAD THIS LIFE SENTENCE.
AND ANOTHER REASON THAT I
WANTED TO- EXPRESS IN EFFECT
THE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IS
THAT WHILE I APPRECIATE AND
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
GOVERNORS TO HAVE SUCH A RULE I
DON'T THINK A PERSON
CIRCUMSTANCE SHOULD BE
DEPENDENT SOLELY AND ONLY ON
THE POWER OF A GOVERNOR TO
COMMUTE. A SENTENCE ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE HAVE 40% OF OUR PRISON
POPULATION WAS ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE FOR SO 40% OF
THAT IS- YOU DO THE MATH OF
ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
SERVING LIFE SENTENCES THERE'S
NO WAY ANY GOVERNOR CAN REVIEW
THAT LEVEL OF POPULATION TO
DETERMINE WHETHER. THEY WERE
APPROPRIATELY SENTENCED SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES THIS DOES NOT
GUARANTEE THAT PEOPLE WITH THIS
SENTENCE WILL. HAPPY COURT
FAVORABLY REVIEWED THEM IT JUST
GIVES THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO PETITION THE COURT.
AND THE COURT THEN TO LOOK AT
THE CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH ALLOWS
THE DA'S TO COME FORWARD THE
PROSECUTOR IT ALLOWS VICTIMS TO
COME FORWARD IT ALLOWS EVERYONE
TO COME FORWARD AND RE LOOK AT
THE- CITY OUT. YOU KNOW WE DID
THIS DID THE CRIME THE ROLE OF
THAT PERSON IN THIS CRIME FIT
THE PUNISHMENT THAT THEY
RECEIVED RIGHT NOW THE COURT
HAS NO CHOICE BECAUSE OF THE
WORDING OF THE INITIATIVE IT IS
ONLY ARE ENACTING THIS BILL
THAT WOULD ALLOW BOTH GOING
FORWARD AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY SERVING SUCH
SENTENCES TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
REVIEW. OF WHETHER THAT
SENTENCE WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
TO OUR LANDS NOW SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT ADDITIONAL
POINT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
YEAH SENATE SENATOR CALM WATER.
I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- AND WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS STILL
A BURDEN OF PROOF THAT HAS TO
BE MET THIS IS NOT OPENING THE
FLOODGATES FOR FOLKS TO JUST.
GET OUT BUT IT IS SORT OF.
ASKING US TO RE THINK VERY LOW
CRITERIA- THAT WE'VE PLACED- IN
THE HANDS OF PROSECUTORS- FOR
SO LONG- IN AIDING US IN KIND
OF RETHINKING- YOU KNOW WHAT
THRESHOLD SHOULD LOOK LIKE WHEN
YOU'RE- INCARCERATING FOLKS.
FOR LIFE- I WOULD ALSO ASK THEM
HUMBLY SO IF- I COULD BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU YES
SENATOR. BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO HAVE YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU HANFORD QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. WELL SIR I DO WANNA
THANK YOU FOR WAR I FIND TO BE
A VERY COMMONSENSE MEASURE A
MEASURE AS SENATOR SKINNER AND
HAS CLEARLY STATED- IS NOT A
GET OUT A GEO THE CARD IS JUST
AN OPTION. IT'S AND I DON'T
KNOW WHY WE ARE SO FEARFUL OF
GIVING PEOPLE OPTIONS AND THE
QUESTION WAS ASKED ADDS TO
FIFTEEN TO BROAD WELL THAT'S
THE CATCH PHRASE ON ANY REFORM
THAT IS CALM BEFORE THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE. ANY NIBBLING AROUND
THE EDGES IS ALWAYS TOO BROAD
FOR OUR D. A. SYSTEM NO MATTER
WHAT IT IS BUT IF THIS WAS
REALLY ABOUT JUSTICE. THE NEW
NGUYEN BE JUST US ON LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE AND I MEAN JUST
US I MEAN BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE AND POOR THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE FACING THIS
SENTENCE ARE POOR PEOPLE
THERE'S NO WEALTHY PERSON IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO'S
ON DEATH ROW. LET'S BE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT SO IT'S A POOR
PEOPLE'S PUNISHMENT AND ALL
THIS DOES IS GIVE A- COURT THE
OPTION OF RESENTENCING
REEVALUATING THAT CRIME WE'VE
SEEN TOO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE THIS
CALIFORNIAN AND IT IS THE ONLY
STATE. ONE OF THE FEW STATES
ARE THREE. N. FEW YOUR STATES
ONE ONLY COUNTRY. THAT HOUSE L.
Y. WE SEE PEOPLE FOR POLITE
WHAT THE POSSIBILITY OF PRETTY.
I WELL AS ARE MINORS. YOU GO TO
THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES WHERE
THEY DON'T SENTENCE KIDS AND
PEOPLE TO DEATH R. OR FOR LIFE
FOR PRESIDENT BUSH WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE SUCH A
PROGRESSIVE LEADING STATE AND
WE OFTEN SAY WITH THE NEXT
COMING ATTRACTION I LIKE THAT
COMMENT THE GOVERNOR STATES
BUT- NOT WHEN IT COMES TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. AND TO
THE QUESTION OF OVERTURNING THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE I'VE DONE
THIS LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND THIS IS NOT TO
DISPARAGE OR BELITTLE THEM THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW TO
PROPOSITIONS THERE ON THE
BALLOT BECAUSE MOST OF US DON'T
UNDERSTAND UNTIL THEIR PASSING
SIR ALL WHILE. THIS IS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND. BECAUSE IF CRAP AND
SET A WAY. THAT ARE SOLD
MISLEADING TO VOTERS BACK. I
GET MORE CALLS DURING ELECTION
CYCLE OF WHAT PROPOSITION ABOUT
FOR WHAT YOU CAN I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT CAN I GUARANTEE
IF YOU PUT THE AVERAGE VOTER
UNDER TRUTH SERUM FINISHED. THE
MAJORITY OF THE STUFF THAT
THEY'RE VOTING FOR. BECAUSE
IT'S WRITTEN IN SUCH A WAY SO I
DON'T THINK THE AVERAGE VOTER
IT WAS CLEARLY EXPLAINED THAT
SENATORS DEMONSTRATED WOULD ACT
ALL- HAVE BOUGHT WHEN THEY
VOTED FOR THIS A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO THAT IT WOULD LIMIT
ONE'S ABILITY TO GET OUT OF
JAIL AND SPEND THE REST OF YOUR
LIFE WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT. FOLKS
WHO WENT TO JAIL AS A NINETEEN
YEAR OLDS AND YOU SPEND THE
POSSIBILITIES OF YOUR LIFE WHEN
YOU DIDN'T EVEN PULL THE
TRIGGER SIMPLY BECAUSE YOU WERE
IN THE CAR OR YOU WERE IN THE
VICINITY AND YOU HAD NO
INTENTIONS OF COMMITTING A
CRIME WITHIN AWARE THAT A CRIME
WAS GOING TO BE COMMENDED
BUTTERICK THE WRONG PLACE AT
THE WRONG TIME SO- I TOO WOULD
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
ON THIS MEASURE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AND WITHOUT.
ANY FURTHER DO I WILL ALLOW YOU
TO CLOSE. THE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- OF VERY HAPPY TO BRING
YOU ON AS A- AS A- AUTHOR- I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THE
SERIOUS DISCUSSION THIS MORNING
IN A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOTH. Q. CONSULTANT WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SOONERS SKINNER
IT'S A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I'M I'M SORT BY CENTER WHEN I'M
SORRY WE HAVE A MOTION IS TO
PASS A REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON S. B. UNDER. SB THREE
HUNDRED BRADFORD REDFORD I
INSURE. NO VOTE THE JOB OF NOT
VOTING COM LAGER HI COMMA- I
SKINNER. AYE SKINNER AYE
WINNER. WHEN AYE THOSE FOUR
ZERO FOUR ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU SENATOR
CORTESE'S WALL MOVING ON THEIR
OWN TO SB THIRTY EIGHTY TWO I
SEE CENTER CABALLERO. IS HERE.
UPON THE PREPARATION OF POLL
YOU YOU BEGIN ONCE WE'VE BEEN
PROPER SENATE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB THREE EIGHTY TWO WHICH WOULD
CLARIFY. THAT A RESTRAINING
ORDER SHOULD BE ROUTINELY
REQUESTED TO PROHIBIT A
PREDATOR FROM CONTACTING BE
EXPLOITED MINOR WHEN A SEXUAL
PREDATOR IS TAKEN TO COURT AND
CRIMINALLY CHARGED. I WANT TO
START BY SAM HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT TO
CHANGE DISTRICT ATTORNEY THE
PROSECUTOR. ESTIMATES BY THE
INTERNATIONAL LABOR
ORGANIZATION REPORTED THERE ARE
CLOSE TO TWENTY FIVE MILLION
INDIVIDUALS BEING TRAFFICKED
WORLDWIDE AND FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION ARE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT OVER 99% OF THOSE VICTIMS
ARE YOUNG WOMEN AND GIRLS.
EXPERTS BELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA
HAS THE HIGHEST INCIDENCE OF
CHILD TRAFFICKING TRAFFICKING
IN THE UNITED STATES STATE DUE
TO OUR BUSY PORTS OF ENTRY
HOWEVER IT'S HARD TO KNOW HOW
MANY CHILDREN ARE VICTIMS DUE
TO UNDER REPORTING. ADVOCATE
INDICATE INDICATE THAT WHAT
CRIMINAL CHARGES ARE BROUGHT
AGAINST AN EXPLOITER AN
OVERSIGHT OFTEN OCCURS THAT CAN
HAVE DIRE CONSEQUENCES
RESTRAINING ORDERS ARE NOT
ROUTINELY REQUESTED WHICH
DENIES THE TRAFFIC CHILD OR
WOMAN. PROTECTION KEEPING
CHILDREN AWAY FROM THEIR
EXPLOITERS IS A LIFE AND DEATH
MATTER AS THE AVERAGE AGE.
AVERAGE LIFE EXPECTANCY OF AN
EXPLOITED CHILD IS ONLY SEVEN
YEARS. DUE TO THE HIGH
INCIDENCE OF HOMICIDE DRUG
OVERDOSE HIV AIDS SB TEAS AND
SUICIDE. BEFORE THE PENAL CODE
EXPLICITLY PERMITTED AND THERE
FOR MOTIVATED PROSECUTORS AND
JUDGES TO SEEK RESTRAINING
ORDERS IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES THE LAW PERMITTED SUCH
ORDERS TO ISSUE UNDER A GENERAL
STATUTE PERMITTING CRIMINAL
PROTECTIVE ORDERS. SUCH ORDERS
IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES WERE
RARE HOWEVER WHICH IS WHY THE
LAW WAS AMENDED AND
SPECIFICALLY THERE ARE NOW
EIGHT EXPLICIT REFERENCES TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS IN THE STATUTE AND THESE
PROTECTIVE ORDERS ARE NOW
ROUTINELY ISSUED WHICH SAVES
LIVES. SB THREE EIGHTY TWO IS A
SIMPLE CHANGE TO GIVE
COMMERCIAL SEX SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION VICTIMS THE RIGHT
TO A PROTECTIVE ORDER AND
CLARIFY THE CURRENT LAW PERMITS
AND SET STANDARDS FOR THOSE
ORDERS AS A PART OF A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS. GIVEN THE UNIQUE
VULNERABILITY OF VICTIMS A
MODEST CLARIFICATION OF CURRENT
LAW IS LONG OVERDUE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS MAGGIE KRAUSE.
SENATOR MAKE CLARIFY SOMETHING
QUICKLY. THE BILL IS ONE OF THE
BILL WHICH WILL. CHAU OKAY PM
ONE WITNESS IN SUPPORT TO DO ED
HOURS WILL. YES. TWO WITNESSES
AND VICTIMS HERE TO ANDERSON
WILL BE GIVEN TWO MINUTES EACH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
WANTED TO CLARIFY THIS BILL WAS
PUT OVER FROM LAST WEEK SO THE
AMENDMENT WAS TAKEN IN THE
MEANTIME SO IT'S NOT AMENDED
DOES NOT M. THANK YOU. FOR THAT
I APPRECIATE IT. YOUR WOULD
MORNING JANUARY. HI GOOD
MORNING SENATOR SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHTY TWO IS A MINOR
MODIFICATION TO PREVENT AND
DANGEROUS AND EVEN DEADLY
RESULTS MIDVALE IS ABOUT
KEEPING TABS TRAFFICKERS AWAY
FROM THEIR DESK MY NAME'S
MAGGIE CORRAL I APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY VIRTUALLY- AND FORMER
PROSECUTOR WHO LED THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND TRAFFICKING EFFORTS
AND SEPARATELY AND THAT THE
WHOLE PRACTITIONER CURRENTLY
REPRESENTING SURVIVORS. I
PROVIDED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
HERE IN THE PAST AND I CREATED
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE ON
THIS CRUCIAL AND YOU WANT
POLITICS I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE BROAD MEMBER
ORGANIZATION TO BRING THEIR OWN
EXPERTISE IN SUPPORTING THIS
IMPORTANT THAT ALL THE SOUTH
BAY COALITION TO ENSURE THE
TRAFFICKING LEGAL LEGAL
ADVOCATE FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. THREE STRANDS GLOBAL.
FOUNDATION AND OTHERS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I MEMBERS THIS
BILL AIMED AT CURBING ABILITY
OF THAT. YOU CAN DIMINISH. AND
TERRIFY TO MAKE THAT. IN CASES
OF SEX TRAFFICKING VICTIM ARE
ON AVERAGE. TO FOURTEEN YEARS
OLD AND SOME ARE EVEN YOUNGER.
MOREOVER AT LEAST HALF OF THE
VICTIMS ARE FORMER OR CURRENT
FOSTER CARE CHILDREN WHO HAVE
SUFFERED ABUSE OR NEGLECT IN
THEIR ON CALL. DISPONIBILIDADE
LAYERED WITH A TACTIC THAT
TRAFFICKERS OFTEN EMPLOY MAKE
IT EXCEPTIONALLY DIFFICULT FOR
SURVIVORS TO BREAK FREE. EVEN
AFTER THEIR TRAFFICKERS ARE
ARRESTED. TRAFFICKERS USE.
FORMS OF SOCIAL MEDIA FAMILY
MEMBERS GETTING NETWORK
INDIRECT COMMUNICATION TO
CONTINUE THE CYCLE OF FEAR AND
LOYALTY. EVEN WHEN. TRAVELERS
ARE IN CUSTODY. IF SURVIVABLE
BY JAM. MY LOOK TO CONSIDER AN
ORDER THAT WOULD PROVE THE
DEFENDANT FROM CON THE IT
REMAINS THE COR THAT OTHER
OUTLINED IN PENAL SECTION ONE
THIRTY SIX POINT ZERO ARE ALSO
AVAILABLE FOR CONSIDERATION IN
CONTRACTING. IMPORTANTLY THIS
BILL DID NOT ENACT ANY NEW
GROUND OR ANYTHING BURKE
SEEKING A RESTRAINING ORDER
NEARLY FLAG THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING STATUTE WITH IN THE
RESTRAINING ORDERS ACTUALLY AS
A REMINDER THAT THIS OFTEN
OVERLOOKED REMEDY. IS AVAILABLE
NEW CASES. AND ACTUALLY
SUMMARIZED ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES
IN ALL CASES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THE PROSECUTOR
SHALL INQUIRE OF THE COURT
WHETHER IT WILL ISSUE A
RESTRAINING ORDER. THIS ENSURES
THAT THE COURT CONSIDERED THE
PICKING. THAT PROTECT THEM.
REQUIRE THE COURT ISSUE ORDERS.
IT DOESN'T EVEN THE FIVE TO
ARGUE FOR THEIR ORDER. IT
NEARLY WERE MY ALL PARTIES THAT
THE REMEDY IS. IN THESE CASES
AND SHOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED.
ULTIMATELY THE COURT WILL FIND
GOOD GOD ISSUE ANY ORDERS. HOW
DID. ARE BUSY BURKE ARRANGE
CALENDAR CROSS WITH THE- THIS.
BILL PROVIDES A CRUCIAL
REFERENCE TO PREVENT AND DETER
THE OVERSIGHT. ALL THAT MAY
CLEAR THE LAW WILL ENSURE GUARD
WORK. TO PREVENT MORE WILL BE
FROM TEACHING. ACTIVATION ABUSE
BY TRACK. I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
IN AFTER ANY QUESTIONS MIGHT
HAVE. GOOD MORNING THE NUMBERS
AT OUR BACKS COUNSEL THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE-
WHAT I THINK YOU'RE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THE ACTUAL WORK
ON THIS BILL AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I DON'T. THANK YOU AND
NOW LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
KERN FORTY TWO OH TWO WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE EIGHT
TWO ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
THE HEARING ROOM ASCENA AND
LET'S GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
OF TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY FORTY-
THERE ARE NO ONE THERE AS WELL.
MODERATOR NOW LET'S MOVE TO OUR
PHONE LINES THOSE WITNESSES
WILL ARE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE EIGHT
TWO. THANK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WATER IS
THERE ANYONE THERE. NOBODY IS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME- IT WITH
THE SECTION MULLIN SECOND
PLEASE EIGHT ONE FILE BY THERE
WE DID HAVE A COUPLE QUEUED UP
AND THEN. I DON'T THEY TOOK.
FIND. NUMBER ONE THIRTY SEVEN
ALIGN ITSELF OPEN. YES MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN- MICHELLE
THOMAS SHOT REPRESENTING
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND SUPPORT.
BY NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HELLO EVER
COMPOUND CO FOUNDER OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION VETERANS EXPLORING
TREATMENT SOLUTIONS. AUTHOR OF
SB FIVE ONE NINE I APPLAUD
CALIFORNIA FOR LEADING THE WAY
AND URGED THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE
I ON SB FIVE ONE NINE. YOU ONE
MOMENT PLEASE ALL TOGETHER THE
NEXT MEMBER. BY ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING THURMOND AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT THAT THEY'LL STILL
WORK ON BEHALF OF MEMBERS STAFF
AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY TWO AND WE WERE JUST.
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS GEORGE KRAMER
CALLING THE FLORIDA LOCATION
THANK. WITH THE DEVICE BUILT
RIGHT INTO THE. PINE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. PLEASE ON
MUTE. FIFTY FIVE. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT. AND
RESEARCHER THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU WELL LET'S MOVE TO
OPPOSITION- SB THREE EIGHTY TWO
YOU ARE THERE ANY- INDIVIDUALS
HERE INSIDE OF FORTY TWO OLD
THREE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SB THREE EIGHTY
TWO. SEEN ONE COME FORWARD
LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE OVERFLOW
ROOM OF TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE THERE SEEN NO ONE THERE
MISTER MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE
NOW TO THE PHONE LINES IF THERE
ARE. THIS IS AN Q. WISHING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
LET US KNOW AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AGAIN- TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME FIND ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IGNACIO
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS. FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE- SACRAMENTO
WILL BE TAKEN I APOLOGIZE FOR
NOT. RIGHT NEXT TO BEGIN THE
POWER OF- SOMEBODY THAT COULD
COME AND HELP FINDING COMMITTEE
AVERAGING GO AMENDMENTS OF THE
BEEN DESCRIBED IN YOUR TAKING
YOU CAN CHECK WORK WITH CHART
TOPPING MISSION- AT ALL. AND AS
A FINAL PLEASE PRESSED ZERO. TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
CALDERON OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. I WILL
GIVE IT ANOTHER MOMENT IF YOU
CAN CHECK TO LAWS WHICH MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
THERE. ABSOLUTELY ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
NOBODY
IS QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU NOW LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEES OR ANY QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO.
SB THREE EIGHT TWO. SENATOR
CALM WATER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I. HAD A QUESTION
REGARDING THE AMENDMENTS I
HEARD. THE CONSULTANTS SAY THAT
NO AMENDMENTS. FOR TAKEN AND
THIS HEARING THAT'S BECAUSE
THEY WERE TAKEN. BUT TO OKAY-
AND THEN I'VE ALSO BEEN TOLD
THAT. THOSE THAT WERE IN
OPPOSITION BEFORE HAVE NOW COME
OFTEN ARE NEUTRAL. DO WE KNOW
OF THAT. SEVEN BUT IT SOUNDED
LIKE IGN ASIO HERNANDEZ SAID
FOR CA CJ ON THE PHONE. AND
THEN- MY LAST QUESTION IS JUST-
AS I WAS READING THROUGH THE
BILL- AND THE ANALYSIS. I WAS
WONDERING IF THERE IS ANY-
CONSIDERATION THAT IS GIVEN
BECAUSE I ALSO HEARD THAT IT'S
NOT REQUIRED IT IS NOT
MANDATORY BUT IT IS AN OPTION
IT IS ANOTHER TOOL- THAT JUDGES
HAVE AT THEIR DISPOSAL BUT I
KNOW THAT IN MANY INSTANCES NOT
IN ALL THOSE THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN THIS KIND OF TRAFFICKING-
ARE ALSO SORT OF VICTIMS ARE
HAVE BEEN. VICTIMIZED BY THE
SAME KIND OF BEHAVIOR AND
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE PAST- IT'S
ALMOST ANALOGOUS TO CHILD
SOLDIERS WHO ARE YOU KNOW
PARTICIPATING IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY AND- ARE CURRENTLY
THEMSELVES BEING VICTIMIZED. SO
I JUST DIDN'T KNOW- IF THERE'S
ANY. REMEDY OF CONSIDERATION
FOR SITUATIONS LIKE THE ACT OR
IS IT SORT OF- INFERRED BY THE
FACT THAT- THIS IS AN OPTION AT
THE DISPOSAL RATHER THAN
SOMETHING THAT IS- MANDATORY IF
THAT MAKES SENSE. SO JUST A
QUESTION- IS YOUR YOUR
REFERENCE TO THAT THE ACCUSED
OR TO THE VICTIM THE ACCUSED.
I'M THIS THIS- THIS DOESN'T
CHANGE THE RELATIONSHIPS- OR OR
MAKE ANY- ASSUMPTION ABOUT THE
ACCUSED- THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'LL BE PART OF I'M ASSUMING
A CRIMINAL CASE WHERE- IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A DEFENSE
BOB A POSSIBLE DEFENSE BOB YOU
KNOW YEAH I WAS A VICTIM OF
THIS ONCE AND SO THAT'S WHY I
GOT INVOLVED IN IT- CERTAINLY
THAT. I'VE I'VE NEVER HEARD
THAT USE BUT I'M I'M I'M I'M
ASSUMING THAT IT A CREATIVE-
DEFENSE ATTORNEY COULD USE THAT
WITH THIS HAS TO DO WITH IS THE
CRIMINAL CASE AS IT COMES INTO
COURT THE OF THE- ABILITY OF
THE JUDGE TO UNDERSTAND THAT B.
THAT THERE'S A PROCESS WHERE I
THE JUDGE CAN ORDER A
RESTRAINING ORDER PENDING THE
OUTCOME OF THE CRIMINAL CASE.
AND WHAT THAT DOES IS IT
PROTECTS THE VICTIM. OR THE
ALLEGED VICTIM IN THIS CASE-
FROM BEING CONTACTED BY FROM
BEING- APPROACHED OR IN ANY WAY
INTIMIDATED BY. THE- THE
PERPETRATOR AND BUT WHAT THE
TESTIMONY AND THE INFORMATION
THAT I RECEIVED FROM THE
ADVOCATES IS THAT MANY TIMES-
SEX TRAFFICKING IT INVOLVES.
MORE THAN JUST THE INDIVIDUAL
IT'S TRAFFICKING THAT THE
VICTIM IT INVOLVES A WHOLE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE WHERE
THAT SEX SEX TRAFFICKER EVEN IF
THEY'RE IN CUSTODY HAS THE
ABILITY TO ASK PEOPLE TO
CONTACT THE VICTIM- TO HAVE
COMMUNICATION TO THREATEN THE
VICTIM AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE AGE OF THAT
THEIR CHILDREN MANY OF THEM-
THAT AND THEIR CHILDREN WHO
BELIEVE THAT THEIR LOVED BY THE
PERPETRATOR- THAT THAT WE HAVE
AN INABILITY TO PROTECT THEM
AND KEEP THEM. FROM HAVING
CONTACT WITH SOMEONE WHO HAS
ABUSED THEM SO THAT THEY CAN
MOVE ONTO THEIR OWN RECOVERY SO
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S THE THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS THIS IS ABOUT IS-
REMINDING THE COURT THAT THERE
IS A TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX WHICH
IS TO PROTECT THEM THE VICTIM
IN THIS CASE AND IN A BUSY
CRIMINAL COURT CALENDAR THIS IS
EASY TO OVERLOOK YOU HAVE. YOU
HAVE- THIS AWARENESS MUCH MORE
IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASE
THEN YOU DO IN A CRIMINAL COURT.
AND THE TEN YEARS IS THAT A
COMMON LENGTH OF TIME HOW WAS
THAT DECIDED YES THAT'S THAT'S
THE LENGTH OF TIME THAT IT
THAT'S IN THE STATUTE. IN OTHER
WORDS WE'RE NOT CHANGING THAT.
YOU ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. BARTHAS COMMITTEE.
HEARING NINE CENTER COPIER
WHICH ALLOWED TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER MISTER CHAIR AND I.
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. WE HAVE
A TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WERE SEEKING A
MOTION ON IT SB THREE EIGHT TWO
ZERO MOTION. HELLO SIR MOVED
SPIN MOVES BY SENATOR OF A CHOI
BOLD. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON SB THREE A TWO SB
THREE EIGHTY TWO BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD AYE IT SHOWBOAT I JOBO
GUY COM LONGER COME LONGER AYE
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE WIENER.
WHEN OUR EYES FIVE ZERO YOUR
SENATOR CONGRATULATIONS VERY
MUCH CONNECTION BOB I BELIEVE
WE'RE GONNA TAKE SB. SEVEN FOUR
EIGHT FIVE CENTER PORTANTINO.
ONCE WE HAVE THE PODIUM
STRICKEN FANS SO. WHEN YOU'RE
READY SENATOR YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT IS
THE CHAIR SAID SB FIVE SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT WHICH EXPANSIVE
TYPE OF EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS COVERED BY PENAL
CODE SIX TWO SIX TO INCLUDE
CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
CURRENT LAW ONLY INCLUDES
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE K. TWELVE SCHOOLS
INCLUSION OF PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
PENAL CODE SIX TWO SIX WILL
CREATE A CLEAR STANDARDS FOR
THE ENFORCEMENT OF TRESPASSING
AT PRIVATE NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES THE BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT THE NONPROFIT
HIGHER EDUCATION SECTOR HAS
SIMILAR RESPONSIBILITIES AND
IT'S CONFRONTING SIMILAR PUBLIC
SAFETY CHALLENGES AS THE
PUBLIC- AS ITS PUBLIC
COUNTERPARTS IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
THAT WE HAVE TO WORRY SO MUCH
ABOUT OUR INSTITUTIONS OF
PUBLIC EDUCATION IN PUBLIC
SAFETY MATTERS AS WE DO- TODAY
AND SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO BRING
EQUITY IT HAD IT WILL HELP
CREATE SAFER COLLEGE CAMPUSES
BY ENSURING THERE IS THE
ABILITY TO ADEQUATELY ENFORCE
TRESPASSING LAWS THE MAJORITY
OF PRIVATE NONPROFIT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES ARE
RESIDENTIAL IN NATURE. AND
HOW'S THE TRADITIONAL EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD COLLEGE
AGE GROUP AS WELL AS SOME
GRADUATES AND FACULTY HOUSING
THIS IS A MAJOR DIFFERENCE FROM
TYPICAL PRIVATE BUSINESSES
CURRENTLY PRIVATE NONPROFIT
HIGHER EDUCATION TEST UTILITY
YOUR LIFE THE SAME PEOPLE CODE
SECTION THAT A PRIVATE BUSINESS
USES NOT THAT OF THE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES. THOUGH THEY
PROVIDE A VERY DIFFERENT
SERVICE THIS INCLUDES USE OF NO
TRESPASSING LETTER SYNDICATE
CONSENT AND HAS BEEN WITHDRAWN
FROM AN INDIVIDUAL TO BE ON
CAMPUS IN RECENT YEARS SOME
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS OFFICES HAVE
EXPRESSED RESERVATIONS ABOUT
ISSUING TRESPASSING VIOLATIONS
ON THE STRENGTH OF THESE
LETTERS ENEA AB APPLICABILITY
OF PENAL CODE SECTION SIX OH
TWO THE PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
FURTHER TRESPASSING LETTERS
MEANT TO SERVE A CONTINUING
NOTICE. OF REVOCATION OF THE
RIGHT TO OCCUPY PRIVATE
PROPERTY HAVE BECOME IN IF IN
CAMPUS COMMUNITIES DUE TO THE
LACK OF CLEAR LEGAL GIDANCE ON
ENFORCEMENT. THE LACK OF AN
IMPORT EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT
TOOL MEANS THAT INDIVIDUALS
HAVE WHO HAVE BEEN ADVISED THAT
PERMISSION TO USE THE CAMPUS
HAS BEEN REVOKED SIMPLY RETURN
TO CAMPUS. OFTEN ENGAGING IN
THE SAME BEHAVIOR THAT CAUSED
HER PERMISSION TO BE REVOKED
UNTIL THEY ARE ASKED TO LEAVE
AGAIN. THEY LEAVE ONLY TO
RETURN AGAIN AND AGAIN REPEAT
OFFENDERS LEARN THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO RETURN TO THESE
CAMPUSES WITH LITTLE CONCERN.
ABOUT CONSEQUENCES SB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT RECOGNIZES THAT
PRIVATE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THE
PHYSICAL SAFETY OF THE CAMPUS
COMMUNITY. AND THEY FACE
SIMILAR PUBLIC SAFETY
CHALLENGES AS THEIR PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION COUNTERPARTS.
SB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT SIMPLY
ASSESS PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES BY
EXPANDING PENAL CODESIX TWO
SIX TO INCLUDE THEM AS WELL.
AND THESE PROTECTIONS ARE
ALREADY AFFORDED TO AS I SAID
TO THE PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND PUBLIC
PRIVATE. PUBLIC AND PRIVATE K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS SO WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF SOME
FORTY EIGHT. IS RANDY BURBA
CHIEF OF PUBLIC SAFETY AT
CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY AND LAUREN
SCHULTZ ALLER SENIOR ASSOCIATE
BY PRO PRICE PROVOST
INSTITUTION EQUITY IN ACCESS AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND
OBVIOUSLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU- SUMMARY
PLEASE. QUEUE UP TO TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THEY HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
RAINY BOURBON ACERS THE CHIEF
OF PUBLIC SAFETY CHAPMAN
UNIVERSITY ON BEHALF OF CHEN
UNIVERSITY I SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND HAVING BEEN A PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CALLED UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. AND REPRESENTING
MANY COLLEAGUES I KNOW THERE IS
BROAD SUPPORT FOR G. CENTER
ACTORS AND TALKING WITH SOME OF
MY COUNTERPARTS WHO WORKED IN
THE PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS WHO ALREADY HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS ADDITIONAL TOOL.
IT IS EVIDENT THAT SIX POINT
SIX MORE AFFECTED THAN SIX SO
TOO BECAUSE IT ALLOWS FOR
IMMEDIATE MITIGATION OF
THREATENING SUSPICIOUS
HAZARDOUS OR CRICKET ACTIVITIES
ON CAMPUS AND WITH THE DIVINE
GROUP AT LEAST SEVEN DAYS.
ADDITIONALLY PROVIDES AN OPTION
OF INTERNAL RESOLUTION WITHOUT
REQUIRING AUTOMATIC PROCESSES
SUCH AS PROSECUTION FOR
TRADITIONAL SIX OH TWO INSTEAD
ALLOWING CAMPUS RESOURCES AND
PROCESSES TO BE ENACTED AND
LEVERAGE TO RESOLVE THE
EXISTING CONCERN. UNDERTAKEN
NATIONAL MINISTRY OF ACTIONS TO
SUPPORT EXTENDING THE STAY AWAY
ORDER IS NECESSARY. THE
BUILDING USED BOTTLE AND
INTENTIONAL OPTIONS WITHIN SIX
TWENTY SIX POINT FOR HER CAMPUS
PERSONS AND. SIX TWENTY SIX
POINT SIX FOR UNAFFILIATED
PERSONS. ITOLD HER CAMPUS
SAFETY. TO HELP. RIGHT OF CAMP
OFFICIAL SUCH AS THE FAIR HUMAN.
AND MANAGEMENT ALL MORE
EFFECTIVELY. CHALLENGING IN
PARTICULAR THE CHAMBER MOVED TO
THIS IS IN BREAKING THE CYCLE
REPEATED OF. IT'S MORE SO ST
TIME AND MOST YOU'RE A-
TYPICALLY IN THE MORNING. AND
SUSTAINED. BY CERTAIN PERSONS.
THEREBY REDUCING THE LIKELIHOOD
OF REPEAT OFFENSES. THIS IS
TRUE FOR STUDENT VERSUS DURING
CONFRONTATIONS EMPLOYEE
MISCONDUCT AND UNRELATED
PERSONS WHO COME ON THE CAMPUS
WITH THE INTENT TO ACT.
UNLAWFULLY OR IN SOME. MANNER
THERE ARE ALSO CASES WERE A
THREAT MAY NOT RISE TO CRIMINAL
LEVEL OR THE VICTIM IS NOT
DESIROUS OF PROSECUTION. IN
THESE CASES WITHOUT THE TOOLS
PROVIDED SIX TWENTY SIX THERE
WOULD BE NO RECOURSE TO
MITIGATE POTENTIALLY ONGOING
CONCERNING BEHAVIOR SHE-
FINALLY IT'S PROVEN. PROVEN
TOOL THAT ALREADY IS AVAILABLE
PUBLIC GEN THREE TWELVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CS USING
UC'S. BECAUSE THIS TOOL CAN
HELP PROTECT AND JEAN PAUL
CONSTITUENTS INCLUDING
MARGINALIZED MEANING THEY WERE
SAFE. AS A MATTER EQUITY IT
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS AS WELL.
A STUDENT SHOULD NOT BE
PENALIZED FOR WHERE THEY CHOSE
TO ATTEND SCHOOL. THANK YOU FOR
GIVING YOUR VALUABLE TIME. HERE
MY SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THANK
YOU WITNESS. GET MORE CARE
BRADFORD COMMITTEE MAY NAY YOU
FOR THIS. MY NAME LAWRENCE
TALLER AND MISSING ASSOCIATE
VICE PRO OF INSTITUTIONAL IT
AND IT. I HER PRONOUNS I
OVERSEE THE OFFICES THAT
ADDRESS SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
ALL FORMS OF DISCRIMINATION ON
OUR CAMPUS I AM SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF STANFORD IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD
PROVIDE A MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE
TOOLS TO PROTECT OUR CAMPUS
FROM INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ENGAGING AND DISTURBING
BEHAVIORS CAUSING FEAR AND
DESTRUCTION ON OUR CAMPUSES
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
VIOLATING OUR HARASSMENT. AND
DISCRIMINATION POLICIES I DO
KNOW WE HAVE LEGAL OBLIGATIONS
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY FROM
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
UNDER STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS
EVEN WHEN THAT CONDUCT DOES NOT
RISE TO THE LEVEL OF BEING A
CRIME RIGHT NOW IT'S AN
INDIVIDUAL BEING DISRUPTIVE ON
OUR ON OUR CAMPUS PENAL CODE
SECTION SECTION SIX OH TWO
REQUIRES THAT WE FIRST
INSTRUCTORS AND TO LEAVE AND IF
THEY DO THE CLOCK RESETS
ALLOWING THE INDIVIDUAL TO COME
BACKAND CAUSE DESTRUCTION. DAY
AFTER DAY OVER THE LAST YEAR
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE ARE SEEING
ACROSS MAJOR CITIES WE HAVE HAD
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE COME ONTO
CAMPUS AND YELLED HATEFUL
RACIAL EPITHETS AT STANFORD
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO IDENTIFY
AS API THIS LAW WOULD HELP US
ADDRESS AND STOP THE
TRAUMATIZING INCIDENCES. EIGHT
THIS PAST YEAR WE HAD ST CODE
RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE BUT
NONETHELESS THE PERSON SHOWED
UP WITHOUT A MASK AND LIKE TO
APPROACH WOMEN AND HARASS THEM
BY MAKING VIOLENT SEXUALLY
AGGRESSIVE STATEMENT OUR
STUDENTS WERE REALLY DISTRESSED
THAT THE MOST WE CAN DO IS ASK
HIM TO LEAVE EACH TIME WE SAW
HIM THEY DID NOT UNDERSTAND WHY
WHY WE COULD NOT DO MORE FOR
THEM. THE RESTRAINING ORDER
PROCESS REQUIRES THAT WE
IDENTIFY A VICTIM BY NAME AFTER
TO GO DOWN TO COURT AND TESTIFY
AGAINST OF HARASSING INDIVIDUAL.
I'M CHOI DONE A FIRE SOUTH OF
THE VICTIM IN A RESTRAINING
ORDER PROCESS FELT MORE
FRIGHTENING AND ONE IS NOT AN
OPTION THAT THEY WANTED TO
PURSUE. THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
PROVIDE A VERY NEEDED WINDOW OF
TIME TO RESET BEHAVIORS. AND
BREAK THE PATTERN. PUBLIC
SAFETY THEY ALREADY HAVE THIS
TOOL AN INDIVIDUAL TO ATTEND
PRIVATE UNIVERSITY SHOULD NOT
BE PROVIDED LESS FAVORABLE
SAFETY OPTIONS IN THEIR CAMPUS
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THIS ROOM- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FOUR EIGHT
ARE THERE ANY IN THIS ROOM SEEN
ON COMING FORWARD NOW LET'S
MOVE TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM ROOM
TWENTY FORTY HE WON IN SUPPORT
OF OUR SB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
SEEN ON THEIR MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINES INTO IT
THERE'S WITNESSES QW TO TESTIFY
ARE WANTING TO TESTIFY SHOULD
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF. SEVEN FOUR
EIGHT. THANK YOU MUCH MUCH
RICHER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS ALEX GRAVES WITH A ICC
YEAR WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL OUR MEMBERSHIP INCLUDES
MORE THAN EIGHTY COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING THOSE OF THE TWO
WITNESSES IN THE COURT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LIVING ONLINE. ONE
SIXTY. MONACAN COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES THE TRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE MORE
QUEUING UP. MEMBERS RANGE FROM
A WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF SCHOOL
SAFETY PROFESSIONAL FINANCE
POLICE OFFICERS L. THREE POLICE
OFFICERS AND LOS ANGELES SCHOOL
POLICE ASSOCIATION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SCHOOL
SAFETY BILL SB. SEVEN FOUR
EIGHT. AND A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO MAKE.
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU WELL LET'S MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I SEE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESS LISTED AND
OPPOSITION ARE THERE WITNESSES
HERE IN FORTY TWO OLD THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO IT SB SEVEN FOUR
EIGHT. SEE NO ONE COMING
FORWARD LET'S MOVE TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM A TWENTY FORTY
WHEN THIS IN OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO ONE THERE. MODERATOR NOW
LET'S MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
SEEING IF THERE'S WITNESSES IN
Q. WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN FOUR
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MISTER- CHAIRMAN THE
MEMBERS THIS IS LARRY MORRIS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL- WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO- GET ON DURING THIS
FOR POSITION- PAUL JUDGE FOR
THAT BUT WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. I WOULD ADD TO THE
PROBLEM ONE MORE TIE BEFORE WE
MOVE ON. THANK YOU- AS A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP WE HAVE NO
TAKERS OKAY LET'S MOVE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE IS THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS RELATED
TO THIS MEASURE BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAID SIR CALM UNDER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- THIS
IS- ARIA. FIND HIS BILL VERY
INTERESTING AND IT'S TRIGGERING
FOR ME MEMORIES OF GOING TO
SCHOOL AT USC- AND ALSO SOME
CONVERSATIONS THAT I HAD WITH
STUDENTS A FEW WEEKS AGO FROM
THAT. SAME SCHOOL WHO TALKED
ABOUT- THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE- REGARDING THE
RELATIONSHIP. THAT THE SCHOOL
HAS DEVELOPED WITH THE
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS- AND HOW
OFTEN TIMES FOLKS WHO LIVE IN
THE NEIGHBORING AREA OF SOUTH
LA- ARE. EITHER INTIMIDATED OR
HARASSED FOR TREATED IN A WAY
THAT SEEMS ON KIND BY STUDENTS-
OF THE- LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTITY
ON THE SCHOOL. AND IT MADE ME
THINK OF WHEN I WAS GOING TO
SCHOOL. AND RECOGNIZING THAT IT
IS A SHORT CUT FOR MANY FOLKS
WHO LIVE IN SOUTH LA- INSTEAD
OF GOING AROUND THE ENTIRE
CAMPUS OFTENTIMES COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WOULD WALK THROUGH. BUT
IT WAS ALSO EVIDENT THAT THEY
READ THEIR BEING PROFILED OR
SOMEONE WAS DETERMINING THAT
THEY WERE NOT STUDENTS AT THE
SCHOOL- AND THEY WOULD BE-
STOPPED APPREHENDED- AND DID
TOLD TO GET OFF THE CAMPUS- BY
CAMPUS POLICE. AND SO I WAS
JUST WONDERING- WHEN. WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO- IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR- THOSE. KINDS
OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS- BECAUSE
WHILE I AGREE STUDENTS SHOULD
BE PENALIZED FOR WHERE THEY GO
TO SCHOOL I ALSO AGREE THAT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS SHOULD BE
PENALIZED FOR WHERE SCHOOLS
BEEN BUILT- AND HOW WE DEVELOP.
RIGHTEOUS RELATIONSHIPS ARE HOW
SCHOOLS DEVELOP RIGHT JUST
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES IS AS
IMPORTANT AS MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE THAT LIVE OR WORK OR ARE
EDUCATED ON THE SCHOOL CAMPUSES
ARE ALSO PROTECTED. SO I JUST
WANTED TO HEAR FROM YOU TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS LAW WASN'T GOING
TO DISPROPORTIONATELY CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE FOLKS THAT ARE
DEEMED YOU KNOW INAPPROPRIATE
TO BE ON CAMPUS- FROM BEING-
UNDULY HARASSED. I THINK IT'S A
IT'S AN EXCELLENT QUESTION AND
CERTAINLY AN ISSUE THAT EVERY
CAMPUS SHOULD BE COGNISANT OF-
YOU KNOW COLLEGE CAMPUSES
TRADITIONALLY ARE WELCOMING
PLACES THEY HAVE. PUBLIC EVENTS
IN THERE ARE GALLERIES THEY
HAVE THEATER PRODUCTIONS-
YOU'RE RIGHT PEOPLE DO YOU
SHORT CUTS ACROSS CAMPUSES I
DON'T THINK THAT'S THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL AT ALL AND I THINK
YOUR COMMENTS FOR THE- AICC YOU
FOLKS WHO ARE LISTENING SHOULD
TAKE IT TO HEART. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE CAMPUSES DON'T
UNDULY- PROFILE OR INTIMIDATE
NEIGHBORHOOD FOLKS THIS BILL IS
INTENDED FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
CAUSING HARM OR POTENTIAL HARM
ON A CAMPUS THAT SOMEHOW MOSTLY
ARE RELATED TO THAT CAMPUS
WHETHER THAT'S A- DISGRUNTLED
EMPLOYEE WHETHER THAT'S
SOMEBODY WHO'S MADE THREATS.
THIS GIVES PRIVATE COLLEGES THE
SAME TOOLS THAT A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY HAS TO DEAL WITH
THOSE ISSUES SO THAT'S WHAT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS BUT I
THINK YOUR QUESTION IS TOTALLY
GERMANE TO THE CAMPUS LIFE AN
ATMOSPHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
DYNAMICS AND- YOU KNOW IS A
GOOD. IS A GOOD STATEMENT TO
HAVE THOSE COLLEGES BE THINKING
ABOUT. I WAS PART OF. THE DAY
AND- HI. I WOULD THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THAT IN MANY
INSTANCES AND I CAN THINK OF A
NUMBER OF COLLEGES- THAT ARE
WELL REGARDED WHERE TUITION IS
INCREDIBLY HIGH. THEY HAVE VERY
STRONG ALUMNI RELATIONS AND
FOLKS GOOD SEND THEIR KIDS
THERE BECAUSE THEY ARE
EXPECTING M. S. STELLAR
EDUCATION AND SAFETY. OFTEN
HAPPEN TO BE UP IN. LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND IS
REALLY BECAUSE OF AL YOU OF THE
LAND WAS SO LOW- YOU KNOW LONG
TIME AGO. AND SO. IT'S WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT FOLKS ARE THERE
YOU KNOW TO GET A GOOD
EDUCATION AND IT HAPPENS TO BE
A GREAT SCHOOL LOCATED IN I'M
AN INTERESTING URBAN SPACE IT
IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY STILL HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENGAGE AND TO
NOT PROFILE- AND TO NOT USE
THIS AS AN ADDITIONAL TOOL- TO
MAKE COMMUNITY MEMBERS FEEL
DISCONNECTED- FROM A SCHOOL
THAT HOPEFULLY WOULD WANT TO-
YOU KNOW ADMIT THEM WHEN
THEY'RE OF AGE TO GO TO THAT
SCHOOL OR EVEN WORK THERE SO I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT
BECAUSE- IT IT MADE ME THINK OF
CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH
STUDENTS ABOUT THE- ABOUT HOW
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE FELT OR
TREATED- BY THE INSTITUTIONS.
THANK YOU DEFINITELY A FAIR
COMMENT. SKINNER THANK YOU I
MISTER CHAIR AND- FIVE WHEN I
READ THE SYNOPSIS OF THE BILL
IT DIDN'T OCCUR TO ME TO ASK A
QUESTION THAT- THAT MS COM
ORDERS ARE SENATOR. BASED AND-
SO I GUESS I WOULD PUT IT A
DIFFERENT WAY AND ASK THE
AUTHOR WOOD THIS. WHEN I READ
IT I WAS LIKE OKAY THIS IS JUST
SAW. ALLOWING THE BENEFIT THAT
OTHER. COLLEGE CAMPUSES HALF
BUT- I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHETHER THIS. WOULD ALLOW FOR
CAMPUS FOR EXAMPLE. TO IN
EFFECT CLOSE ITSELF OFF IN
OTHER WORDS ENACT A RULE SUCH
THAT ONLY. STUDENTS REGISTERED
STUDENTS AND- OUR CAMPUS STAFF
WITH ID WOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE
THROUGH A CAMPUS AND THE REASON
I ASK IS INTERESTINGLY- THE
SENATORS AT. I GAVE THE EXAMPLE
OF U. S. C. AND WE'RE IT
SITUATED- I CAN GIVE THE
EXAMPLE OF THE COLLEGE IN MY
OWN TOWN UC BERKELEY WHICH
LITERALLY. UC BERKELEY IS AT
TELEGRAPH AVENUE ENDS RIGHT UC
BERKELEY. AND IN EFFECT IF YOU
WERE WALKING ACROSS THE CAMPUS
IT BEGINS AGAIN THOUGH NOT
UNDER THE SAME NAME BUT UNDER
THE NAME EUCLID AVENUE. ACROSS
THE CAMPUS AND- THE ONLY WAY IF
YOU'RE WALKING TO GET TO THOSE
SPOTS QUICKLY IS TO GO THROUGH
THE CAMPUS YOU YOU REALLY HAVE
OTHERWISE YOU WOULD HAVE TO GO
MANY MANY MANY BLOCKS OUT OF
YOUR WAY. AND INTERESTINGLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE
BECAUSE MOST PEDESTRIANS IN
BERKELEY USE THAT ROUTE. THE
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE CAMPUS.
BASICALLY SAID WELL THEY'RE
GOING TO CLOSE IT OFF SO THAT
NO PUBLIC COULD WALK THROUGH.
AND THERE WAS A HUGE UPROAR IN
MY COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF COURSE
THAT WOULD MAKE IT REALLY HARD
TO GET. TO IT I MEAN THERE IT'S
A SHOPPING DISTRICT IN SUCH- SO
THE UNIVERSITY PULLED BACK BUT
I'M JUST WONDERING WOOD. WITH
THIS BILL ALLOW SUCH PROVISION
BECAUSE I DID NOT LOOK AT IT
FROM THAT LEADS WHY I THINK WE
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL THAT THE
PICNIC IS DIFFERENT. THAN YOU
KNOW NORMAL ACTIVITY AND
COLLEGE CAMPUSES UNDER NORMAL
ACTIVITY HAVE SPORTING EVENTS-
WHICH THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
THEY HAVE AS I SAID THEATER
PRODUCTIONS- THEY HAVE
FACILITIES THEY HAVE. THE YOU
KNOW TRADITIONALLY COLLEGE
CAMPUSES HAVE A VERY STRONG
PUBLIC PRESENCE WITH THIS BILL
IS DESIGNED TO DO IS TO DEAL
WITH THAT PERSON WHO WAS BEING
DISRUPTIVE ON A CAMPUS WHO
POSES A THREAT. TO STUDENTS ON
THAT CAMPUS AND I WOULD ARGUE
THAT MANY OF THE PRIVATE
COLLEGES ARE ACTUALLY MORE
DIVERSE. STUDENT POPULATIONS
UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY SO THIS IS
PROTECTING ALL STUDENTS FROM
THAT POTENTIAL HARMFUL ACT IT'S
NOT GIVING THEM THE TOOLS TO
BORDER. THEIR COLLEGE CAMPUSES
FROM THE PUBLIC INTERACTION
WHICH. IS NOT A NORMAL COURSE
OF EVENTS ON DIFFICULT CAMPUSES.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S A WE HAVE
TO AT AND FOR EXAMPLE BERKELEY
HAS THE TOOLS WERE STANFORD
DOESN'T. CALCULATE CAL STATE LA
HAS THE TOOL WHERE USC DOESN'T
THIS IS JUST PROVIDING PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THEIR STUDENTS SAFE. FROM
THAT OF ABERRATION. PERSON WHO
POSES OF IMMINENT THREAT TO THE
WELFARE OF THOSE STUDENTS UNDER
THE CURRENT SYSTEM THAT PERSON
CAN KEEP COMING BACK AD
INFINITUM. AND POTENTIALLY YOU
KNOW WITH A WEAPON. AND HURT
SOMEBODY AND SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS SEEKING TO DO IT'S
NOT SEEKING TO PUT A WALL
AROUND CAMPUS. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
BOB SENATOR I WOULD JUST GO
BACK TO THE QUESTION THAT-
CENTER COM MODERATES AS IT
RELATES TO- USC IN THE
SURROUNDING AREAS AND JUST
USING THAT AS AN EXAMPLE AND
YOUR RESPONSE WAS LESS THE
DEFINITIVE OF WHAT I WOULD HAVE
HOPED YOU SAID I HOPE THAT'S
NOT THE INTENT VERSUS BEING
DEFINITIVE TO SAY THAT IS NOT
DOWN TO THAT IS IF I SAID HOPE
IT THAT IS NOT OKAY. I WAS JUST
TALKING TO A LITTLE CONCERNED
THAT. YOU MIGHT NOT SURE. THE
CONCERNS AT THE CENTRE REYES
WILL BE ADDRESSED HERE SO
LET'S. WE ALL WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. IT IS OPENS BECAUSE I'VE
KNOWN THAT COMMUNITY SINCE I
WAS A LITTLE KID AND YOU KNOW
I. RELATIVES LIVED IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND YET. THE
SUPPLY ON THAT CAMPUS AND
WITHOUT ANY THOUGHTS AND FEARS
OF BEING A ROUTE SO I HOPE THAT
WOULD NOT BE THE CASE TODAY
NOT. OKAY HEARING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS SENATOR
WHICH ELECT CLOSE- I THINK THE
CONVERSATION WAS VERY IMPORTANT
I THINK THE COMMENTS WERE.
QUITE GERMANE AND I HOPE. THE
COLLEGES ON THE PHONE OR
LISTENING YOU KNOW WE WANT OUR
COLLEGES DID BE SAFE WELCOMING
INSTITUTIONS TO SERVE THE YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. Q. WE A TO
PASS TO REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON CORPORATIONS I
DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL GET OUT OF
THAT COMMITTEE BUT I- CAN WE
GET A MOTION. FOUR SB SEVEN
FOUR EIGHT. SO MOVED BY CENTER
CAR MARKER. CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON IT SB. SEVEN
FOUR EIGHT. SB SEVEN FOUR EIGHT
BRADFORD HI REDFORD I'D SHOW
BOTH I FOR THE BOGO I CALM
WATER I AM LONGER AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE WIENER WIENER AYE
FIVE ZERO. THAT MEASURE HAS
FIVE GOALS CONGRADULATIONS THE
TOWN. SINNERS WIENER YOU OR
NAQSH.
CENTERS GENERAL ANYWAY
I'M SORRY CENTER WINNER WHEN
YOU'RE PREPARED YOU HAVE SB
FIVE NINETEENTHS. SEP FIVE
NINETEEN FIRST. FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN OKAY ARE AGAINST SB FIFTY
SEVEN I'M SORRY THE TRIP TO
GHANA I'M ALWAYS HAPPY TO BE
CENTERS SKINNER WILL BE AN
HONOR- THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
COLLEAGUES ARE SENATE BILL
FIFTY SEVEN. WILL HELP US TO
ADDRESS THE ONGOING- SPITE-
WHICH HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
YEARS AND IS NOW ACCELERATING
OF. OVERDOSE THE OVERDOSES AND
OVERDOSE DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA.
BY ALLOWING BUT NOT MANDATING.
SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTIES IF THEY
DECIDE. NOT BE ABILITY TO
AUTHORIZE OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS ALSO KNOWN AS SAFE
CONSUMPTION SITES- THIS SET
CONSUMPTION SITES ARE PROGRAMS.
WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL CAN USE A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF STAFF WHO ARE
TRAINED TO PREVENT AND TREAT
OVERDOSES AND ALSO TO PREVENT
HIV AND HEPATITIS INFECTION AND
FACILITATE ENTRY INTO SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT AND
OTHER RECOVERY SERVICES- AND
OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES- SIX
CONSUMPTION SITES ARE A
CRITICAL INTERVENTION TO
PREVENT OVERDOSE DEATHS.
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY OF THESE SITES EXIST IN
TEN COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
THEY HAVE BEEN RIGOROUSLY
STUDIED FOR YEARS AND THEY HAVE
BEEN SHOWN OVER AND OVER AGAIN
TO REDUCE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH DRUG
USE. INCLUDING PUBLIC DRUG USE.
TO REDUCE SURRENDER LETTER. TO
REDUCE HIV AND HEPATITIS
INFECTIONS AND TO REDUCE
OVERDOSE THOSE DEATHS. THAT IS
ONE PER AND ONLY TURN YOUR CALL
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. MODERATOR
OKAY. NINE ZERO AT AT THE ONE I
AND SEVENTY- SIX CONSUMPTION
SITES AROUND THE WORLD SOME OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR
DECADES THERE HAS NEVER NOT
ONCE BEEN A RECORDED ONLY
NINETEEN BUSINESS TELLING SUCH
SUPPLEMENTS KILEY I'M
UNAVAILABLE TO TAKE YOUR CALL
AT THE TONE PLEASE RECORD MY.
BAT PERHAPS THE WATER TO QUIT.
YOU YEAH. BLINDS YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OKAY R. P. THOUSAND
IMPORTANT POINTS I GOT
INTERRUPTED AT THESE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SITES
AROUND THE WORLD THAT HAVE BEEN
OPERATING FOR YEARS AND YEARS
THERE HAS NEVER ONCE NOT ONCE
BEEN RECORDED OVERDOSE DEATH.
COMPARE THAT TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON OUR STREETS RIGHT
NOW WE'RE IN SAN FRANCISCO
ALONE WE HAD SEVEN HUNDRED
OVERDOSE DEATHS LAST YEAR. AND
THE SAME IS HAPPENING AROUND
THE STATE. BY THESE SITES.
REDUCE THE SEARCH REDUCE
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS SO
INSTEAD OF GOING TO AN
EMERGENCY ROOM. PEOPLE ARE
TAKING CARE OF THE REDUCES
PRESSURE ON OUR HOSPITALS
REDUCE HIS PARAMEDIC CALLS WE
KNOW THAT IN MANY OF OUR CITIES
ARE FOR OUR FIRE DEPARTMENT OR
PARAMEDICS ARE HAVING TO SPEND
A LOT OF TIME DEALING WITH DRUG
USE ISSUES- THIS PREVENTS THOSE.
WE NO FROM THE STUDY SAID
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAM
SAFE CONSUMPTION SITES I DO NOT
INCREASE CRIME IN FACT THERE'S
SOME INDICATION THAT THEY
REDUCE CRIME IN THE
SURROUNDING. AREA. THERE IS A
REDUCTION IN SYRINGE LITTER WE
KNOW THAT IT IS A PROBLEM WHEN
PEOPLE USE SYRINGES AND DROP
THEM. ON THE GROUNDS. AND THEY
INCREASE ENTRY INTO RECOVERY
PROGRAMS. MANY SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. SIJSLING BECAUSE BY
THESE SITES HELP TRANSITION
PEOPLE INTO RECOVERY. WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A CRISIS ON OUR
HANDS WITH WITH SUBSTANCE USE
AND OVERDOSE DEATHS THE
PANDEMIC IS MAKING IT WORSE.
TOM WE HAVE STAFF AND THAT IS
WHY WE ARE SEEING RECORD OVER
THOSE STUFFS AND CITIES AROUND
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
ON SOME INCLUDING IN THE
OPPOSITION. TALK AS THEY OFTEN
DO THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW. GOING
TO INCREASE DRUG USE OR
FACILITATE DRUG USE OR
NORMALIZED ARGUES WE NEED TO BE
CLEAR THE DRUG USE IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND PARTICULARLY
HAPPENING ON OUR STREETS ON OUR
SIDEWALKS IN FRONT OF PEOPLE'S
HOMES IN PARKS. IN BUSINESSES
BEHIND DUMPSTERS AND ALL SORTS
OF PLACES WHERE IT IS ON
SANITARY- AND UNHEALTHY. AND WE
KNOW FROM INTERVIEWS- THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO INJECT IN
PUBLIC PRECISELY BECAUSE- THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF THEY
OVERDOSE THAT PEOPLE WILL SEE
THEM AND SOMEONE WILL BE ABLE
TO SAVE THEM. WE KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING LET'S MAKE IT SAFER
AND HEALTHIER BY GIVING PEOPLE
THE ABILITY TO MOVE INSIDE INTO
A CLEAN AND HEALTHY CITING. SO
IF THEY DO OVERDOSE SOMEONE
WILL BE THERE TO REVERSE THAT
OVERDOSE OR TO SEND THEM TO AN
ER- IF NECESSARY- AND LET'S
HELP THEM DEVELOP THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH PEOPLE WHO
CAN HELP GET THEM INTO. A
RECOVERY PROGRAM- WE- WE HAVE
GREAT SPONSORS ON THIS BILL.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES- AND OTHER GREAT CO
SPONSORS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY OR DAVID KAHN
MD IS AN ADDICTION. THE AND
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE AND VICA EISEN WHO IS
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF HEALTH
RIGHT THREE SIXTY AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM. EXECUTIVES THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU
SENATOR AT WIENER WILL NOW
BEGIN WITH THE LEAD- SUPPORT
WITNESSES- EITHER DOCTOR CON OR
A DOCTOR AISIN. I'LL LET YOU
DECIDE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
FIRST. SATURDAY BECOMING CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES SIR. THANK YOU.
WELL I'M DOCTOR DAVID KAHN AND
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY AND IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE
AND CHEAPAIR WHAT BUT JUST
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T FOR SHORT.
SENT SIX HUNDRED AND OVER SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY POSITION AT
ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
OVER THE VOICE OF DETECTION
TREATMENT. OR PRAKRIT PONSORS
IT'S CRITICAL LEGISLATION.
PEOPLE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
REQUIRE TIME TO CHANGE WE NEED
TO MATCH AVAILABILITY OF
TREATMENT SERVICES WITH THE
DEMAND. BUT THE FIRST LAST AND
MOST ENDURING TASK WITH THE
ACTION TREATMENT JUST TO KEEP
IT ALIVE. WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF
AN OVERDOSE CRISIS AS WE NOW.
AND THE HOPE IT HAS AMPLE BY
THE ATTACK THAT SCORED TIMES
NOW PEOPLE GUIDANCE AT THE
DISCO FROM DRUG OVERDOSE THANK
OPEN. I THE OPPORTUNITY TO A
NUMBER DOES PREVENT PRO. AND A
REMINDER ME OF THE TREE CENTERS
THAT PROVIDE MYSELF. THE
PARTICIPANTS ARE TREATED WITH
RESPECT AND DECENCY. THEY HAVE
A IN THE IMPACT PROGRAM IN
VANCOUVER THEY HAVE OVER
HUNDRED FORTY SIX A DAY BUT
THEY'RE GOING CORD EIGHT
OVERDOSE ROBERT EVERY DAY. THE
MEDICAL LITERATURE OVER HIS
PROGRAMS CLEAR IT REDUCES
PUBLIC USE DISCARDED CARELESSLY.
SYRINGES SEVEN AT CRIME
REDUCING THEIR- AND H. AND HAVE
C. AND REDUCE. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY OVERDOSE BURKE
PROGRAMS STATE NEED A ONE
HUNDRED AUTOMATIC CARE THESE
ARE NOT THE PATIENTS AT HIGH
SPEED PEOPLE ARE OVER. FROM
HOME IN THE AND THEY ARE YOU
KNOW OUR WRITERS BECOME
REPORTING BURKE- BURKE HAS. BUT
STATEMENT I'M SORRY INTERRUPT
AND SHORT OVER TO NOT. YOU KNOW
MEAN THAT AT. DR COM I'M SO
WITH THE WOULD WE'RE GETTING
SOME RECEIVING FEEDBACK WHICH
MAKING IT. TO YOUR TO. HE YOU
WOULDN'T MIND HOLDING WHILE WE
TRY TO THE IS. MEDEVACED EITHER
IS IT BECAUSE THIS HAVE OVER
AND OVER IN A POTS FOR THEM.
TIM YOU EVERY OTHER THAN THE
SPEAKING AT THE MOMENT I WE
COULD THAT IT WE CAN ACTUALLY
GO THROUGH WITH ALL THE
SPEAKERS IF YOU LIKE USE THEIR
LINES COULD THAT THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING THEY'RE NOT USING
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THIS HAPPENS
AT ALL THE PEOPLE TESTIFYING.
WE APPRECIATE THAT MODERATOR
WOULD YOU MIND. GETTING. ALL
THE CALLERS UNTIL THEIR TURN.
ABSOLUTE AND THEN I WILL HAVE
TO OPEN TO SET THEIR TURN WORK
THANK YOU JUST GIVE US A COUPLE
SECONDS PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU MODERATOR THANK YOU DOCTOR
CONDUCT WHICH ALSO OUR WORK.
YES WOULD YOU MISTER WHERE I
WAS. AT I THINK I WAS BEING
TALKED OVER SO- THE MEDICAL
LITERATURE AN OVERDOSE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS CLEAR. IT
REDUCES PUBLIC DRUG USE
CARELESSLY DISCARDED SYRINGE
AND THERE'S EVIDENCE A
REDUCTION OF CRIME IN THE AREA.
WE CAN REDUCE HIV AND HEPATITIS
C. INFECTIONS. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS PROVIDE SAFETY PEOPLE
OR NOT INTERSTITIAL MEDICAL
CARE. SINCE BUT I DON'T SEE BUT
HE CAN BECOME THE PATIENT BUT I
WILL SAY. PEOPLE PARK AT IN THE-
30% MORE LIKELY TO ENTER
DETOXIFICATION OR CONDITIONAL
TREAT. IN SHORT BARCA'S
PREVENTION PROGRAMS DISTRICT
TREATMENT AND THAT IS WHY THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE URGING HERE I PUT IN
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR CON. WELL NOW HERE
FROM LEAD WITNESS DR EISEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
VICTOR HIGH THEN THE CITY HELP
BREAK THREE SIXTY SAN FRANCISCO
ONE OF THE LARGEST EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES THIS ORDER TREATMENT
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT ON THE BOARD OF
CAT PEE STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
OF SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AND I'M A FORMER GIVE
ME I'M A FORMER INJECTING
HEROIN USER AND HAVE BEEN
WORKING IN THE. FIELD FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. ADDICTION TREAT
HAS OF ALL OVER THE YEARS IN A
CO WITH THE LAW. TREATMENT BUT
IT IS NOT. IN THE SAME WAY
EVERYONE. FOR THOSE WHOM WE
HAVE NOW ACCEPTED REACHED. WE
NEED TO BE WILLING TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENTLY FROM A
TREATMENT PROVIDER PERSPECTIVE.
YOU HAVE TO CRITICAL. TO REACH
THOSE WE HAVE NOT REACHED AND
TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM DYING
BEFORE WE CAN REACH THEM IT IS
THAT SIMPLE. A LOT OF COUNTRIES
PROVIDED WE SEE THOSE SERVICES
AS THE MISSING ELEMENT IN A
CONTINUUM OF TRADE IN SERVICES.
HELLO WHO SAY WE SHOULD BE
SPENDING MORE MONEY ON TRIPS
AND WE SAY YES WE SHOULD. HI
THIS IS A PART OF TRIPLE THAT
IS A FALSE DICHOTOMY TO SAY. WE
DO ONE WE ARE NOT COMMITTED TO
THE OTHER. THERE IS A
PREVAILING MYTH THAT PEOPLE WHO
STRUGGLE WITH AN ADDICTION.
MUST HIT BOTTOM BEFORE THEY
SEEK RECOVERY. WELL LET ME THE
BOND THAT NEEDS FOR YOU. MANY
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE WITH THEIR
DRUG YOU ARE LIVING IN ABJECT
MISERY WE CANNOT MAKE THEM FOR
SHOULD WE MAKE THEM MORE
MISERABLE. IT ONLY LEADS FOR
THEIR DRUG USE. CRIMINALIZATION
AND INCARCERATION PROGRAM
MONSTER WE FAILED POLICY
RESPONSES. TO ADDICTION ONLY
SLOWING OUR PRISON POPULATION.
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITY. AND COUNTLESS PEOPLE
DIED ON THEIR WAY TO THE
POLITICAL BOTTOM NEVER GETTING
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR TREATMENT
YOU KNOW MISERY AND SHAME DO
NOT LEAD PEOPLE TO RECOVERY.
ONLY HOPE IN CONNECTION WITH
THE HEALING. PREVENTION
PROGRAMS BUILD CONNECTION AND
LEAD TO HOPE LINKING PEOPLE TO
CARE. EVALUATION OF WHETHER
SUCH PROGRAMS IN CANADA HAVE
SHOWN THIS TO BE TRUE THIS IS A
LIFE OR DEATH MATTER.
LEGISLATURE HEARD A BILL LIKE
THIS ONE AND 200-017-1800
PEOPLE HAVE DIED OF A DRUG
OVERDOSE IN SAN FRANCISCO
ALONE. I'M MORE HAVE DIED IN
TAMPA DIFFICULT MOBILITY
INCLUDING. NINETEEN CONTRACT
MARCH. I THIS IS THE URGENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND- IT IS TO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. PLEASE
VOTE YES IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. RIGHT THAT WAS
R. TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE HEARING ROOM HERE
AND FORTY TWO OH THREE OR THEIR
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT WANT
WISHING TO TESTIFY CHAIN KNOWN
COMING FORTH. LET'S GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM A TWENTY FORTY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- NO ONE
THERE. MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES AND DO WE HAVE
WITNESSES QUEUED UP. TWENTY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED BY.
ZERO ONE MOMENT AS PARTICIPANTS
QUEUE UP. AND OUR FIRST WINE
WILL COME BE LIKE ONE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JENNA HEY WOULD WITH
THE NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT WE WILL ALIGN
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CARE NUMBERS TYLER IN
THE WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SADDAM SB. FIFTY
SEVEN. NINE ONE SIXTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING DONNA
SITES REPRESENTING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IMPORTED SB THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM WEINBERGER ON
BEHALF OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. SIX
TWO ONE ONE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
GOING BACK AS FOR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEVENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
MORNING CATHERINE FROM HOUSING
CALIFORNIA'S THE COURT SB FIFTY
SEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD NINE
FIFTY FIVE. ONE FIFTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. HELLO WORKING RIGHT
ALEXANDER CAMPOS WITH THE
FUTURE CONVENTIONS FOUNDATION
OTHER TO VOTE YES ON THIS TOPIC.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SIX. RELAY HERE FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS- SB
SEVEN THANK YOU ARE. NINE ONE
SIX PLEASE AHEAD. LARCOM THAT
THAT THEY'VE BEEN WITHOUT IT
FOUNDATION WERE ON TO BE A CUT
ANSWER IN FRONT FOR. THANK YOU
ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHARLES WALTON ON BEHALF OF
PART COULD BE ACTED BAY RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE. EIGHTY TWO. ONE EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE ON MUTE. ONE EIGHTY
TWO. WELL THE ONE WITH A LINE.
ONE FIFTY SIX. ONE ONE FIFTY
SIX. ONE ONE FIFTY SIX
COMMUTERS. WE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SIX
WHO ALIGN WITH TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MOVING ON WITH A LINE ONE
SEVENTY TWO. SEMENTARA FIRST
MAR DR CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE FORTY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. PINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE ON MUTE. THEN
POLICY NEEDS FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TO THAT BUT BEING
ON BEHALF OF DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE AS A CO SPONSOR AND
INSTRUCT. THEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
UNMUTE. BUILDING ALONG WITH
OVERLYING SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CARL TANNENBAUM AND RETIRED
SERVICE THE POLICE SERGEANT AND
CURRENT MEMBER OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
COMPASSIONATE HUMANE BILL FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE. ONE SEVENTY FOUR. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES. LITTLEWOOD
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE ONE
FIFTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. ONE
FIFTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE ON
YOU. WELL BEING ALONG WITH ALLY
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CARLOS BLOWS ALL THAT CHAIR
BECOME ALLIES NATURE- CALLING
ONE ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS TERRY BLEVINS
FORMER LOCAL AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER NOW A
MEMBER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTION PARTNERSHIP I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AN EXCELLENT
LINE. ONE SEVENTY ONE. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES GREAT
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
CATHERINE CALLING WITH THE
NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CELL THANK YOU. WHY ONE OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CANACCORD ARE NOW ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. SIX OVER LINE. ONE
FORTY ONE. ONE ONE FORTY ONE
THE GREAT TOOK THEMSELVES OUT
OF QUEUE NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS NINA CHRISTY I'M
A PHD STUDENT AT USC AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT. NEXT TO
A LINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHTY TWO PLEASE ON
MUTE. ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL GO
BACK AND TRY TO GET LINE ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONLY. NINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
ON YOUR. HELLO THIS IS COLIN
WELLS- REPRESENTING VETERANS
WALK AND TALK AND I AM A FORMER
OPIATE USER AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. S. THANK YOU AND LINE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MY NEIGHBOR FROM D.
CRIME CALIFORNIA KOREAN STRONG
SUPPORTER THANK YOU. BLIND ONE
FIFTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS ROBERT STANLEY ON
HEALTHCARE LIFE SCIENCE
RESEARCH OR RECOGNIZING THE
STRONG RESEARCH SHOWING
POSITIVE IMPACT ON ADDICTION
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PLEASE DON'T YOU WORRY.
YES HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN GOOD MORNING I'M SANDRA
ARNOLD THE LOCAL DON'T.
ACTIVATION I'M CALLING FOR A
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF NATIVE
AMERICAN CHURCHES AND THE
INDIGENOUS PURITY CONSERVATION
INITIATIVE WILL SHOW ME SUPPORT
SB FIVE ONE NINE YUP THE
BECAUSE IT PROTECTS THE
INDIGENT POD IN SOUTH TEXAS BY
NOT LEGALIZING OR
DECRIMINALIZING PURELY IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY ONE FIFTY PLEASE ON
YOU. NOT RESPONDING ONE MORE
TRY ONE FIFTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
AND A FINAL REMINDER IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO OUR MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS BILL IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING REPORT THERE
WOULD BE GROW CALIFORNIA'S
BORDERS. THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY
TO YOUR OWN BUT. PLEASE ON YOU
EIGHTY TWO. I NEEDED. TO WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR OPEN MIND. SIXTY
YES HI MY NAME IS LUCAS MARTIN
I'M NOT A STATE CERTIFIED DRUG
AND ALCOHOL COUNSELOR- MAC
COUNSELOR TO A TARZANA
TREATMENT CENTERS AND A
MASTER'S STUDENT AT JOHNS
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
ONE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE MISTER CHAIR. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN. YES I AM A REGISTERED
NURSE AND I ONE HUNDRED AND
SORT OF GO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. PLEASE ON MUTE. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT. MY NAME IS AARON THERE'S
SOME UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS
WAR VETERAN- VETERANS HEALTH
CARE ADVOCATE OUT OF SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA AND JOHN THE BOARD.
MISTER THANK YOU MISTER SHOWS
NO THE PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME. YOU NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO OPPOSITION WE
HAVE TO LEAVE- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FIRST UP IS RYAN
SHERMAN AND WE HAVE JOHN LOWELL
THEY'LL BOTH BE GIVEN TWO
MINUTES EACH MISTER CHAIRMAN.
CENTER SOME OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THE BILL ONCE FOR
SB FIVE NINETEEN THE NEXT BILL
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF THE
MODERATOR. COULD ASK FOR
COMMENT AND NAME THE BILLS TO
SO BECAUSE OTHERWISE PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE CALLING
IN FOR. AND SO I JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
RECOGNITION. THANK YOU WE HEARD
THAT YEAH. OKAY I CAN DO THAT-
SO WE RIGHT NOW WE ARE I'M- TO
REITERATE WHAT'S BILL. P. FIVE
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE TAKING
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE SEVEN AT THIS POINT. WOULD
YOU LIKE US TO START OPENING
LINES FOR THOSE. BUT WE ARE A
PRIMARY WITNESS DO WE NOT HAVE
RYAN SHERMAN. OPPOSITION PLEASE
TRY TO FIND YOUR LIFE HE MIGHT
BE MUTED NOW ONE SECOND PLEASE.
BRIAN SHERMAN. THIS IS JOHN
LEVEL. WELL TO JOHN LEVEL IN
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING- JOHN
LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE-
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION- CONGRESS OF RACIAL
EQUALITY INTERNATIONAL TRADE
SPACE COALITION- IN OPPOSITION
BUT I WANT TO MAKE VERY CLEAR
THAT THE PEOPLE I REPRESENT DO
NOT UNDERLINE DO NOT OPPOSE
INJECTION SITES- AS A MATTER
OF- AS A PERSON A MATTER. IN
FACT- I EVEN REACHED OUT TO THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE- IN THE WINTER-
ASKING FOR A MEETING TO SEE IF
WE COULDN'T FIND SOME COMMON
GROUND. UNHAPPILY THAT MEETING
HASN'T HAPPENED BUT PEOPLE OF
BC I GET THAT ONE OTHER QUICK
POINT BY HONORING RESPECTIVELY
CREDENTIALS THE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES- BUT I AM ALSO
BLESSED WITH AN EXPERT ON
ADDICTION- MY WIFE THIS PAST
SUNDAY. JUST CELEBRATED HER
THIRTY SIX YEAR OLD POINT BEING
CLEAN AND SOBER AND I'VE RELIED
HEAVILY ON HER TRUE EXPERTISE
ON ADDICTION OKAY HERE'S WHAT
WE KNOW. IN CANADA- THE-
INJECTION SITES ARE UNDER
UTILIZED IN THERE ARE SOLUTIONS
TO. ADDRESS THAT BUT THEY'RE
NOT ADDRESSED IN CANADA THEY'RE
NOT ADDRESSED HERE IN HIS
RESULTS B. OR BUT AROUND
INJECTION SITES BEACOM HAIFA
PALICKI. FOR EXAMPLE IN CANADA
IN THE ORBIT AROUND THE
INJECTION SITE THERE'S A 64%
INCREASE. IN OVERDOSE DEATHS.
YOU ARE HAVE SEARING COPE WITH
NINE NATIONS AGAIN INTENDED.
THE DOWN TO EAST. WHICH IS THE
LOCATION OF. INJECTION SITE HAS
THE HIGHEST COLD WOULD NINETEEN
RATE IN ALL OF THE PROVINCE OF
VICTORIA. NEED LEGAL PROBLEMS
EXIST THROUGHOUT ALBERTA
PROVINCE IN CANADA- IN FREEZER
CHEST ON HAPPY REALITIES THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED- THIS BILL
DOES NOT HAVE A WAY OF
ADDRESSING THE UNDER
UTILIZATION OF INJECTION SITES
THE- PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE IN
CANADA IN VANCOUVER- WHO USE
INJECTION SITES CONSISTENTLY IS
ONLY FIVE PERCENT. EVERYONE
ELSE IS USING. IS INJECTING IN
THE ORBITS AROUND. THE INSIDE
LOCATION IN FACT THERE'S A
PICTURE THAT WAS TAKEN BUT I'LL
BE HAPPY TO SHARE AT SOME POINT-
THAT SHOWS ALL THE WHOLE HOST
OF DRUG USERS STREET DRUG USERS
SHOOTING UP IN FRONT OF. THE
CANADIAN- SITE IN IN VANCOUVER-
THREE. THREE THIS BILL NEED TO
ADDRESS THE- ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN READY BY THE INJECT SITE
IN IN CANADA BECAUSE TO NOT
ADDRESS THEM MEANS THAT
INTERACT WITH OF THIS WOULD
REDUCE ON HAND. IN THE SAME YES
THAT EXCEED YOU IN A THE SITE
IN- YOU KNOW- IN BEGIN- OBJECT
OR ACROSS. INTO WE READY TO
WORK IN A SOLVE WAY TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT- YES THEY ARE NOT
ADDRESSED WE CAN LOOK FOR A
VERY UNHAPPY REPETITION OF WHAT
IS GOING ON IN THOSE SITES AND
WHAT WE STAND READY TO HAVE
CONSTRUCTIVE PROBLEM SOLVING
DISCUSSIONS WE HOPE THEY DO
OCCUR AT SOME POINT THANK YOU
THANK. YOU NOT TO ADDRESS. FROM
I NEED TO NAP- ALL RIGHT THEN
LET'S MOVE TO OUR NEW WITNESSES
HERE AND- FORTY TWO OH THREE
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
I MEAN IN OPPOSITION OF- SB
FIVE SEVEN HERE AND IN THIS
ROOM. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND- YOUR ORGANIZATION MY NAME
IS TACK ALLEN I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF THE INTERNATIONAL FAITH
BASED COALITION AS WELL AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CONGRESS OF
RACIAL EQUALITY AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESSES OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE AND- A- FORTY
TWO OH THREE IN OPPOSITION. I
MEAN NO ONE ELSE COMING FOR IT
LET'S MOVE TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
A TWENTY FORTY WITH THIS IN
OPPOSITION SEE NO ONE THERE.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES ANNOUNCED THOSE
WITNESSES. WANTING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO PLEASE QUEUE
UP AT THIS TIME. SHE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION S. B.
FIFTY SEVEN THIS PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME- BUT FIRST A
LITTLE COME THROUGH THE LINE OF
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS AN
EAGLE- DELUCA ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF OAKLAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I GOT SKIPPED OVER.
WHEN I WAS WAITING- BUT I WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
AND APPRECIATE BEING PART OF
THIS PILOT. ALL RIGHT WE ARE
NOW TAKING OPPOSITION MISTER
MODERATOR MAKE SURE WE HAVE
OPPOSITION CUED UP THE TO START.
THANK YOU. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
BILL SB FIFTY SEVEN SB FIFTY
SEVEN IN OPPOSITION. OUR ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. I
WOULD LIKE TO ABOUT FOURTEEN
GENTLEMEN THAT FOLKS ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS IN CANADA NINETEEN
IS MEANINGLESS IN AND I AM A
CANADIAN CITIZEN LIVING HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES THE PERMANENT
RESIDENT AND I HAVE LIVED IN
VANCOUVER DOWNTOWN AND HAS SEEN
EXACTLY AND HAS- STEEN THE FACT-
WHAT THE JOB TRUMP ABOUT WITH
THE OVER. AND THE UTILIZED
NATION AND DO STRONGLY ALTHOUGH
I DO THINK A GREAT I AND THERE
HAS TO BE MUCH DONE TO
DISPATCHES CAN AND YOUR. THANK
YOU. TO A SIX WILL ALIGN ONE
MAY SEVEN. MY NAME MERRY WE
STRIDES UNDER OF MY LICENSE
CURRENT CAN IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND AS A
FINAL REMINDER IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
ONLY AT THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR BILL
S. B. FIFTY SEVEN. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUING UP. I
WOULD JUST ASK ONE MORE TIME.
MAKE SURE WE GET EVERYONE HERE
YOU. OKAY AS A FINAL REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO BILL SB. FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NOW LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS
IT RELATES SB FIVE SEVEN. THE
AUTHOR. SCENE NINE IT SENATOR
OR TROUBLED. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. ANDCOMMONS- WITH
REGARDS TO THIS BILL- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN TO- VETOED A SIMILAR
BILL- IN PART SEVERAL CONCERNS
BUT ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
THEY MENTIONED WAS THE UNITED
STATES ATTORNEY GENERAL
THREATENING SOME PROSECUTION DO
WE KNOW WORK THE- IF. YOU HAVE
RECEIVED ANY MESSAGING OR ANY
INFORMATION AS FAR AS HOW THE
NOTICES ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD
FEEL ABOUT. IMPLEMENTING THESE
THIS BILL HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I
YES EXCUSE ME- IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- SADLY GOVERNOR AROUND
I'VE ENORMOUS RESPECT FOR
GOVERNOR BROWN BUT HE WAS JUST
DEAD WRONG WHEN HE VETOED OUT
OUR PARTICULAR BILL BY THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SUSAN EGGMAN-
AND WITH A PRETTY MUCH A JUST
SAY NO- MESSAGE WHICH- WE'VE
KNOWN FOR FIFTY FOR FIFTY YEARS
A PRACTICE JUST DOESN'T WORK.
ON THAT WAS A- A THREAT FROM
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION- THE-
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SUED
PHILADELPHIA TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION MADE THREATS
AGAINST OUR CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE
A NEW ADMINISTRATION NOW THAT
TAKES A LOT MORE FORWARD
LOOKING. APPROACH TO MANY
HEALTH ISSUES AND SO WE HAVE
NOT DONE OF ANY STATEMENTS-
FROM THE BITING HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION- BUT I SUSPECT.
WE WILL HAVE A MORE- MORE OR
LESS COST APPROACH BUT I WE
HAVENO COMMUNITY. FROM THEM.
KEEP IN MIND THAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THIS WITH CANNABIS
WHERE THERE WERE TIMES WHEN WE
HAD HOSTILE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS BUT WE STILL
WERE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD. AND
DO WE HAVE ANY MODELS OF THIS
BILL. IN PLACE IN OTHER STATES
HERE IN THE US AND ALSO JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS- THE TWO
SIDES WOULD VIOLATE FEDERAL
LAW. AND THAT IS CURRENTLY
BEING LITIGATED AND THERE WAS A
DISTRICT COURT DECISION IN
PHILADELPHIA STATING THAT THEY
DON'T VIOLATE FEDERAL LAW
THAT'S BEEN DISPUTED ON APPEAL
KNAUS- SO- IN TERMS OF OUR
MODELS NO IT'S NEVER. BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IN THE U. US IN
IMPLEMENTER ON THE WORLD THERE
IS ONE STUDY. THAT CAME OUT OF
A- MORE OF AN UNDERGROUND SORRY
THAT WAS NOT LEGAL. WE DON'T
KNOW WHERE IT WAS- BUT THEY'D
COLLECTED A LOT OF DATA I HAVE
VERY POSITIVE RESULTS
CONSISTENT WITH RESULTS THAT
WE'VE SEEN AROUND THE WORLD.
FIVE- I KNOW OVER THOSE DEATHS.
REDUCING A HEALTH PROBLEMS. AND
SO ON AND SO FORTH. DO YOU HAVE
ANY DATA WITH REGARDS TO THE-
SOCIAL CULTURAL- UNDERSTANDING
YOUR PERCEPTIONS OF DRUG USE.
AS FAR AS WHAT I MEAN BY THAT
IS- AS FAR AS HAS THE
PERCEPTION OR THE ACCEPTANCE OF
DRUG USE INCREASED DECREASED
WITHIN THAT CULTURAL- SOCIETY
OKAY I DON'T THINK THAT IT DID
THE SITES INCREASE OR DECREASE-
DESIRE RECEPTIVITY TO DRUG USE
HAVING TO BE APPROACH HERE IS
THAT DRUG USE IS WHAT IT IS.
PEOPLE USE DRUGS FOR MANY MANY
DIFFERENT REASONS- THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO WILL USE DRUGS THEIR
WHOLE LIFE THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
VERY MUCH WANT TO STOP USING.
DRUGS AND THE GOAL IS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE REALITY OF THE
WORLD BUT PEOPLE USE DRUGS WE
TRIED TO THROW PEOPLE IN JAIL
THAT DIDN'T WORK. WE TRIED TO
BERATE PEOPLE TO JUST SAY NO
THAT DIDN'T WORK- AND
RECOGNIZING THE REALITY THE
IDEA IS HOW DO WE MAKE IT SO
THAT FEWER PEOPLE- OVERDOSE AND
DIE SO THE FEWER PEOPLE GET HIV
AND HEPATITIS. HOW DO WE MAKE
IT TO THE PEOPLE ARE INJECTING
ON THE SIDEWALK WHERE PEOPLE
WALKING BY WITH THEIR CHILDREN-
HOW DO WE HELP FACILITATE
PEOPLE AND THE RECOVERY OF
BALLOTS WHERE THEY WANT TO GO.
AND THESE PROGRAMS HAVE SHOWN
THAT THEY DO ALL OF THAT- AND
SERVE I DON'T IT DOESN'T
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT IT
INCREASES DRUG USE THERE IS AN
INDICATION THAT IT HELPS THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE GET INTO
RECOVERY. SO THEY USE DRUGS
LESS OR MAYBE STOPPERS ARE LIKE.
THE BILL DOES NOT MANDATE
TREATMENT ONCE YOU'RE USING ARE
YOUR ALLOWED TO USE WITHIN
THESE FACILITIES RIGHT THE BILL
IS NOT MANDATORY MEN- MANDATING
TREATMENT- YOU KNOW IT IS IT IS
NOT- FACTORS TYPICALLY- FOR
MOST PEOPLE- THERE MIGHT BE.
SOME EXTREME CASES WHERE- WHERE
WHERE YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER
DIFFERENT OPTIONS BUT FOR THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE USING
DRUGS. MANDATING TREATMENT
ISN'T PROBABLY GOING TO HELP
THEM WHAT DOES HELP THEM IS TO
OFFER THEM RESOURCES AND
SERVICES. AND TO STOP THEM FROM
OVERDOSING AND DYING. YOU KNOW
IT'S VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE I
AM VERY MUCH. INTERESTED IN
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AS AN
UNDERLYING FACTOR IN MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE SEE ACROSS
MANY. DEMOGRAPHICS AND-
AGENCIES ENTITIES I AM WHAT
HAVE YOU IN IN- IN THE U. S.
AND THE WORLD BUT SPECIFICALLY
SPEAKING WITH REGARDS TO THE U.
S. AND I LOOK AT THE ISSUES
RIGHT NOW AND I AM LOOKING TO
APPROACH ISSUES IN A WAY THAT.
TRIED TO TREAT. THE PROBLEMS AT
THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM AND.
THIS AS YOU SAY IT IS A REALITY
OF WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
UNFORTUNATELY AND I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE- HOW DO
WE- WILL. REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. GETTING INTO ARE BEING
ADDICTED TO DRUGS. AND THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE IT OUR
WITH REGARDS TO CREATING. A
CULTURE AND THIS IS WHY I ASKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW THE DATA IN
OTHER COUNTRIES IN THE
PERCEPTION THE CULTURAL
ACCEPTANCE OF. OF DRUG USE IS
IT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW I THINK-
IN MY MIND I SEE MANY PEOPLE
WHO USE DRUGS ENTERING BECAUSE
OF BEHAVIOR HELP IN TRYING TO
DEAL WITH HIM BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE COPING SKILLS
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN TAUGHT THE
COPING SKILLS. TO DEAL WITH
ISSUES AND SO THAT IS ONE VENUE
THAT THEY USED TO. MEDICATE
THEMSELVES ANYWAY- SO YOU SEE
IT AS THE HEALTH PROBLEMS OF
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH PROBLEM.
AND FOR SOME IT'S JUST
SOMETHING THAT THEY DID BECAUSE
IT WAS- YOU KNOW USE AMONGST
THEIR THEIR PEERS- FROM THE
THAT THEY JUST TRIED ONCE AND
THEN BECAME ADDICTED TO. OUR
EVENTUALLY SO THERE'S A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT GO INTO THE DRUG
USE. BUT THE CONCERN THAT I
HAVE IS ONE. IS IT CREATING
THESE SITES AND THE ALLOWING
SOME OF THE POPULATION TO FEEL
THAT IT IS OKAY IT WILL BE SAFE
TO DO DRUGS OR TO EXPERIMENT
BECAUSE THERE'S A SAFETY NET
BEHIND IT- AND I'M NOT SURE
WHETHER OR NOT IT WOULD AND I
AND I DON'T KNOW THIS IS WHY I
ASKED FOR FREE CITIES OR OR
DATA ON THAT BUT I'M NOT SURE
THAT. THIS WOULD. CURTAIL
SOMEONE'S- FEAR OR I'M NOT SURE
WHAT COULD HELP THEM NOT WANT
TO PURSUE OR TRY DRUGS- IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT I WOULD BE
COMPELLED TO USE OR OR OR DO
BUT I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DIFFERENT
CULTURAL BACKGROUNDS AND LIFE
EXPERIENCES THAT MIGHT BE MORE-
RECEPTIVE TO- OR MORE. AB MUSIC
RECEPTIVE AT MORE PRONE TO USE
THEIR DRUGS I'M JUST CAN
NERVOUS THAT THIS THAT THIS
BILL IN PLACE WOULD MAKE IT A
LITTLE EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO AT
LEAST TRY AND NOT KNOWING THEIR
GENETIC MAKEUP OR PRIEST
DISPOSITION TO ADDICTION THAT
THIS WOULD CREATE A CYCLE THAT
WOULD MAKE- CERTAIN DESERT
ERROR ISSUES A LITTLE OF THE
ISSUE WORSE- THIS IS WHY I WAS
ASKING WHETHER OR NOT YOU HAVE
ANY DATA. ON WHETHER OR NOT
CULTURALLY OR SO IN IN THERE IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES ARE THIS
COUNTRY'S THE DRUG USE
INCREASED OR DECREASED AND THE
PERCEPTION OF IT IF IT WAS.
SOMETHING THAT WAS STILL.
LOOKED UPON NEGATIVELY OR IF IT
WAS LOOKED UPON AS SOMETHING
IT'S OKAY. IF YOU'RE GONNA USE
IT BECAUSE THERE'S A SAFETY NET
THE HIGH DO YOU HAVE ANY. OR
FOR. YEAH AND TO BE CLEAR WE
ALL. PEOPLE TO BE HELL AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE YOU DRUGS OUT WANT TO STOP
USING. AND THAT WE WANT WE WANT
TO HELP THEM STOP USING BUT
ABOVE ALL WE WANT THEM TO BE
SAFE AND NOT DIE. AND WE HAVE
TRIED THE APPROACHES OF THIS
YEAR LECTURING PEOPLE AND
TELLING THEM TO STOP USING- WE
TRIED THE STRATEGY OF THROWING
THEM IN JAIL. AND IT HASN'T
WORKED YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE HAVE
MORE. DRUG USE AND ADDICTION
NOW THAN THAN IN THE PAST AND
SO YOUR THIS IS ON. THE VERGE
OF THE SITE DON'T. GET PEOPLE
STARTED ON USING DRUGS THESE
SITES ARE FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN FRANKLY USING PROBABLY FOR
A WHILE. OFTEN ON OUR STREETS.
THESE ARE PROBABLY YOU KNOW FOR
SOME OF OUR MOST MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES OF DRUG USERS- AND
THAT WERE OFFERING THEM A
SERVICE. WHERE THEY CAN USE. IN
A MUCH SAFER ENVIRONMENT-
REDUCE THE RISK OF IN FACT. AND
OVERDOSE DEATHS- AND GET ACCESS
TO SERVICES AND IN THESE
PROGRAMS NOT EVERYONE BUT A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE. OF
PEOPLE ULTIMATELY GO INTO
RECOVERY SO THESE CENTERS.
THESE SITES HELP PEOPLE AND TO
RECOVER MAYBE THEY'LL DO IT THE
FIRST TIME TO GO THERE MAYBE
IT'LL BE THE FIFTIETH TIME TO
GO THERE. BUT EVENTUALLY A GOOD
NUMBER OF THEM WILL GOING TO
RECOVERY AND THIS WILL HELP
THEM DO SO AND WILL HELP KEEP
THEM ALIVE. AS THEY MAKE THAT
JOURNEY TOWARDS RECOVERY. I
RESPECT THAT. THE INTENT. I'M
JUST CONCERNED THAT HAVING
THESE FACILITIES AND MAKING AB-
OF MAKING THEM READILY
AVAILABLE OR BEING APPROVED.
CREATES A SENSE OUR PERCEPTION
THAT IT'S OKAY TO TRY I'M AND
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE I AND I
KNOW THIS IS INTENDED FOR
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN USING FOR A
WHILE BUT- EVERYTHING THAT WE
DO CREATE A CERTAIN. PERCEPTION
OR CULTURAL ACCEPTANCE OF
ISSUES AND I'M JUST CONCERNED
THAT THISBILL. WOULD CREATE A
PERCEPTION THAT IT'S OKAY.
BECAUSE THERE'S A SAFETY NET-
SO. I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT
THE LONG TERM EFFECTS OF.
EATING AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE
THINK THAT IT'S OKAY TO TRY
AND- BY PROVIDING BUT I DO
RESPECT THE- INTENT OF TRYING
TO SAVE LIVES BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT- BUT I'M JUST
I'M A LITTLE HESITANT ABOUT
THE- FORWARD THINKING AND-
MORAL ACCEPTANCE OF DRUG USE-
EVENTUALLY. I RESPECT THAT I
HAVE A DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THANK THANK YOU
SYNERGEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF- THANK YOU CENTER
WIN FOR BRINGING THE BILL THIS
THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS IN EFFECT.
JUSTIFIES WERE- CREATES A
PERMISSIVE CIRCUMSTANCE FOR
ORTIZ SAYS TO A USER HEY IT'S
OKAY TO USE- THESE ARE
DIFFICULT OUTSIDE AS YOU
QUESTIONS THAT WE ALL GRAPPLE
WITH BECAUSE IT WILL BE FOR ONE
WHEN I'VE LOOKED AT RESEARCH.
THERE ARE VERY VERY FEW ADDICTS
WHO IN ANY WAY OUR. PROUDER
PLEASED TO BE AN ADDICT THAT
MOST ADDICTS REALLY WOULD
PREFER NOT TO BE NOW. IT THESE
TYPE OF ADDICTIONS I THINK MOST
OF US KNOW ARE REALLY HARD TO
KICK. M. BUT THE THING THAT'S I
FIND REALLY INTERESTING ABOUT
THE RESEARCH IS THAT. THE TYPE
OF INJECTABLE DRUGS THAT WOULD
BE- SAFE IN THESE TYPE OF
SETTINGS. THEIR USE HAS
INCREASED ACROSS EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC IN THE U. S. IN THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC. IN INTERESTINGLY
THE FOLKS THAT WOULD USE THE
SITES ARE PEOPLE THAT BY AND
LARGE DON'T HAVE A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN. USE IT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT ANY USER SAY A WEALTHY
USER IS ANY SAFER THEY CAN DIE
OF AN OVERDOSE ALSO. BUT THEY
THEY CAN BE AT HOME OR THEY CAN
BE AMENDED IN OTHER WORDS THIS
THESE TYPE OF SITES ARE REALLY
MUCH MORE USED FOR USERS THAT.
IN FACT HAVE NOWHERE ELSE TO GO
AND POSSIBLY ARE USING MORE
BECAUSE EITHER THEY LIVE ON THE
STREET OR THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE SUCH. AND THAT ITS
POTENTIAL THAT BY THIS SUCH A
SITE. THEY MAY USE LESS. THEY
THEN HAVE ACCESS TO PEOPLE WHO
COULD. PUT THEM ON A PATH
TOWARDS TREATMENT THEY ALSO
HAVE MORE ACCESS I MEAN THE
OTHER RESEARCH SHOWS THAT FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE A VERY LOW
INCOME USER. IF YOU HAVE EATEN
IF YOU'VE HAD NEW YOUR
NUTRITION MET YOU USE LESS.
THEY'RE ALL THESE FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE. TO- EITHER A
PATHWAY TO GET OFF OF THE DRUG
OR TO USE LESS OF IT. AND SUCH
A SITE IN THE RESEARCH THAT
I'VE LOOKED AT WOULD HELP
FACILITATE THAT DOESN'T
GUARANTEE IT BUT IT WOULD HELP
FACILITATE IT. NOW THE OTHER
THING IS THAT UNFORTUNATELY.
OVERDOSES NOW BECAUSE OF THE
WAY VERY SEIZE DRUGS ARE BEING
SPIKED WHETHER WITH FAT NO OR
OTHER MATERIALS. ARE ON THE
RISE ALSO VERY SIGNIFICANTLY
AND AGAIN OKAY OF CROSSED ALL
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS. BUT THIS
HAS THE HOPE FOR REDUCING THE
DEATH BECAUSE- YOU KNOW ONCE A
PERSON'S TED FROM AN OVERDOSE
THERE IS NO HOPE OF GETTING
THEM OVER THEIR ADDICTION
HOWEVER. THERE IS STILL THE
POSSIBILITY TO GET PASSED IN
ADDICTION EVEN IF YOUR USER BUT
NOT ONE TO VOTE DE AND IN SUCH
A SITE THERE WOULD BE THE
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO THE- THE
DRUGS NOR CAN AND SUCH THAT CAN
HELP PREVENT OR STOP THE DEATH
FROM THE OVERDOSE. SO I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT. PILOT TWO
AND IT WOULD GIVE US A LOT MORE
INFORMATION THIS IS NOT
ALLOWING THIS ACROSS THE WHOLE
STATE BUT IT WOULD GIVE US MORE
INFORMATION AS TO WHETHER THE
FOLKS THAT UTILIZE SUCH A
PILOT. ACTUALLY THEN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF MORE SERVICES TO
GET OFF OF THEIR ADDICTION. AND
YOU KNOW IF IT DOES NOT TURN
OUT TO BE SO THAT'S THAT MUCH
MORE INFORMATION WE HAVE- BUT I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT ONE TO
TRY- I WAS FRUSTRATED WHEN
GOVERNOR BROWN. VETOED THE LAST
BILL. AND- ALL OF HIS-
REASONINGS I MEAN GOVERNOR
BROWN HAS A- KIND OF DFFERENT
ATTITUDE ON DRUG USE WHICH
LOOK- I DON'T FAULT ANYONE FOR.
I THINK ALL OF US WOULD PREFER
THAT THERE NOT BE ANY ADDICTS
OF ANY SORT WHETHER IT'S
ALCOHOL INJECTABLE DRUGS OR ANY
OTHER. HOWEVER WE DO KNOW THAT
IT'S QUITE RAMPANT AND
ESPECIALLY AN INJECTABLE DRUGS
UNFORTUNATELY NOW AND ACROSS
ALL DEMOGRAPHICS. AND THE
THREAT OF. FEDERAL FEDS COMING
DOWN US AT THE TIME WAS REAL IT
WOULD BE LESS NOW IT'S NOT TO
SAY THAT IT'S ABSOLUTELY THE
MINUTES WERE IT'S STILL NOT
FEDERAL LAW TO ALLOW BUT WE'RE
THERE WOULD PROBABLY BE A
DIFFERENT. PERSPECTIVE BUT WE
WILL SEE BUT I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PILOT TO TRY BECAUSE
IT WOULD GIVE US SOME
INFORMATION AND WITHOUT ALL
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU IN THE
CAR A SENATOR CALM WATER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I TOO WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND- I
THINK I'M A CO AUTHOR I JUST
WANTED TO ADD IT- IT'S- I THINK
WE WANT TO BE OPERATIONAL WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT. DRUG USE AND
DRUG ADDICTION AND- PEOPLE NOT
WANTING TO BE ON DRUGS. YOU
KNOW THE REALITY IS THAT WHILE
THERE ARE SOME FOLKS WHO ARE
TRYING TO GET OFF THEIR ALSO
FOLKS WHO ARE NOT. YOU KNOW
WHO- LIKE DRUGS LIKE DOING
DRUGS LIKE STAYING HIGH FOR
WHATEVER THE REASON IS AND I
THINK WHEN WE START HAVING
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. IT MOVES
FROM BEING- CONVERSATION AROUND
POLICY. TO BEING ONE AROUND
MORALITY. AND THAT ISN'T REALLY
SOMETHING THAT. WE SHOULD BE IN
THE BUSINESS OF TRYING TO
LEGISLATE- THE MORALITY OF HOW
FOLKS LIVE THEIR LIFE I THINK.
WHEN WE'RE ASKING WHERE WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT DRUG USE AND
ABUSE AND ADDICTION AND
OVERDOSING. THEN WE'RE
ESSENTIALLY PUSHING USERS WERE
KEEPING THEM IN THE SHADOWS-
AND NOT ALLOWING US TO HAVE
HONEST CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
PROGRAMMING AROUND SUPPORT
AROUND HOW TO GET HELP- BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT BEING HONEST ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT FOLKS ARE
FACING AND THE IMPACT THAT DRUG
USE AND ABUSE HAS ON
COMMUNITIES I SUPPORT THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM I
THINK THERE'S A SUNSET OF IT.
ON IT FOR TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
AND LET'S SEE WHAT WORKS
BECAUSE WHAT ISN'T WORKING IS
NOT TALKING ABOUT IT NOT
FIGURING OUT WAYS TO DEAL WITH
IT NOT MEETING PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE WITH THEIR ADDICTION.
AND ALLOWING- UNDERGROUND
MARKET TO PROLIFERATE WHERE
FOLKS ARE TAKING LOTS OF DRUGS
TO THE SKINNER'S POINT AND
ACTUALLY TAKING MORE BAD DRUGS-
THAT ARE CUT WITH NASTY
SUBSTANCES- THAT LEAD TO
GREATER ADDICTION AND TO DEATH.
AND BY NOT CREATING THESE KINDS
OF SITES YOU ACTUALLY STILL
CONTINUE TO PERMIT. DRUG USED
TO HAPPEN WHERE YOU REALLY
DON'T WANT TO SEE IT. IN FRONT
OF CHILD CARE CENTERS ARE AT
THE BUS STOP OUT IN THE OPEN-
SO WHY DON'T WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ADDICTION CRISIS THAT WE HAVE.
AND TRY SOMETHING TRY AND
APPROACH. TO FORCE THE ISSUE
AROUND WHAT RECOVERY LOOKS LIKE
WHAT ADDICTION LOOKS LIKE- YOU
KNOW HOW TO MEET PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE. THERE HAVE BEEN
STUDIES THAT HAVE SHOWN IN
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE THESE KINDS OF SITES YOU
ACTUALLY DO DECREASE. OR MENTAL
BEHAVIOR AND ACTIVITY- AND
THERE IS A GREATER
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF ABUSE AND
THERE'S ACTUALLY GREATER
INFUSION OF RESOURCES TO HELP
DEAL WITH- BEHAVIORAL
CHALLENGES AND ADDICTION. BUT
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN WITHOUT THE
KIND OF ACKNOWLEDGEMENT- AND
SAVE SPACE FOR PEOPLE TO TALK
ABOUT AND TO SHOW- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE CRISIS- AND WE'VE BEEN.
IT REMINDS ME ACTUALLY OF THE
HEARING WE HAD RIGHT BEFORE
BREAK- WITH FAMILIES TALKING
ABOUT ADDICTION AND OVERDOSE
AND MANY OF THOSE WERE STORIES
OF FOLKS KIND OF IN THE SHADOWS.
DEALING WITH DRUG USE AND THIS
IS AN ATTEMPT TO REALLY YOU
KNOW RECONCILE I THINK HOW WE
CONTINUE TO CHASTISE FOLKS- FOR
BAD DECISIONS THAT THEY MAKE OR
FOR FRAILTIES THAT WE ALL- FIVE
EIGHT. SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY I'M SUPPORTING
THIS BILL ON MY JOINED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR RECOGNIZING IN LOS
ANGELES IN PARTICULAR WE HAVE
HUGE HOT SPOTS. OF DRUG USE.
AND WE HAVE GOT TO GET CONTROL
OVER THAT IN THE CONTROL ISN'T
CHARGING FOLKS WITH CRIMES AND
PUTTING THEM IN JAIL AND PRISON
WHERE THEY STILL HAVE ACCESS TO
DRUGS THAT ARE WORSE- AND THE
ANSWER ISN'T TO TURN A BLIND
EYE AND SAY OKAY BECAUSE I
DON'T DO IT. THAT MEANS IT
ISN'T HAPPENING AND AS LONG AS
IT'S NOT IN MY FAMILY THEN I
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT- SO
I THINK. WHILE I'M CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW NOT A FAN. OF DRUG
USE. I RECOGNIZE THAT WE- HAVE
BEEN DENYING REALITIES OF IT
FOR A REALLY LONG TIME. AND I'M
INTERESTED IN. TRYING SOMETHING
ELSE AS A SOLUTION- TO HELP
CITIES THAT ARE CHALLENGED BY
THIS- TO FIGURE OUT NEW WAYS OF
DEALING WITH IT SO I AM
SUPPORTING THE AUTHOR AND JUST
WANTED TO SHARE BECAUSE I-
REALLY HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT HOW DO WE CREATE A SPACE
WHERE WE'RE NOT CONDONING DRUG
USE- AND I DON'T THINK ANYONE
IS CONDONING IT. BUT I
CERTAINLY I HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT IT'S A REALITY- AND THEN
HOW DO I WORK TO TRY TO HELP
ALL PARTIES INVOLVED. THE
BYSTANDERS WHO WERE TRYING TO
GO FROM POINT A TO POINT B. AND
THE FOLKS WHO WERE USING AND
ALSO THE FOLKS WHO WERE
SELLING. AND LIKE THE FACT THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THESE KINDS OF
SPACES BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THEM
TO HAVE A PROLIFERATION OF
THEIR OWN BUSINESS- AND I THINK
IN A WAY THIS ALSO ADDRESSES
THAT TO. WHICH WE HAVE SEEN IN
STUDIES FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
SO. I JUST WANTED TO ADD THOSE
COMMENTS AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. YES
SIR. THE TROUBLE. SO THANK YOU
FOR THOSE COMMENTS APRIL SHE
THEM VERY MUCH AND I DO ONE AT
A KNOWLEDGE YOUR EFFORT IN
TRYING TO THINK CREATIVELY TO
SOLVE AN ISSUE THAT IT IS AND I
ACKNOWLEDGE VERY MUCH OF A
REALITY OF WHAT WE HAVE- IN
THAT AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO IMPLEMENT IN
ORDER TO GET MORE DATA AND MORE
STUDIES ON. ON THE ISSUE-
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT I
DO APPRECIATE AND RESPECT IN
THIS BILL I REALLY DO- IN MOST
IN FROM THE EAST INTENT IN
TRYING TO SOLVE AN ISSUE THAT
IS VERY MUCH A- A HUGE PROBLEM
FOR MANY FAMILIES AND MANY.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OUT LEGALLY
AND ILLEGAL- MY APPROACH THOUGH
OR MY CONCERN HOW IS A CONCERN
I WOULD SAY WHAT IS A CONCERN
IT IS AN APPROACH BUT- WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TREATMENT
CENTERS- IN. IN OUR STATE ARE
IN THE COUNTRY TO TAKE CARE OF
INDIVIDUALS FOR DEALING WITH
ADDICTION- AND I AND I SPEAK
THAT FROM. PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
I REMEMBER. MEETING AT A YOUNG
GENTLEMAN- I WAS HELPING HIM
AND HE WAS TRYING TO GET INTO A
FACILITY AND DID NOT HAVE
ACCESS TAKE OUT THE FACILITIES
IN OUR AREA WERE FULL- WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO INDIVIDUALS WHO FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE. IN CREATING
MORE TREATMENT CENTERS TO HELP
PEOPLE- VERSUS CREATING. A
PLACES TO. SAFELY USE TRUCKS.
ON THANK YOU OPERATIVE BECAUSE
I THINK WE'RE GONNA LOSE THE
PHONE LINES AT SOME POINT- IT'S
NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE WE NEED
MORE TREATMENT WE NEED TO
DRAMATICALLY EXPAND ACCESS TO
TREATMENT. THIS IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO THAT THE GOAL
HERE IS TO HELP TRANSITION
PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT AS OF THE
TWO GO HAND IN HAND- AND THAT'S
WHY WE NEED BOTH IN MY VIEW.
THANK YOU- ENOUGH FOR THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE BETA SOON
WHEN WE TALKED CLOSER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A TO
PASS IN THIS BILL WILL BE
REFERRED TO THE RE REFER TO THE
FLOOR. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON S. B. FIFTY SEVEN.
SB FIFTY SEVEN BRADFORD BY FRED
FRIED SHOBO NO NO TROUBLE NO
CALM LONGER I HAVE A MARKER I
SKINNER WIENER I WENT AWRY. THE
ROLE OF THE MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER MEMBERS
JUST TO LET YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
HARD STOP AT TWELVE THIRTY WE
STILL HAVE TWO MORE- MEASURES
BEFORE US SO AN INTEREST OR
TIME IF YOU CAN BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONCISE WITH YOUR
QUESTIONS OR STATEMENTS IT
WOULD HELP US- MEET THAT
DEADLINE OF TWELVE THIRTY- NEXT
WE HAVE SB FIVE NINETEEN FIVE
CENTER WINNER WHEN YOU'RE READY
MISS WHEN YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SP FIVE NINETEEN WHICH WILL
DECRIMINALIZE THE POSSESSION OF
CERTAIN PSYCHEDELIC. DRUGS SOME
OF THE SITE AND- SOME OF THE
STOLEN. MDMA LSD ECONOMY AND-
MASKELYNE AND IDLE GAMES FOR
PEOPLE TWENTY ONE YEARS OR
OLDER. SB FIVE NINETEEN DOES
NOT AUTHORIZE DEDUCTION OR
PERSONAL USE FOR ANYONE UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE AND
ENSURES ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR
ANYONE WHO GIVES PSYCHEDELICS
TO MINORS. TO ENCOURAGE SAFER
USE THE BILL ALSO DECRIMINALIZE
DRUG TESTING KITS. AND PERMITS
THE POSSESSION OF PARAPHERNALIA
TO USING SUBSTANCES. AND ALSO
EXPLAINED HIS CRIMINAL RECORDS
FOR PEOPLE PART PREVIOUSLY
CONVICTED OF POSSESSION AND
PERSONAL USE. OF THESE
SUBSTANCES. THE BILL WILL ALSO
CREATE A WORKING GROUP TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. ON HOW CALIFORNIA
CAN REGULATE LEGAL ACCESS TO
THESE SUBSTANCES- ARE GIVEN
THEIR MEDICAL BENEFITS. FIFTY
FIVE NINE IS A C. TOWARD THIS
MAN THE FOR. AND RESET WAR ON-
BECAUSE LUCKY PEOPLE FOR DRUG
USE DOESN'T WORK- IN RECENT
YEARS VARIOUS CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA- AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY AND MOST RECENTLY
OREGON HAVE DECRIMINALIZED
PSYCHEDELICS- AND ALICE OREGON
DID IT BY BALLOT MEASURE- OTHER
COUNTRIES SUCH AS PORTUGAL HAVE
DECRIMINALIZED DRUG USE AND
POSSESSION- WE KNOW THAT-
PSYCHEDELICS- OUR- CREW
INCREASING NOTE THEY HAVE
SIGNIFICANT. MEDICINAL BENEFITS
PARTICULARLY AROUND MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION SOME OF
BEEN DEFINED BY THE FDA AS
QUOTE BREAK THROUGH- DRUGS- AND
SO THE WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
SAY LET'S NOT ARREST PEOPLE.
FOR POSSESSING OR USING
PSYCHEDELICS- LET'S ALLOW
PEOPLE TO DO SO AND THEN LET'S
TAKE STOCKS- IN TERMS OF HOW WE.
MIGHT REGULATE- IN THE FUTURE.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECT ASK YOUR
I. BOATS- AND WITH ME TODAY
TESTIFIED BY PHONE OR JOSE
MARTINEZ WHO IS AN ARMY VETERAN
WITH BAROQUE ARTS PROJECT.
AMERIS BIRD- AT THE HARM
REDUCTION ON ONE OF T. BUT THE
HARM REDUCTION CENTER. THANK
YOU WILL TAKE THE FIRST WITNESS
ARE PREPARED TO TESTIFY
REMINDING YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO BE SPENT ON YOUR TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN.
MISTER MARTINEZ ARE YOU
PREPARED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE TIME CENTER WINNER
AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF SB FIVE NINETEEN-
MY STORY STARTS OFF BY A IN THE
WAR VETERAN FROM AFGHANISTAN I
STAINED. LIFE CHANGING INJURIES
WHILE I'M SERVING MY COUNTRY
I'M ACTUALLY A TRIPLE AMPUTEE
NOW- IF THE DENTICULATE TRIPLE
THAT BECAME BE EXACT. I WOKE UP
HEARING THE DOCTORS. TEN DAYS
LATER BACK IN THE STATE. AND TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU I DON'T
THINK I WAS GOING TO MAKE IT
THIS FAR IN ALL HONESTY- I
BECAME ADDICTED KILL BE UPHELD
AGUIAR-CURRY- BEING INJURED.
YEAH BECAUSE I MEAN ALL THE
ENTRY THAT I HAVE- AND ON FOR
IT FORTUNATELY ENOUGH I WAS
ABLE TO GET OFF OF ALL OF ON
BUT MY MENTAL STATE OF MIND
WAS. STILL IN SHAMBLES. AND
ABOUT. EIGHT YEARS AGO I ENDED
UP FINDING THE CODE BY BAND.
AND STARTED USING AS A THERAPY
FOR MYSELF. AND THE GRAYSON VA
HAS CHANGED THE LIVE MY LIVE MY
PERSONAL LIFE I ACTUALLY WAS
ABLE TO GET MARRIED- THIRD IN
THE WORLD AND THE PARALYMPIC
HARPER CREEK IN USA. AND
THEY'RE HAS DRAMATICALLY
CHANGED MY. FAMILY MY FRIENDS
AROUND ME AND- HELLO WE CHANGE.
ALL THE AROUND ME AS WELL I'VE
BEEN BUT OUT OF BETTER FINE
THEIR OWN TREE. AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GET THEM OFF THE TAKES
AND BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS.
CONTINUE WITH THEIR LIVES AS
WELL. ONE THING I CAN TELL YOU
HERE IS THAT WE'RE NOT. THE
PANDEMIC IN THE NATION WHERE
SUICIDE IS A LOT OF ANSWERS FOR
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE. AND WE
HAVEN'T FOUND AN ANSWER I HAVE
A LOT MORE VETERANS HERE BACK
IN A TIME. AND A LOT OF THE NOT
GONNA STAND ON A LOVED ONE OF
MY BROTHERS OUT THERE. BUT I
LOGGED FIFTEEN BROTHERS BACK IN
THE STATE SIDE. SO WE HAVE A
BIG PROBLEM AND I THINK
BASEBALL DEFINITELY BE A WAY
TO. HELPING OUR VETERAN
BROTHERS. AND OUR COMMUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO GET AWAY FROM
ADDICTION AND FINALLY HAS. AN
ANSWER FOR. OUR SOCIETY. AND
ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT HAS
HELPED ME TREMENDOUSLY AND
THEN- BUT CONTINUE TO HELP AND
IF WE- ARE ABLE TO PASS THIS
NOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
RESEARCH PROPERLY SO WE CAN.
ACTUALLY HAVE. ACTUAL FACT HARD
BACK SO WE CAN ACTUALLY START
HELPING THE REST OF THE WORLD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND ENERGY AND I WILL.
SUPPORT THIS BILL ON THE PORTAL.
OTHER CHOICE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JOHN. THANK YOU FOR YOU
TO. THAT'S WHAT FELIZ. YES
THANK YOU BRADLEY- ESTIMATED ON
TH LICENSE AMERICAN DOWN THEIR
PRISM ALSO UNDER THIS. ENTRY
INTO THE AND PRACTICING DOES
THAT THIS. UP FOR THE PAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS OF LOCAL PEOPLE
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS ON
PROBABLY- PRIMARILY PEOPLE GO
BACK NURSES ALL THOSE- HERE TO
OFFER A PERSPECTIVE ON HARM
REDUCTION. THERAPEUTIC
APPLICATION LOOKS. LIKE ALEX.
FIRST THE- THIS IS. THE WAR ON
DRUGS BECAUSE HARM THE DRUG USE
SO ON. CALLED IN THE CAR. IS
NOT UP AND WE BLACK AND BROWN.
KNOWING FAMILIES COMMUNITY. WE
SEEM TO BECOME OF PERSONAL DRUG
USE AND THE ARM BECAUSE TO QUIT
WILL LOSE APPLE- REGULAR BUT
THAT THAT THERE BEING WELL.
CANNELLA PROTOCOL IN USE OF THE
NET. THAT BEING USED FOR YEARS.
SPECULATIVE THAT THERE BE. WHEN
RESEARCH ENTRY FOR US THE TO DO
THIS WITH COURT BUT THAT THERE
IS A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS BY
ELSE YOU. CAN RELATED TO QUITE
GET BECAUSE YOU AND OF LIFE
ISSUE AND BECAUSE ALL TOM ONLY
BE SOME GOING OF UP THE. ONE
OF THE BURLESQUE THE BREAK THAT
OCCURRED ON THEM NOT DAILY
LET'S TAKE I HAVE COURSE
EXPERIENCE WORK WILL BE. AND BY
THE BILL THAT THE- FROM. OUR
LEGAL SO WE DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW
THE POTENTIAL OF ALL THESE. YET
NO INCLUDING ALSO SAY. PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO USE DRUGS BECAUSE
OF THEIR LEGAL OR NOT SO BY
DECRIMINALIZING WE CAN OFFER A
PATH TO LEGAL PEOPLE ACTUALLY
USE THESE ALMOST EIGHT WILL BE
MAINLY. ON ALSO I BECAME GOOD
STUFF CRIMINALIZING BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT INCARCERATIONS OF
ABOUT. ZERO ZAGREB. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO THE HEARING ROOM HERE FORTY
TWO OR THREE OR THEIR WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT- SB FIVE ONE NINE
HERE IN THE ROOM. SHEEN AND
LET'S NOW MOVE TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM OF TWENTY FORTY OR THEIR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SHEEN ON
THEIR MODERATOR NOW LET'S GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES- PLEASE LET US
KNOW IF THERE'S WITNESSES IN Q.
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ONE NINE.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE ONE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. OUR FIRST ONE
WILL COME FROM LINE TWO TO
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GINSBERG IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE SP. FIVE ONE NINE. THANK
YOU ANNEX WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWO HUNDRED YOU ARE OPEN.
GOING ON WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO
FIFTEEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
DANIELLE THE GRAND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PSYCHEDELIC SOCIETY AND I
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU-
A LINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIFTY FIVE YOUR OPEN.
THIS IS ALEXANDER DALY CAMPER
WITH A FUTURE FOR VETERANS
FOUNDATION OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVIDERS NONPROFIT YOU
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL FIVE
NINETEEN. THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR YOU
MUTED. OKAY NO I WILL I WON
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BIGELOW DELUCA ON BEHALF OF THE
OAKLAND CITY COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT WILL ALIGN. TO TEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS ERIN KNEW SOME-
SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA VETERANS
HEALTH CARE ADVOCATE-
PORTRAITIST PROVIDING- SIX
ACCESS TO THE KIND OF HEALING
MODALITIES AND I JUST REQUEST-
THAT YOU CONSIDER THAT THIS IS
ONE OF YOUR LOVED ONES. YOUR
SON OR DAUGHTER THAT NEEDED
THIS TOOL TO HELP HEAL THEIR
LIVES. WOULD YOU WOULD YOU WANT
THEM TO BE DENIED THAT TOOLS
PLEASE ALLOW FOR THE STATE
FACTORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
NINETY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON I
AM DR JENNIFER CHRISTIAN I'M A
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST AND PSYCHEDELIC
INTEGRATION THERAPIST WITH THE
CREAM AND BASS AND
DECRIMINALIZED TERM. A ROOT
CAUSE OF PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISORDERS UNTREATED OR
UNPROCESSED TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES. RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT ONE WAY TO GET OUT OF THE
PORT AND EMANUEL YEMEN OR MY
INTEGRATING ABROAD. WE JUST
NEED YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU AND YOUR POSITION-
OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE WERE LINE ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS DAVID
YELLAND COURT OF SB FIVE
NINETEEN. I ASK THAT MY CHURCH
THE PAIR THE WAY CHURCH BE
GIVEN SIMILAR CONSIDERATION THE
OTHER CHURCHES AMENDING THE
BILL. TO DECRIMINALIZE AND
GRANDFATHER AND YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION ONLY BARELY CARD
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION ONLY
UNUSUAL ACTIVITY GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME BUT WE CAN'T. HI MY
NAME IS LUCAS MARTIN I'M A
CERTIFIED DRUG COUNSELOR WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ANAK
COUNSELOR WITH TARZANA
TREATMENT CENTERS AND A
MASTER'S STUDENT AT JOHNS
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK AND WE WERE LINED- TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. NEXT ONE TWO ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
NINE FORTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
MY NAME IS COLIN WELL I
REPRESENT BETTER AND WALK AND
TALK. IS THERE A FEW GROUP AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT THE
STATE BILL FIVE ONE NINE THESE
MODALITIES THAT MADE MY LIFE
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROBERT STANLEY
HEALTHCARE LIFE SCIENCE
RESEARCHER OFFERING STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE FORTY
FIVE YOU ARE NOW OPEN. THURMOND
AMBIANCE OF NEW APPROACH
ADVOCACY AND BETTER AND LOOKS
BORING TREATMENT SOLUTIONS CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND
TRANSPORT. THANK YOU WELL THE
LINE. FIFTY SEVEN. AARON
GOLDSTINE RETIRED LIEUTENANT WE
DON BEACH POLICE DEPARTMENT
CURRENT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ONE TWO OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEARLY YES GREAT GOOD MORNING
OR GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN
CENTERS MY NAME IS DR
RECOGNIZED. ON BEHALF OF AND
EUGENIC RESTRICTION GRETCHEN
EDUCATIONAL STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE ON THAT VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AN ONLINE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CARLOS CARRILLO
LEDGER BECOME ALLIES NATURE
YOUR TO SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE ONE NINE
SPECIFICALLY ON BEHALF OF OUR
ANCESTRAL SACRED PLANTS KNOWN
AS ANTIGENS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU M. LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS WHILE
THE GRANDMA FORMER MARINE AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR VETERANS OF
WAR- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE ONE NINE. ONE THIRTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE ON MUTE. HI THIS IS AMY
JAMIESON ON THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CHING THOUSAND SINCE ALLEGATION
AND AM EXPRESSING OUR STRONG
SUPPORT- FOR THIS BILL AND-
LIFE ALTERING AND SAVING
THERAPIES- OFFERED BY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE WERE LINE
FORTY FOUR. ACCORDING BURKE HI
THE AND POLICY ON BEHALF OF THE
ARTISTIC PSYCHEDELIC
COMMUNITIES NOT COURT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO THE LINE.
FORTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS
NATALIE CHICAGO I'M JUST A
PERSON THAT HAS EXPERIENCE
PROFOUND HEALING FROM PLANT
MEDICINES AND EXTREMELY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME'S NICOLE CLEMENTS I'M A
MEDICAL RESEARCHER WHOSE LIFE
HAS BEEN SAVED BY PSYCHEDELIC
THERAPY I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
MEASURE AND ACCESS TO THE
MEDICATION THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. ONE SIXTY
THREE. HI WHAT WE NORMALLY
LEVINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MINDY
HARLEY I AM IN SUPPORT SB FIVE
NINETEEN I AM A DEVELOPER
INTEGRATION COACH AND HELP
LEVEL IN MY LIFE BUT MY
CLIENT'S LIFE AS WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU LINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE EIGHTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
LOCATED. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY NINE. MOVING ON WITH THE
LINE ONE FIFTY THREE. HI MY
NAME IS DR AMANDA REISMAN AND
I'M A SOCIAL WORKER AND PUBLIC
HEALTH RESEARCHER AND I SUPPORT
SB FIVE NINETEEN BECAUSE THESE
MEDICINES ARE IMPORTANT TOOLS
FOR HEALING HARD TO TREAT
DIAGNOSES LIKE PTSD DEPRESSION
AND ANXIETY ESPECIALLY IN
PEOPLE BUT NOT BOUND BY THE
PROFESSIONAL TREATMENT. THANK
YOU. BRING ALONG A LINE ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MOLLY PARKER
COUNCIL FOR THE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY ASSOCIATION FOR
PSYCHEDELIC STUDIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ONE NINE
BECAUSE CRIMINAL PENALTIES DO
NOT IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE SEVENTY
NINE YOU ARE OPEN. JERRY
BLEVINS I'M A FORMER LOCAL AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
NOW WITH THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTION PARTNERSHIP STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. PINE
EIGHTY NINE CAN YOU HEAR US.
MOVING ALONG WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CANACCORD ON ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WELL WE WILL OPEN UP
LINES SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS CARL MY
NAME IS CARLTON A MEMORY TIRES
THERE'S A POLICE SERGEANT IN A
CURRENT MEMBER OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND IT'S HUMANE APPROACH TO
DRUG USE AND THE FIRST STEP IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I AM MOVING
ALONG WITH THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON RULED
ON BEHALF OF HER CARDS PROJECT
WHICH IS A CO SPONSOR OF. THE
FIVE ONE NINE A STRONGLY URGE
TO COMMITTEES I BOW ON THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF VETERANS COST
GREAT STATE CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE WERE LIED
TWO HUNDRED AND. FIVE HELLO MY
NAME IS AMBER COMPOUND WIFE
BEFORE MARIA S. NAVY SEAL AND
CO FOUNDER OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATION
BETTER DECLARING TREATMENT
SOLUTION A CO SPONSOR OF SB
FIVE ONE NINE ON BEHALF OF THE
HUNDREDS OF VETERANS WE SERVE
WE APPLAUD CALIFORNIA FOR
LEADING THE WAY IN ENDING
VETERAN SUICIDE WITH THESE
LIFESAVING THERAPIES. AND URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE AYE ON SB
FIVE OR NINE. THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS MARLON RETIRES LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THE FUTURE ALSO MEMBER
MARK FORTUNATE YOU HARDER SHIP.
AND I STAND FULLY SUPPORTING
ABOUT SB. FIVE ONE NINE. THANK
YOU WINDS HUNDRED SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT NOW OUR TOP ON
BEHALF OF DOCTOR BRONNER'S
EXCITING THAT COMES- IN STRONG
OF THAT FIVE. CONNIVING PEOPLE
ACCESS MEDICAL THE MODALITY
HE'LL THEM IT'S NOT JUST THAT.
THANK YOU AND LINE TO SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ALEXANDER AND I'M AN
ADVOCATE WITH YOU CRIMINALIZE
NATURE SAN FRANCISCO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WHAT
MOVING ON WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWO HUNDRED NINETEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SANDEL I
WROTE A LIFELONG POD
PRACTITIONER FROM THE LOCAL TO
TRY REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURES AND INDIGENOUS.
CONSERVATION INITIATIVE WHO
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE
NINE AS DROPPED IT BECAUSE IT
PROTECTS THE ENDANGERED POD IN
SOUTH TEXAS BY NOT LEGALIZING
OR DECRIMINALIZING. SHOOTING
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND LYING TO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS AN
INTELLIGENT MAN I AM A MASTER
CHAIN REGISTERED NURSING PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE I'M A PART OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT BRINGS AWARENESS
TO THE POSITIVE AND THERAPEUTIC
EXPERIENCE A RESPONSE PLEASE
CHECK IT OUT. I WIN IT POSITIVE
IMPROVEMENT IN THE LIVES OF
NUMEROUS PATIENTS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO THE THERAPEUTIC USES
LIKE A BALLOT NOW THE JERSEY
WHERE THERE HAVE THERE HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED YOU CAN REALIZE
ALREADY THERE BEEN NO STATE
ISSUE THAT ONLY INCREASED
ABILITY TO PROVIDE HARM
REDUCTION PROPERTIES. CHECK IT
OUT LIKE THAT DOUBLES UP BY
THEN HOW PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ILLNESSES THAT UPS
NAMING YOUR ORGANIZATION PLEASE
SEND IT TO THEM. AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AND WE COME AGAIN.
FROM THE- BE CRAMPED CAL.
NOTHING ELSE OUT THERE IS TO
HELP FIGHT AND THE NAME YOUR-
WE DO NEED TO STATE YOUR NAME
MY NAME IS. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS ANY COMING. FROM D. CRAM CAL
COULD THAT THINK YOU NEXT IT.
THANK YOU THE LINE TO TWENTY
FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS RENEE
OUR CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR CALL FROM
MY CALIFORNIA- WE STRONG
SUPPORT YOU'RE DOING AND YOUNG
KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK BUT THAT.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL LIKE TO
TWENTY EIGHT. MCCARTY I AM A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND- COLLEAGUES TO
CRIMINALIZE SAN FRANCISCO I AM
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN
WE NEED COMMUNITY BASED
FRAMEWORK TO IMPLEMENT MICRO
ENTERPRISE A COMMUNITY ACCESS
WITH. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWO THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU. HELLO THE
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN GROUP. WILL
BE A VASQUEZ VOLUNTEER FOR YOU
CRIME CALIFORNIA AND I'M FOR
THE BILL YOU TO THE FACT THAT
IT SAVED MY LIFE AND CAN TAKE
YOUR CHILD CARE A MOTHER'S
LIFE. ANYWHERE ANYTIME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WINE TWO THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS RYAN STEVENSON A
PSYCHOLOGIST I WORK WITH MAPS
CONDUCTING RESEARCH ON MDMA
ASSISTED PSYCHOTHERAPY FOR PTSD
AND ASKING THE HEALING BENEFITS
OF THESE MEDICATIONS I ARE
OFFERING STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT. PAT AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO WINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI.
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE ON MUTE. THE
CARD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
IN SUPPORT FOR A VOLUNTEER WORK
YOU CAN CALIFORNIA AND I AM A
SOCIAL WORKER MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCATE AND COUNSELOR AND ARE
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE- ONE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FINE. ONE
EIGHTY THREE. I'M MOVING ON
WE'RE WILLING TO THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO THIRTY
FOUR TOOK THEMSELVES ARE Q.
MARIN MODERATOR MANY CALLS TO
SHOW IN A- YOU- KEEP VOTING
RIGHTS I'D SAY ABOUT. TEN ONE
MOMENT WE NEED TO GET CAUGHT UP.
THE OPERATORS. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS RYAN MILLER
MARINE CORPS VETERAN AND
FOUNDER OF OPERATION FEEDBACK
EDUCATING VETERANS ABOUT
CONSCIOUSNESS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BY NINETEEN THANK
YOU CENTER WHEN. THANK YOU AND-
WE WILL TRY LINE TO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
NINE ONE NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU NOW RULE MOVED
TO OPPOSITION WE ARE ONE LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION MICHELLE
LOVELL ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. MODERATORS FROM
TO LEVEL THEIR- ONE MOMENT
WE'LL TRY AND SEE IF HE IS
MUTED. MR LEVEL ONE SECOND WE
WILL OPEN YOUR LINE. YOU SHOULD
BE OPEN NOW SIR PLEASE GO AHEAD
OWENS IF HE. HELLO YOU ARE OPEN
YES WE CAN THANK YOU OKAY OUR
CLIENT HI MY NAME'S JOHN LEVEL.
IN TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE-
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION- WE HAVE
GOOD CURRICULAR CONCERNED.
ABOUT THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL. THAT AUTHORIZES ENABLES
SOCIAL SHARING WHATEVER THAT
PRECISELY MEANS- WHO YOU MAY
REMEMBER IN THE MOST RECENT
HEARING OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE- THERE WAS A BILL BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ. IN WHICH
THERE WERE OVER A HUNDRED
WITNESSES. WHO HAD LOST A
FAMILY MEMBER. THROUGH BASIC
THROUGH SOCIAL SHARING THESE
ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO HAD
ADDICTIONS THESE WERE PEOPLE
WHO- ASK FOR SOME KIND OF A
DRUG COULD DEAL WHERE. SOME
PARTICULAR ISSUE THEY WERE
DEALING WITH HIM ON BE KNOWN TO
THEM THERE WAS SHRAPNEL IN THE
DRUGS CAN MAKE ALL RIGHT. READ
OTHER COMMITTEE FOLLOW. PEOPLE
FROM THE COMMUNITY CAN LOOK AT
HER VERY YOUR SOLUTIONS IN
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF SOLUTIONS
TO DEAL WITH IT. WELL BUT WE
ARE VERY VERY CONCERNED. ALL
ABOUT ON MITIGATING SOCIAL
SHARING WITHOUT SOME KIND OF
OVERDOSE AND NO WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT PUTTING SOMEONE
IN JAIL- BUT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HAVING SOME KIND OF
SAFETY SO THAT WE DON'T EVEN
ABLE. FURTHER FOR CALYX BOB NO
ONE CAN DOUBT READ THE FACTS OF
THE ACTUAL BARRACKS PEOPLE CAN
LOOK TO DIFFERENT REMEDIES BUT
WE THINK BUT LEAVING. NO
REMEDY- OR HAVING NO OVERSIGHT
IS IT TRAGIC. MISTAKE THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS AN I WILL. THAT'S
PRIMARY WITNESS NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO WITH AND FORTY TWO
OH THREE WHO ARE AND OPPOSITE
OF S. B. FIVE NINE ARE THERE
WITH ARE SOMEONE COME FOR PLAY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME TACK OUT
I'M WITH THE INTERNET FAKE
COLLEGE AS FOR AND THE CA EVERY
EQUALITY I WAS ACTUALLY DO HERE
TO SERVE AS THE SECONDARY
PRIMARY WITNESS FOR THE
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINETEEN.
GLORIA YEP TO MOUNT OKAY I'M-
SB FIVE NINETEEN WHILE IT SEEMS
INTENDED FOR GOOD SEEMS TO COME
WITH A TON OF UNINTENDED HARMS
WHILE STATING THAT IT'S DUE FOR
HARM REDUCTION- IT'S WELL KNOWN
THAT LOW INCOME AND
IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITIES SUFFER
THE GREATEST FROM DRUG EXPOSURE
ABUSE AND ADDICTION IS ALSO
WELL KNOWN THAT EXPOSURE COMES
BY PRIMARY SOURCE AND THEN
SECOND HAND USAGE IN MOST
CASES- IT'S ALSO SCIENTIFICALLY
PROVEN THAT PSYCHEDELICS OVER A
TERM USE. TEND TO COST A SIDE
EFFECT OF PERSISTENT PSYCHOSIS
WHICH IS THE ACTUAL
CONTRADICTORY EFFECT THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR IN A MENTAL HEALTH
CIRCUMSTANCE I'M COMING TO YOU
NOT JUST AS A PRESIDENT OF A
FAITH BASED COALITION WITHOUT
THE DAUGHTER OF A FORMAL DRIP
FROM REJECT ADDICT AND A PERSON
WHO HAD TO GO THROUGH REHAB
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I HAVE TO
NOTATE. THAT THE BILL WHILE.
THE WITH A THE RESPECT IN. THAT
IT IS FOR- META USAGES ACTUALLY
WRITTEN IN A WAY THAT IT.
SERVES RECREATIONAL ESPECIALLY
LEWIS TALKED SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
THE SOCIAL SHARING ASPECT AND
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IN A
COMMUNITY. I REPRESENTED TO ME
THAT ALSO SUFFERS THE LARGEST
DISPROPORTIONATE INCARCERATION
RATES AND THE DECRIMINALIZATION
CARE GETS DANGLED IN FRONT OF
US QUITE FREQUENTLY WHEN POOR
POLICY GETS WRITTEN AND THEN
THE POLICY COMES DOWN. AND WE
SUFFERED THE LASTING LONG TERM
EFFECTS OF IT SO IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE WE'RE LOOKING
AT INCREASED ADDICTION MORE
ACCESS TO DRUGEXPOSURE ARE
ALSO LOOKING AT INCREASE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. WHERE INSTEAD OF
THIS POLICY BEING CREATED A
POLICY SHOULD HAVE BEEN CREATED
OR POLICY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DESIGN IN THIS INSTANCE. TO
ASSIST THESE COMMUNITIES WHO
ALREADY SUFFER THESE THINGS
EXCEPT FOR DECRIMINALIZING AND
LETTING IT GO RAPID NO THE
INTERNATIONAL FAITH BASED
COALITION DOES NOT STAND TO
REPRESENT THAT OUR PEOPLE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE LOCKED
UP. FOR THE USAGE OF SPECIFIC
THREATS BUT WE ALSO REALIZE
THAT THE APPROACH TO DRAG.
REDUCTION IN HARM REDUCTION IS
NOT MONOLITHIC AND SO MANY
TIMES WE SEE THAT MONOLITHIC
APPROACHES ARE BEING TAKEN. AND
THEY SERVE AS A SURFACE LEVEL
SOLUTION TO SOMETHING THAT IS
COMPLETELY DEEPLY ROOTED IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE RUDY
CRIMINALIZING THE USAGE OF
PSYCHEDELICS ONE IN PARTICULAR
THAT SERVES AS A DATE RAPE
DRUG. IN A SOCIAL SHARING
CIRCUMSTANCE WE CAN KIND OF SEE
WHERE THAT CAN GO IN SOME
INSTANCES. ON THE OTHER HAND OF
THIS WE ALSO SEE THAT WE HAVE
THE DECRIMINALIZATION OF
SOMETHING THAT EVEN. YOU KNOW
THE SENATE ARE PRESENTING IT
HAS MADE A STATEMENT IS NOT
REGULATED JUST YET THEY HAVE NO
REGULATION TECHNIQUES. IN PLACE
AS OF RIGHT NOW YOU DON'T LET A
RABBIT DOG LOOSE AND THEN
CHANGE IT AFTER IT'S BEEN
SOMEBODY. THAT'S NOT HOW THAT
GOES SO IF YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THIS IS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
CAPACITY. AT LEAST THE POLICY
SHOULD CONVEY THAT THIS WOULD
BE REGULATED OR OVERSEEN. BY
MENTAL HEALTH AND THANK. THEIR
ARE MET PER. IN OF PERPETUATE
THE- YEAH. IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT IS PERMISSIBLE.
IT IS RECKLESS AT BEST AND FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE THAT I
COME FROM AS A CHILD OF A
FORMER DRUG ADDICT. I'M A STATE
AGAIN BUT IT IS COMPLETELY
IRRESPONSIBLE OF US TO DEVELOP
A POLICY THAT DOES NOT. GIVE US
SOLUTIONS TO THE ISSUES THAT
COMMUNITY ALREADY FACES THIS IS
A BANDAID AND TYPICALLY WHEN
YOU PUT A BANDAID ON A LARGE
WOUND IT DOES NOT CLOSE. IT'S
IN THE GETINFECTED AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE TIMES WE'RE LOOKING AT A
COMMUNITY LOOK. FACING YET
ANOTHER INFECTION WITH NO
TREATMENT OPTIONS BEING OFFERED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS WATER KNOWLEDGE
MOVED TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM I
SHOULD SAY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
YEARS SEE NO WITNESSES AND-
THERE ARE TWO. FROM TESTIFYING
IN OPPOSITION MISTER MODERATE
LET'S MOVE TO OUR PHONE LINES
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN Q. TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF FIVE
ONE NINE. WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
CHEWED UP- AND I DO SEE A FEW
PEOPLE THAT HAVE QUEUED UP NOW
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT SO LIKE
SKIP OVER THOSE MISTER CHAIR
LET'S DO IT OPPOSITION RIGHT
NOW THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY FOUR THANKS THIS ONE IS
IN OPPOSITION FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO OPPOSITION ONLY PLEASE.
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY FOUR- ARE.
HELLO I AM ROSE EARLY SUNDAY
AND I MEAN INDIGENOUS DOT
UNETHICAL AND PROTECTOR FROM
SOUTH TEXAS WHERE THE BEAUTY
GROWS AND I'M OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AS IT IS WRITTEN BECAUSE
THE DEFINITION OF MASCULINE IS
INCORRECTLY WRITTEN BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE POD TO DEFINE
MASCULINE WITHOUT POD WILL
CONFUSE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COURTS AND IT WILL BE COSTLY TO
ENFORCE THE DISTINCTION. IN DO
DEAL BECAUSE OUR NAME YOUR
ORGAN. IN YOUR- SIDE NINE.
COULD HAVE- TO BOTH MASCULINE
AND POP. I'M SO I AM- IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AS IT
IS WRITTEN THANK YOU FOR THIS.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE THIRTY FOUR POLICE. I DON'T
MOVING ALONG WE WILL GO TO THE
TOOK HIMSELF OUT AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE. EIGHTY EIGHT. YOUR
MEMBERS JONATHAN PUBLIC THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANKS. FOR THANK YOU
ONE MOMENT. OUR LINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS DONTE DAVIS I AM A MEMBER OF
THE SYSTEMATIC TRIBE- A PHD
CANDIDATE SAID THE SCHOLAR WITH
OVER FOURTEEN YEARS OF BEAUTY
RESEARCH I'M REPRESENTING THE
NEW ONE EIGHT AMERICAN CHURCH-
BECAUSE THE THIRD THE MEXICAN
WILL BE ALTERED NO MATTER ITS
FORM IT WILL BE DIFFICULT TO
VERIFY AND IDENTIFY THE
ORIGINAL SOURCE OF THE MEXICAN
THIS IS NEEDED TO PROTECT THE
DECLINING POPULATIONS OF POD
AND PROTECT CHURCHES LIKE MIGHT
HAVE CONTINUED ACCESS TO OUR
POPULATIONS AND THEIR RELIGIOUS
PRACTICE. THEREFORE I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO RECONSIDER THIS
BILL AS IT APPLIES TO MASKELYNE.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWO THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MERRY LEASE
WRITER AND DIRECTOR RIGHT TO
LIFE OF KERN COUNTY AND THE
MOTHER OF A FORMER DRUG ADDICT
IN STRONG OPOSITION TO THIS
DANGEROUS AND IRRESPONSIBLE
BILL. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LIVE. IS ME LYING TO TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GRABER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB.
FIVE ONE NINE. THANK YOU A LINE
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY ONE THIRTY FOUR YEAR OPEN.
ONE MORE TRY ONE HELLO I AM
ROSALEE'S UNTIL AND ON
INDIGENOUS POD AND MASCULINE
PROTECTOR FROM SOUTH TEXAS
WHERE THE BEAUTY GROWS AND I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS WRITTEN
THE DEFINITION OF MASCULINE
INCORRECTLY WRITTEN BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE POD AND TO
DEFINE POD. LEVINE MASCULINE
WITHOUT POD WILL CONFUSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COURTS AND
IT WILL BE COSTLY TO ENFORCE
THE DISTINCTION THERE'S NOT
BEEN DUE DILIGENCE CONCERNING
THE IRREPARABLE IMPACT SB FIVE
ONE NINE COULD HAVE ON BOTH
MASCULINE AND POD. IN SOUTH
TEXAS. THANK YOU. I'M NOT
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWO THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
MARISSA MAYER AND I WAS MOVED
TO THE OTHER LINE I'M A
POLITICAL RESEARCH AT UCSF AND
ONE OF THE LEADERS AT THE-
ACADEMIC AND NGO JAN ACADEMIC
COUNSELOR AT YOUR GETS UP AND I
STRONGLY. SB. FIVE NINETY. WE
ARE ONLY TAKING PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
DO NOT QUEUE UP IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. IN THIS
BILL SB FIVE ONE NINE AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE. ONE NINETY
FIVE. HI MY- MY NAME IS EVA
VIDEO I AM BOTH NATIVE
CALIFORNIA TOO MUCH IN THE
SANTA BARBARA COASTLINE AS WELL
AS THE NATIVE AMERICAN CHURCH
MEMBER AND PAID THE
PRACTITIONER OF ALL OF THE
RESIDENT THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA CURRENT THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS. I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE SENATE BILL
FIVE ONE NINE AS IT IS WRITTEN-
SPECIFICALLY REGARDING ITS
INCLUSION OF MASCULINE AND THE
DISTANCE OF THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN MASCULINE AND PEYOTE IS
VERY. SKEWED AND HARD TO
DECIPHER- I AM URGING THE
COMMITTEE FOR A NAY VOTE ON IT
SENATE. BILL FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU. YEAH MISTER SHARE
THERE ARE NO PURCHASE Q. UP AT
THE TIME. I WOULD JUST SEARCH
CHUCKLE MORE TO GIVEN BENEFITS
JOB THERE'S ANY OPTIONS A
LITTLE. CHECK ONE MORE TIME IF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
AGAIN A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE ONE NINE IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION ONLY TO SB. FIVE ONE
NINE. AND MISTER KERR WE HAVE
NOBODY ELSE QUEUING UP AT THIS
POINT THANK YOU WE'LL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS WHETHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES OUR
CENTER- TROUBLED. SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND- I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH SOME
OF THE VETERANS- WHO ARE- IN A
POSITION OF. USING THIS TYPE OF
TREATMENT FOR THEIR DEPRESSION
AND OUR STORIES WERE COMPELLING
THEY WERE VERY I WAS VERY- I
WAS HAPPY TO MEET THEM AND
REALIZE THAT WE HAVE HOPE FOR
MANY OF OUR VETERANS WERE
SUFFERING FROM PTSD WITH
REGARDS TO- TREATMENT-
ALTERNATIVE TREATMENTS THAT YOU
KNOW WHERE. THEY HAD TRIED I
BELIEVE THEY WERE A HUNDRED AT.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TREATMENT
THAT THEY WERE TRYING AND WAS A
WORKING OR MEDICATIONS AND THEY
FINALLY FOUND THE WAY TO DEAL
WITH THAT WITH PTSD I THINK
THAT THE EFFORT THERE- IS
COMMENDABLE AND I AND I TRULY
RESPECT THEIR- THEIR- THEIR
DESIRE TO. CONTINUE IN THEIR
HEALING PROCESS AND WILL TO
SURVIVE- I'M ALSO ENCOURAGED TO
SEE MANY OF THE STUDIES AND
CLINICAL TRIALS AND BENEFITS OF
THESE SPECIFIC DRUGS- HOWEVER
THESE TRIALS WERE DONE UNDER
THE DIRECTION AND CARE OF A
MEDICAL PROFESSION PROFESSIONAL
WITH THE DRUG IN AN ADULTERATED
FORM AND WITH THE CORRECT
DOSAGE WHICH WERE ALL THINGS
THAT WE CANNOT GUARANTEE WITH
BLANKET ORDERS CRIMINALIZATION
AND- IN THIS BILL. TO THAT
POINT I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
YOU. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF YOU
HAVE CONSIDERED STARTING TO
ADDRESS THE LEGITIMATE MEDICAL
USAGE FIRST. SIMILAR TO THE
APPROACH THAT THE STATE TOOK
WITH MEDICAL MARIJUANA. AND
WAITING FOR THE RESULTS FROM
THAT STUDY IN THIS BILL BEFORE
FULLY DECRIMINALIZING ALL
PERSONAL USAGE HERE AND- JUST
TO BE CLEAR WITH MEDICAL
CANNABIS WHEN VOTERS LEGALIZED.
MEDICAL CANNABIS IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT THAT WAS NOT
EVEN THOUGH YOU NEED A
RECOMMENDATION FROM A PHYSICIAN
FOR IT- IT DID NOT THE PRODUCT
ITSELF IS NOT REGULATED IN
TERMS OF ITS PURITY IT'S OUT OR
WE DON'T GET THERE UNTIL
TWENTY. TWENTY YEARS LATER WITH
FULL LEGALIZATION- AND YOU KNOW
A LOT OF PEOPLE DERIVE ENORMOUS
MEDICAL BENEFIT FROM THAT
MEDICAL CANNABIS- IN TERMS OF
HERE JUST TO BE CLEAR. ON ONE
OF THE USES OF PSYCHEDELICS IS
FOR MEDICINAL USE AND IT CAN BE
VERY POWERFUL IN THERE ARE MANY
STUDIES SHOWING THAT. ON RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE PSYCHEDELICS- ARE
WILL CONTINUE UNTIL THOSE
CHANGES TO BE ILLEGAL. OTHER
THAN WITH ONE EXCEPTION UNDER
FEDERAL LAW- PHYSICIANS CANNOT
BE INVOLVED THEY RISK. FEDERAL
PROBLEMS WITH EIGHT IF THEY DO
THAT SO SOME OF SAID WHY DON'T
YOU REQUIRE SUPERVISION OF A
PHYSICIAN- WE REALLY CAN'T DO
THAT UNTIL THERE'S A CHANGE. IN
FEDERAL LAW- AND SO ON WHAT
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS SIMPLY
DECRIMINALIZATION IT'S A FIRST
STEP TO SAY WE'RE GONNA STOP
ARRESTING PEOPLE. FOR
POSSESSING OR USING- THESE
SUBSTANCES- AND BECAUSE OF THAT
IT TO WE RECORDED A
DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN MEDICAL
USES AND OTHER USES. THAT WOULD
BE REALLY YEAR HOW I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU WOULD EVEN DO THAT- IN
A IN A DECRIMINALIZATION
CONTACTS OF EX EXTREMELY HARD
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE THOSE
BRIGHT LINES AROUND YOUR UNDER
THE SUPERVISION. OF A
PRESCRIPTION FROM A PHYSICIAN
OR YOU DON'T- AND SO OUR
APPROACH IS SAID LET'S TRY TO
STOP ARRESTING PEOPLE FOR USING
US FOR SETTING UP A TASK FORCE
TO TALK ABOUT NEXT STEPS. AND
WE HOPE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
COMES ALONG. OKAY HOW WOULD YOU
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT ARE
UP WITH ONE OF THE- THE YOUNG
LADY THAT SPOKE IN OPPOSITION A
WITH REGARD TO HER COMMUNITY
MEMBER AND NOT HAVING. THE
SAFETY CARDS- AND HOW TO DEAL
WITH THE- UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE
CRIMINALIZING THESE TRUCKS- AND
IDLE WHATEVER'S. EXPECT FOR
THOSE COMMENTS AND- FOR THE YOU
KNOW FOR THE JOURNEY AND THE
CHALLENGES OF HER. OF HER I
THINK SHE'S AT ONE OF OUR
PARENTS- AND- DRUGS HAVE HAD
HUGE IMPACTS IN IN VARIOUS.
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
WE'RE SEEING NOW THAT DRUGS
ARE. YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
OPIOIDS IT'S EVERYWHERE- EVERY
EVERY COMMUNITY EVERY- EVERY
BACKGROUND EVERY ETHNICITY
EVERY RACE- AND SO- IN TERMS
OF. YOU KNOW GUARD WAS I JUST
WANT TO BE REAL CLEAR-
WEATHERED PSYCHEDELICS OR OTHER
DRUGS. PEOPLE ARE USING THOSE
DRUGS NOW AND HAVE BEEN FOR
EVER I MEAN SOMETIMES AND WE
HAD A LITTLE DIALOGUE ABOUT
THIS BEFORE I CONCERNS AS A
PERSPECTIVE. THAT IF YOU
DECRIMINALIZE SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE AN INVITATION FOR
PEOPLE TO USE. AND AS CENTER
COM LONGER THINGS VERY
ELOQUENTLY SAID BEFORE THAT
IT'S JUST NOT. THE GUYS JUST
NOT THE CASE- IF BANNING AND
CRIMINALIZING DRUG POSSESSION.
WORKED THEN WE WOULD BE AN
NEVADA THERE'LL BE NO DRUG USE
AT ALL IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. BECAUSE THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. ISN'T IT IF
YOU IF YOU THINK
CRIMINALIZATION OF DRUGS IS
GOOD OF DRUG USE IS GOOD. THEN
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD THINK THAT
WERE THE ABSOLUTE BEST A PLUS
COLD STARTS TO HIM BECAUSE- THE
US HAS CRIMINALIZED DRUG USE- I
MEAN JUST. IN AN EXTREME WAY.
AND PEOPLE ARE STILL USING EVEN
THAN THEY WERE. BEFORE AND SO
BY THE CRIMINAL WE'RE NOT A
INVITING PEOPLE TO USE. WERE
TAKING INSTEAD OF A CRIMINAL
APPROACH TO DRUG USE WE'RE
TAKING A HEALTH APPROACH
HELPING PEOPLE WHO NEED TO GET
IN THE RECOVERY. ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO USE SUBSTANCES ARE
HELPFUL. TO THEM AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING. TO DO HERE
SO IS THIS LIKE THE PERFECT
GLOBAL SOLUTION TO EVERYTHING
NOW I WOULD NEVER. STATE THAT
WE NEED THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO START TAKING A MORE FORWARD
LOOKING APPROACH. TO DRUGS IN
GENERAL IN PARTICULAR AND TO
PSYCHEDELICS SPECIFICALLY. BUT
UNTIL THAT HAPPENS WHAT WE CAN
DO AS CALIFORNIA IS TO STOP
ARRESTING AND LOCKING PEOPLE UP
FOR POSSESSING. AND USING THESE
DRUGS. SO IN ORDER FOR SENATE
JUST RIGHT SO I CAN UNDERSTAND.
IN ORDER FOR THIS TO BE. ADAM
IN ORDER FOR THIS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN A IN A MEDICAL
ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE TO
DECRIMINALIZE IT FIRST ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IS THAT CORRECT
WOULD HAVE TO HAPPEN- IS THEY
WOULD HAVE TO BE RESCHEDULING.
OF THE DRUGS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND I THINK OF THE DRUGS
THAT WE INCLUDE YOUR ONLY ONE
ACADEMY IN- A DOCTOR CAN
PRESCRIBE ECONOMY BUT THAT'S
THE ONLY ONE AND SO WE WOULD
NEED TO HAVE FEDERAL
RESCHEDULING OF MORE DRUGS INTO
ONE PROVISION IN THIS BILL. IS
THAT IF AND WHEN THERE IS
FEDERAL RESCHEDULING A
PARTICULAR SUBSTANCES
CALIFORNIA WILL AUTOMATICALLY
RESCHEDULE AS WELL AND AT THAT
POINT- DOCTORS WOULD BE ABLE TO
BE INVOLVED BUT WE'RE NOT THERE
YET. OKAY AND THERE WAS A THERE
WAS A COMMENT SOME. MAYBE WAS
THE- I'M NOT SURE WHO MENTIONED
THE FACT THAT ONE OF THE DRUGS
THAT WERE. INCLUDED IN THIS
WAS- SOME FORM OR LEVEL OF
FENTANYL IS THAT. THAT I CAN'T
CHATTER WAS OUT COMPLETELY.
THERE'S A WRONG DID I
MISUNDERSTAND ABSOLUTELY NOT IS
NOT INCLUDED AS PART OF THOSE-
YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE ADDRESSING ARE
PUTTING PEOPLE IN JAIL FOR
USING PENCIL EITHER THAT'S A
MAJOR HEALTH ISSUE. AND WE WANT
TO HELP PEOPLE IT'S A SEPARATE
ISSUE FROM WHAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY- NO- AND SENT ALL THE
LEASING A SENTINEL WHICH WE
HEARD ABOUT WOULD CENTER
MELENDEZ IS BILL WITH. OFFICE
PERCOCET CENTEL'S ETCETERA-
THAT'S NOT REALLY TO MY
KNOWLEDGE A REAL ISSUE WITH
WITH PSYCHEDELIC SO I CAN'T SAY
IT'S NEVER HAPPENED BUT I THINK
YOU'RE NOT IT'S NOT TYPICAL AT
ALL TO SEE LACING OF
PSYCHEDELICS- WITH- WITH
RENTAL. AND HOW DO YOU RESPOND
TO THE DRUG THAT- IS. USED
DURING DAY OR DATE. THE THERE
IS THERE A DRUG THAT WE X. FOR
NEXT YEAR. WHICH IS LIKE A-
WHAT WE THINK OF AS THE DATE
RAPE. ROG I THINK SHE WAS
REFERRING TO CADMIUM IF I'M
NOT- MISTAKEN- AND I CAN KIND
OF MEAN IS ALREADY SCHEDULED SO
PHYSICIAN. CAN PRESCRIBE AND
SO- YOU KNOW WE DID KEEP GHB
OUT OF THE OUT OF THE BILL.
TIME AND WHEN WE THINK OF. THE
DATE RAPE DRUG STOCKS LIKE THE-
BURKE BUT THE CULPRIT IN CHIEF
SERVICE SPEAKING WE TALK ON BUT
IT'S NOT INCLUDED IN THIS BILL.
AND THEN MY LAST QUESTION I
THINK WOULD BE- WITH REGARDS TO
IN YOUR- IN YOUR MIND HOW DO WE-
HOW DO WE RECIPROCATE THE EIGHT
THE NOTION OF IT I KNOW. WE CAN
TALK ABOUT MEDICAL. CANNABIS OR
MARIJUANA BUT- THE FACT THAT IF
YOU DECRIMINALIZE IT HERE WE
STILL DON'T HAVE IT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE TODAY WITH WITH CANNABIS IN
CALIFORNIA- FOR ALMOST TWENTY
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS I THINK
IT'S ABOUT TWENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY WE HAVE DID YOU
KNOW FIRST MEDICAL AND THEN
IT'LL BUT DON'T USE- AND- WE'VE
AND SO IF A BUNCH OF STATES I
THINK 40% OF THE US POPULATION
NOW LIVES IN THE STATE. OF NEW
YORK AND SOME OTHER- SEDUCTIONS
40% OF AMERICANS LIVE IN STATES
WHERE IT'S LEGAL TO USE
CANNABIS- AND CONGRESS HASN'T
CAUGHT UP IN WHAT I DON'T GET
ME STARTED ON THE LAUNDRY LIST.
OF ISSUES WERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S WAY BEHIND THE
STATE'S- BUT AS US AS JUSTICE
LOUIS BRANDEIS ONCE SAID THE
STATES ARE THE LABORATORIES WE
TRY THINGS OUT AND THEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALTERNATELY
COMES. ALONG SO IT WORKED OUT
OKAY WITH CANNABIS I'M NOT
SAYING FROM PERFECT HAVE BEEN
SOME MOMENTS IN TIME WHERE
THERE'S BEEN TENSION BUT
ULTIMATELY WE HAVE A WHOLE
ROBUST SYSTEM OF CANNABIS. IN
THE STATE AND IT'S WORKING OKAY
THE CULTIVATION THE SALE OF THE
USE THAT CETERA. ON SO I KNOW
THAT WE CAN DO IT. OKAY SO JUST
FOR THE RECORD CENTER WIENER
AYE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS AND
I UNDERSTAND AND RESPECT THE
EFFORTS IN. THESE THAT THIS
BILL IS INTENDED ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO SAVING THE
LIVES OUR VETERANS AND OUR- I'M
SURE OUR PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
AS WELL- I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL RIGHT NOW BUT
I TRULY DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU- INCOMING.
PERHAPS IN A WAY THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO MEET THE CONCERNS OF MY
COMMUNITY MY DISTRICT- BUT I DO
COMMEND YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE AND TRYING TO
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX IN IN
DEALING WITH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AND SAVING OUR VETERANS I TRULY
TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT IN
THAT ENDEAVOR. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANSWER FROM MY TO SAY I
KNOW YOU TAKING QUITE A BIT OF
TIME ON THIS BILL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE- I
WOULD SAY I THINK MISS SKINNER
MENTION FENTANYL IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE LAST BILL.
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN IT FOR.
THERE WERE NO WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE OUR COLORS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. YOU CAN
CHOOSE MEMBERS WE- A TO PASS TO
THIS COMMITTEE ON. HEALTH EARN
WE WERE LOOKING FOR THE MOTION
ON THIS MEASURE. CENTER CAMARGO
HAS MOVED THE S. P. FIVE ONE
NINE CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB FIVE ONE NINE SENATOR
BRADFORD. ALL RIGHT BRADFORD
AYE IT TO A VOTE NOW TROUBLE NO
CALM WATER I FAMILIARIZE
SKINNER WIENER RIGHT GENERAC.
OUR MEMBERS WILL LEAVE THE- I
AM OPEN FOR OUR OUR APPS TO
MEMBER WE CURRENTLY AT THREE TO
WARN. THREE HOURS NO ONE ON ONE
NO MOVIE DROVE LAST
MEASURE SB SEVEN TEN. FINE
SENATOR BRADFORD TO. HOPEFULLY
AS A STEP IN ORDER TO GO AND.
IF I MAY I WILL PRESENT FROM
RIGHT HERE TO SAVE SOME TIME
WITH. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL. SB SEVEN TEN THANK YOU.
SB SIX SEVEN TEN IS JUST REPORT
MEASURE THAT WOULD ADDRESS WHAT
IS CLEARLY A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST THAT. EXISTS BETWEEN
PROSECUTORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO HAVE COMMITTED
MISCONDUCT WHILE ON DUTY THIS
BILL REQUIRED TO SECURE TURNING
WHO HAS RECEIVED A MONETARY
BENEFIT FROM AN ASSOCIATION
THAT SOLELY REPRESENTS LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
FROM THE INVESTIGATION CHARGING
AND THE PROSECUTION OF OFFICERS
THAT IS A MEMBER OF THAT
ASSOCIATION- THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIES IF THAT ASSOCIATION
ALSO PROVIDES REPRESENTATION
FOR THE OFFICERS. IN THE
CRIMINAL CASE. AFTER RECUSING
THEMSELVES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR-
PROSECUTE THE CASE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR HIMSELF WITH COMP.
THEN THE SPONSOR PROSECUTOR
WILL BE A SIGN. BOTH STATE LAW
AND THE STATE BAR. MARCH OF
PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT ADDRESS
HOW ATTORNEYS SHOULD RESPOND
WHEN FACED WITH A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST BUT THEY ARE UNCLEAR
WITH THE SPECIFIC TYPE OF
SITUATIONS. PROSECUTORS ARE
SOME OF THE MOST POWERFUL
ACTORS AND OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND THEIR ROLE IS UNIQUE AND
UNLIKE ANY OTHER ELECTED
OFFICIALS THEY CAN DETERMINE
ONCE. FUTURE AS IT RELATES TO
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION AND
CONVICTION THEIR DUTY- IS TO
FAIRLY AND IMPARTIALLY ENFORCE
A LAW NOT SIMPLY MAKE POLICY
CHOICES WHICH WE FIND OURSELVES
IN MANY TIMES. FOR ALL THE
TIMES ISSUE SIR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY HOLD A FUNDAMENTAL
ROLE- IN. HOLDING BAD OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE YET POLICE OFFICERS
IN THE STATE- SERIOUSLY HARM
KILL PEOPLE ON A REGULAR BASIS
AND VERY RARELY IF EVER ARE
CHARGED LET ALONE PROSECUTED
AND- BY TWENTY ONE TALK ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF CONVICTIONS THAT
WE FIND IN THAT AREA. AS A
RESULT OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- AND
RIGHTFULLY SO- HAVE GREAT
DISTRUST WITH OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN THE SEARCHERS RELATIONSHIP
THAT EXISTS BETWEEN THE TWO-
SUPPOSED TO WIN AGAIN THOSE
ASSOCIATIONS DONATE TO THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S AND IN
FINANCING. THE COUNCIL- FOR THE
BAD OFFICERS OFFICERS. THIS IS
A CLEAR ETHICAL ISSUE AND OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WILL BE
A GREAT BENEFIT BY ADDRESSING
THIS CONFLICT OF INTEREST. BY
THIS BILL THERE'S NO PREVENT
ANY FROM RECEIVING A FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL TRIAL THIS BILL DOES
NOT PREVENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
UNIONS FROM DONATING TO THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY CANDACE NOR
DOES IT FOR BED. DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FROM ACCEPTING THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS IT ONLY REQUIRES
THOSE ATTORNEYS TO RECUSE
THEMSELVES. FROM THEIR CRIMINAL
CASE REMOVING ANY OPPORTUNITY
OF A BIAS IN- FAVORITISM WE
HAVE TO DO THAT AS LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
ALL THE TIME THERE IS A
FINANCIAL BROKER CONFLICT
ANYTHING THAT WE'RE DOING.
TODAY TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS IS DA- DIANA BECTON FROM-
CONSEQUENCE TO. CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF
SOME SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY- TORY
BERBERS CELLS ARE ABLE TO MORE
MEMBERS OF THE PRO PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE FOR CALIFORNIA AND THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I'M
SORRY I FAILED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT I HAVE YOUR GAVEL- WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO YOUR LEAD
WITNESS- AND WE HAVE. DIANA
BECTON AND TORY- PRAYER SALAZAR
DIANA BECTON WOULD YOU LIKE TO-
TO MAKE YOUR STATEMENT. YES
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR
CARRYING- THIS BILL MY NAME IS
ZAINAB ECONOMIC FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB SEVEN TEN I AM THE
ELECTED DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. PRIOR TO
BECOMING DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
SERVED FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS AT
THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE HI I HAVE
DEDICATED MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE
TO ENSURING THAT THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM PROVIDES FAIR
AND EQUAL ACCESS TO TALK. BUT
THE SYSTEM DOESN'T. CHUNKS
EFFECTIVELY THE PUMP DOES NOT
TRUSTED AND HAVE FAITH IN ITS
IMPARTIALITY. THE NATIONWIDE
DEMONSTRATIONS OVER THE DEATH
OF GEORGE COOLEY PRETTY ON THE
TAYLOR AND COUNTLESS OTHERS.
HAVE MADE IT CLEAR THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FACES A CRISIS OF
LEGITIMACY. IT'S NOT JUST THE
POLICE IT'S ALSO THE
PROSECUTORS AND THE COURT
STRUCK FAILING TO HOLD THE
POLICE ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY
BREAK THE LAW. WHEN PEOPLE AND
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
FIGURE ABOUT ONE. HELD OFF TO
JAIL FOR MINOR OFFENSES BUT
WATCH POLICE OFFICERS KILLED
MEMBERS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT FACING ANY CRIMINAL
CONSEQUENCES. IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT PEOPLE CONCLUDE
THAT THE SYSTEM IS RIGGED
AGAINST THEM. SB SEVEN TEN WILL
ADDRESS ONE ALL TOO COMMON
PRACTICE THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS PERCEPTION. DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ACCEPTING A MONETARY
BENEFIT FROM THE SAME LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATIONS THAT
REPRESENT THE OFFICERS THERE'S
SUPPOSED TO BE HOLDING
ACCOUNTABLE. REGARDLESS OF THE
PROSECUTORS INTENTIONS THIS
FINANCIAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
PROSECUTORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
APPRECIATION. CORRODE TRUST IN
OUR IMPARTIALITY WHICH
SERIOUSLY UNDERMINED
RELIGIOUSLY LEGITIMATE. THE OF
THE ENTIRE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. AT THE TOURNEY GRUBER
HEALTH ETHICAL STANDARDS.
REGARDING CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
BUT THERE ARE CRITICAL GAPS IN
THOSE STANDARDS THAT RESULT IN
A LOOPHOLE FOR THAT SITUATION.
SB SEVEN TEN WILL CLOSE WHO
POLL AND HELP RESTORE TRUST
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE I ASK. FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH. OF RESPECT IN. DO HAVE
TORY SALAS SAID. ON THE LINE.
TORY BERBER SALAZAR. ONE SECOND
LET'S MAKE SURE LINE IS NOT
MUTED. NO ONE SECOND WE'LL GET
TORIES LINE OPENED. THERE IS A
LOT OF NOISE EARLIER SO BASSES
TO MUTE EVERYBODY HERE WE GO
ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU MODERATE
YOUR YOUR NOW OPEN. WONDERFUL
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TORY
REBELS ARE NINE ACCOUNTING
MEMBER OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA AND A
PROUD SPONSOR OF SB SEVEN TEN
BY SENATOR RAPPER. I HAVE BEEN
A MEMBER OF THE OFFICE FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS AND IT SERVED
AS A DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN. I ECHO THE SENATOR'S
NDA BECKONED COMMENTS ON THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL AND WITH MY
TESTIMONY WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS WE'VE
HEARD IN OPPOSITION. THIS BILL
NEARLY TAILOR TO A MAN I CAN
STATE INTEREST ENSURING THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR JUDICIAL
SYSTEM AND FAIR TREATMENT FOR
ALL VICTIMS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHICH IS OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY. THE OPPOSITION CLAIMS
THAT WE ARE INFRINGING. ON
THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
ENGAGE IN POLITICAL SPEECH. TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE CAMPAIGN OF A
DISTRICT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
CANDIDATE OF THEIR CHOICE. SB
SEVEN TEN DOES NOT LIMIT THE
ABILITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
SITUATIONS TO CONTRIBUTE TO
CANDIDATES. FOR PROSECUTOR
OFFICES. DA CANDIDATE TO ACCEPT
THE COUNTRY. THE BILL MERELY
PROVIDES THAT IN CASES
INVOLVING ALLEGED CRIMINAL
CONDUCT BY ON DUTY PEACE
OFFICERS. THE DHR HOUSTON'S
FELL FROM THE INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION IF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION ALSO
PROVIDES REPRESENTATION TO THE
OPS DURING THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION. CONGRESSMAN BE
MET. THIS GAVE A MONETARY TO DA
DURING THE INVEST. AND THE
ASSOCIATION IS PROVIDING
REPRESENTATION TO THE AFTER
BEING INVESTIGATED AND THE
REMEDY IS SIMPLY REFUSAL OF THE
DNA. TO ADVANCE A COMPELLING
STATE INTEREST MAINTAINING
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
INTEGRITY OF PROSECUTORS AND
THEIR INVESTIGATION POLICE
WRONGDOING. THE ACTOR
PROSECUTORS CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT POSITION AND
EXCELLING TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE
MEMBERS OF THE SAME
ASSOCIATION. FOR SEEMINGLY
CRIMINAL ACTS CORRODES PUBLIC
TRUST IN AN INSTITUTION
LEGITIMACY HINGES ON THE PUBLIC
SPACE IN ITS FAIRNESS
IMPARTIALITY. FINALLY THE
OPPOSITION ALSO POINTS OUT THAT
MEMBERS OF LEGISLATIVE BODIES
DO NOT HAVE TO RECUSE
THEMSELVES FROM VOTING ON
ISSUES RELATED TO AND INDEED.
THAT HAD DONATED TO THEIR
CAMPAIGNS. BUT PROSECUTORS
SERVE A PUBLIC DUTY DISTINCT
FROM OTHER POLITICIANS. WEIRD
MINISTRY YEARS OF JUSTICE NOT
CRAFTERS A POLICY WE MUST HOLD
ANYONE WHO BREAKS THE LAW
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
EVEN IF THEY ARE FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IT IS OF PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE FOR THE PUBLIC TRUST
US TO CARRY OUT THOSE DUTIES
FAIRLY AND IMPARTIALLY. SB.
SEVEN TEN IS CRITICAL TO
BUILDING THAT TRUST. THANK YOU
IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR VOTED BY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE- TO THE ROOM.
ERA TO THE CURRENT CHAMBER. TO
HAVE ANY WITNESSES OF WE DO
PLEASE. I'M SURE CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF GOVERNOR
FOR CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THIS IS ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND FORTY TWO OR THREE. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES AND IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY. SCENE NINE. THANK
YOU WROTE WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE OR
THIS. MODERATOR YOU ON THE
PHONE LINES. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL- BILLS SB SEVEN TEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LATER CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE TO AND
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. OUR FIRST. OUR FIRST-
PERSON WILL BE LINE ONE SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ATTACHMENTS ON BEHALF OF
SPONSOR SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TO BOOTING ALSO
EXPRESSING SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
SMART JUST TO CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE RESTORED CHAPTERS
COURAGE CALIFORNIA ON COMMON
LAW CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. INITIATE JUSTICE
SOLVING MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION WE THE
PEOPLE THINK DIGNITY ASIAN
SOLIDARITY COLLECTIVE HELLER'S
OF THE COMMUNITY SAN DIEGO
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE.
SANDIEGO AND NORTHERN SAN DIEGO
AND THE GRASSROOTS LAW PROJECT
ALL ASKING FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU- TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
ELEVEN PLEASE ON MUTE. DANIEL
THE CHERRIES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
AND I'M SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP KEEP.
THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU
CHECK THE LINES ONCE AGAIN JUST
TO BE SURE WE HAVE HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORT WITNESSES PLEASE.
AND THANK YOU- AND THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TEN. ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. SEVEN CAN. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM. GEN
WE HAVE ONE THAT LEAD-
OPPOSITION WITNESS LARRY MORSE
WOULD YOU HAPPEN TO BE ON THE
LINE. I AM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED
PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LARRY MORSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL SEVEN TEN. L.
SINGLED OUT DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
AMONG ALL ELECTED OFFICIALS AS
BEING INCAPABLE OF RECONCILING
THEIR ETHICAL DUTIES WITH
HAVING RECEIVED POLITICAL
SUPPORT IN THIS CASE FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATIONS. WHY
WOULD BE AS BE HELD TO A
DIFFERENT STANDARD THAN MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
MANY OF WHOM ROUTINELY SOLICIT
SIGNIFICANT CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM A VAST ARRAY
OF SPECIAL INTERESTS WHO HAVE
BUSINESS IN THE LEGISLATURE.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
AN ELECTED DA RECEIVING THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT UNION IN HIS OR HER
COUNTY AND THEN FAIRLY AND
ETHICALLY ASSESSING A
SUBSEQUENT BOB CERTAIN BALL
SHOOTING CASE. AND A MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATURE ACCEPTING
CONTRIBUTIONS THROUGHOUT HER OR
HIS CAREER FROM SAY UTILITY
INTERESTS AND THEN VOTING ON
LEGISLATION REGULATING THOSE
SAME UTILITY. PRACTICALLY
SPEAKING NOT. WE WOULD NOT
SUGGEST THAT JUST BECAUSE A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TAKEN CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM SPECIAL INTERESTS HERE SHE
IS RENDERED INCAPABLE OF VOTING
YES OR HER CONSCIENCE ON THE
BILL AFFECTING NOT SPECIAL
INTERESTS YET THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL TELLS ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. WHY IS THE
BILL SINGLE OUT ONLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONTRIBUTIONS THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL HAVE BEEN
ACTIVELY SUPPORTED BY DEFENSE
MARKETERS BUT THE BILL DOES NOT
PROHIBIT THEM FROM
INVESTIGATING OR PROSECUTING AN
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING OVER
THOSE SAME MEMBERS OF THE
DEFENSE BAR HAVE A KEEN
INTEREST IN WHETHER CHARGES
WERE FILED. THIS WOULD SEEM TO
BE IN THE GREAT JUST DOUBLE
STANDARD AND FAST AS WE READ
THE BILL IF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY DID NOT RECEIVE
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS FROM A
LOCAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OR DEPUTY SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION BUT DID RECEIVE A
CONTRIBUTION OR ACCESS
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION WHICH HAS
MEMBERS OF BOTH THE LOCAL
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND LOCAL
POLICE AGENCIES. THE DA WILL BE
DEEMED TO HAVE A CONFLICT. OF
INTEREST. PUT IT CONDUCTING BY
SHOOTING INVESTING. IN ANY
AGENCY THAT HAS OR ARE MEMBERS.
UNDER THIS WHEN I OFFICER
INVOLVED THE- A DIEGO BECOME TO
IF OR HER. CONTRA TO THE WHAT
IF ANY POLICE ASSOCIATIONS
SUPPORTED HIS OR HER CANDIDACY
AND IF THAT OFFICER WAS A
MEMBER OF ANY OF. THE BILL IF
APPROVED WOULD BE GUARANTEED
THIS DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING CASES THAT THE AG WILL
SOON BE INVESTIGATING UNDER
LAST YEAR'S AB FIFTEEN OH SIX.
MOREOVER YOU ALMOST CERTAINLY
HAVE SITUATIONS IN BOTH IN
WHICH BOTH THE AG AND A LOCAL
VA. RECEIVED CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
PORAC- OTHER STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATIONS. SUCH
CASES CA WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
CONDUCT THE L. I. S.
INVESTIGATION NOR WILL THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO WILL THEN
BE COMPELLED TO RETAIN A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR. TO CONDUCT
THE INVESTIGATION. MISTER
ATTORNEY DOESN'T WANT TO A
CONTRA FROM SAFE ORGAN. AND
HERE SHE CAN DECLINE BUT AS
WOULD MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
STRENUOUSLY OBJECT TO THE
IMPLICATION THAT THEY CANNOT
DESTROYERS ARE ELECTED DUTIES
FAITHFULLY AND WITHOUT FEAR OR
FAVOUR NO MATTER WHO HAS
SUPPORTED THEIR CAMPAIGN FOR
OFFICE. WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
CREATES SIGNIFICANT
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGES AS
WELL IN THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT CASES WOODLAND HILLS
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION ENFORCES
CITY COUNCIL OF LOS ANGELES THE
COURT NOTED THAT QUOTE. A
LITTLE CONTRIBUTIONS INVOLVE
EXERCISE OF FUNDAMENTAL
FREEDOMS PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION AND ARTICLE ONE
pCONSTITUTION. IN THE WOODLAND
HILLS CASE THE COURT REJECTED
THE IDEA THAT ALEXIS CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS MUST BE RECUSED
FROM VOTING ON THE DEVELOPMENT
ISSUE. BECAUSE DEVELOPERS THAT
DONATED TO THE COUNCIL MEMBERS
CAMPAIGNS. IN REJECTING THIS
CLAIM THE COURT SAID QUOTE
DISQUALIFIER CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER FROM ACTING ON THE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSAL BECAUSE
THE DEVELOPER HAD MADE A
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION ABOUT
NUMBER WOULD THREATEN
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
POLITICAL SPEECH AND
ASSOCIATION FREEDOMS. END QUOTE
WE SUPPORT THE TRANSPARENT AS-
TRANSPARENCY AND REPORTING ALL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO ELECTED
OFFICIALS INCLUDING THE H. M.
BELIEVE THE VOTERS DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES HAVE TO ASK JUST. AS
THEY WOULD MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE YEAH
CANCEL ANYTIME AND IT MAXIMUM
WHETHER. ANY OF. ARE TIED TO
THOSE KIND OF. THIS BILL IS
DANE ARBITRARY INCOME. AND
LIGHTING ON KERR. AND WE WERE
ASK BIRD- BOTH THANK. THANK YOU
MISTER MORRIS FOR YOUR FREE
TESTIMONY WOULD LIKE TO NOW
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WAS TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN TEN.
COENEN THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE WITNESSES WANTING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR VERSUS MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THAT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN TEN
WE WILL BEGIN. OKAY ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. THANK YOU MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF WAITING AT
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. WE HAVE
NOBODY CUTE OUT. THANK YOU
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE-
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE HEARD FROM
ALL OPPOSITION WITNESSES. THANK
YOU AS A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVEN TEN.
MADAM CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP. THANK YOU MODERATOR- THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE TO THE MEMBERS TO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. SEEN
ON. SENATOR I BROUGHT FOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
I'M SURE AND I'M GOING TO THANK
THE WITNESSES WHO ARE SPOKE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE BUT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES SPOKE IN OPPOSITION
BECAUSE I THINK- HISTORY HAS
PROVEN THAT- THAT THERE. IS A
CLEAR NEED FOR THIS MEASURE- WE
WOULD LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT-
JUSTICE IS BLIND- BUT IT'S NOT.
AND HISTORY HAS PROVEN THAT
THERE IS AN INCESTUOUS
RELATIONSHIP THAT HAS EXISTED
BETWEEN. LAW ENFORCEMENT AND DH
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF TIME.
MANY OF THOSE INVESTIGATORS WHO
WORK FOR THE DA ARE FORMER
POLICE OFFICERS. MANY OF WHOM
ARE FROM- FORMER MEMBERS OF THE
UNION TO PROVIDE US. AND TO SAY
THAT A CONFLICT OF INTEREST IS
DIFFERENT OUR OUR SHOULD BE
VIEWED AS THE SAME FOR STATE
LEGISLATOR VERSES EIGHT DA IS.
FAR FROM ACCURATE. WE HAVE A
GREAT RESPONSIBILITY AS
LEGISLATOR TO BE ON A LOCAL
STATE OR FEDERAL LEVEL TO SHAKE
LAW. BUT DA'S HAVE THE RIVER-
THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY. TO
AFFECT ONE'S LIFE FROM CRIMINAL
STANDPOINT- FROM THE BILLY TO
CHARGE AN INDIVIDUAL TO
PROSECUTE INDIVIDUAL AND TO
SENTENCE SOMEONE. TO LONG TERMS
IN PRISON AND WE AS LEGISLATORS
TO NOT HAVE THAT AUTHORITY. IT
HAS ALSO BEEN PROVEN TO VOTERS
INDIVIDUALS BOTH JUDGES. THAT
I'VE TALKED TO ALONG THE WAY
ONE WHICH WHO RESIGNED FROM THE
BENCH BECAUSE OF THE SEARCHERS
RELATIONSHIP HAT EXISTED
BETWEEN. D. A.'S ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT WORK HE COULD VERY
RARELY EVER SEE. A CHARGE EVER
BEING FOLLOWED BY A POLICE
OFFICER WHO HAD UNJUSTLY USE
FORCE OR KILLED SOMEONE. OR
TAMPERED WITH EVIDENCE OR- BOB
USED HE SHE'S. WHILE ON DUTY-
TO VERY WERE- EVERY CHARGE LET
PROSECUTING CONVICT. CASE IN
POINT OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
POLICE SHOOTINGS HAVE HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME. LESS THAN
TEN WERE PROSECUTED AND ONLY
ONE CONVICTED I DON'T CARE WHAT
PROFESSION YOU AND NO ONE GETS
IT RIGHT THAT MANY TIMES AND TO
SAY THAT. ONLY TEN FOR FOLKS
WERE WORTHY OF BEING PROSECUTED
CLEARLY SPEAKS VOLUMES TO THE
NEED. FOR THIS MEASURE AGAIN A
PROVIDES BETTER GOVERNMENT IT
PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY IT AND
PROTECTS. US CITIZENS AND
RESTORES CONFIDENCE THAT NO
LONGER EXIST HERE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER TO
MOVE THE BILL. THE MOTION. IN
THE PAST THE S. B. TWO SEVEN
TEN TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD ROAD PROVIDED SHOW
VOGUE. IN TROUBLED NINE COM
LAGER HI I'M LONGER AYE
SKINNER. WIENER WIENER AYE WILL
BE THE BILL OPEN FOR. ABSENT A-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL- WE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS. YEAH I WILL
PASS THE GAVEL BACK TO SET UP A.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
APPRECIATE. KANNSTHEROES
CONSULTING CAN YOU OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
WIENER. WIENER ONLINE. CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS FIVE THAT'S
CONSIDERED CALLER HAS BEEN
APPROVED. FIVE ZERO. AND WILL
YES WE'LL JUST WAIT MMENTARILY
FOR CENTER SKINNER TO RETURN
AND WE CAN CLOSE OUT THE
OUTSTANDING MEASURES.
I'LL JUST
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S PUBLIC TESTIMONY- AND
FOR WHATEVER REASON IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS.
AND SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING- TO
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD SO
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
APPRECIATION TODAY WE REALLY
GREATLY APPRECIATED AND WE WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
COOPERATION AND DAY BOTH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF.
AND WE HAVE CONCLUDED AUTHOR
GENDER FOR PUBLIC SAFETY- WELL
I'M JUST IM NOT FOR COMMITTED
UNDERSTAND I'M JUST THANKING
EVERYBODY RIGHT NOW SO. AND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WE WILL
MANAGER. CONSULTING PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE OUTSTANDING
ITEMS SB FIFTY SEVEN WIENER
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI THE BILL
IS FOUR TO ONE. THOSE OUT FOR
ONE. SB FIVE NINETEEN WIENER-
SKINNER ALL RIGHT SKINNER I'D
THE BILL IS FOUR TO ONE SB FIVE
NINETEEN OUT OF FIVE TO ONE. SB
SEVEN TEN BRADFORD SKINNER. HI
SKINNER I'D- PORTABLE AND-
FORTY ONE FORTY ONE MEASURES
OUT FOR THE ONE. I'M A STOKE
SPOKE AGAIN. THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN YOUR
COOPERATION WILL CONCLUDE
TODAY'S AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
STAND ADJOURNED.